[Music]
thank you
one two three one two three one two
three let's get it Mike check you know
all that my check and all that hear ye
hear ye Brown how's my level salad
what's going on out here
soft talk Sunday
now Zach Mullins what's going on let me
know how the levels is doing a little
mic check and all that live Supremacy
what's going on man Cheryl Mack the OG
was good Zach Riley yeah what's going on
what's going on sack shop normal people
not you know I'm saying regular people
Jago 6 in the building what's going on
how we doing we sounded good check check
yes thank you thank you very much Scotty
Z let's go Scotty
check it out 210 from the 210 my man's
chicken eye let's go Brick House harsh
what's going on pop now I see you Darth
Revan what's going on yeah man we got a
show for y'all today you know what I'm
saying oh it's a little chat Nintendo
league on Taco
um we got I hope Lord attic is doing
okay I want him to let him want to let
him know that we always here and we all
for real I just got off the phone with
Alex and my brother going through it you
know what I'm saying but we're gonna
give him a day off you know what I'm
saying let him get his mind right man we
got a lot going on man that's my brother
hope he's doing all right he said he
might just pop in and listen you know
what I'm saying I said go get your mind
right get your mind right if you need
mental health as well as well so thank
you for that
send our brother some love
okay
[Music]
Game Pass losing money Activision deals
CMA rejected damn we ain't got no good
news messing with R Kelly
oh Kelly out here he went down he's
putting fires out early you know what
I'm saying we gonna talk about it I'll
let cake deal with you later yo make
sure you fill up that cell phone brother
make sure you know saying phone time
phone time anyway Chris Jones what's
going on at Michael Jordan line that in
the building fix your face fix your face
let people write what they want to write
nah it's all up brother you already know
what's going on it's gonna be fun man
I'm looking forward to talking to y'all
has it and uh yeah we're gonna get the
legendary Ben Smith up in here have some
fun great topics we can talk to the
people today
Last Stand media oh it's crucial MJ's in
the building you in the gym you [__]
fixing up an article right now oh oh
okay
good to see you brother all right y'all
I'll see y'all in a minute let me go get
uh amazing guest
[Music]
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and sampling making
it flammable this is that this is that
Yoga Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up
in the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold y'all
I ain't heard the boy and you ain't
gotta say it I'm embarrassed for you I
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Voltron with and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just to Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
it regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social but
I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social
knowing my city but I'm still by Coastal
I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Fred and Kruger that's
who
let's do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns uses the target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when he was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with and I'm going places better
tell an Uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still
bi-coaster
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny word to
cry Neato who cares if he fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
nothing but really be Stevo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if he really was that joke
King David still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord day
[Music]
radio radio
mike check and all that song let's hear
your glorious voice real quick
hello I'm back here there we go there we
go smooth is back and back move is back
no doubt my check let's get the mirror
real quick look at the mic check for the
man real quick hello and greetings yes
yes greetings and salutations
okay let's get a bike check back
yo Mutiny
yo okay
yeah this is not gonna be a soft talk
Sunday oh he ready
he ready that's what I want to hear what
color is this song
out there is looking kind of shaky
okay oh man Kool-Aid heart dude oh man
we gotta stop
and welcome to the iron Lords podcast
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number
303. let's move that's that's hard
that's hard and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the round table on
the Lord's day I'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
red Fall reviews aftermath
Phil Spence is kind of funny interview
PlayStation data on 70 games and Sony
shuts down pixel Opus to discuss what's
he laughing so we are gonna get right
into it I want to introduce the Lord
who's plethora of talents not only
extend beyond his production of video
game podcasts but his only rivaled by
his pure passion for technical game
design Innovative game reviews with
hilarious sarcasm
introducing the associate producer at
Last Air media and Lily Mo games and the
host of the Ben is handsome handsome
YouTube and twitch channels
the Lord of sea of Thieves and spoiler
casts legit former mayor of Butler PA
with the most handsome Phantom in the
game
live from PA and finally making his
debut into the realm of the Lords my man
Lord Betty Smith how we doing sir what's
up gentlemen how's it going happy to be
here thank you very much appreciate it
for the amazing intro as always Kyle you
just you rock those intros appreciate it
we really do man appreciate it man we
got a lot of respect for that we got to
get your hype upping around man you're a
lord at what you do you're a lord of
production a lord of spoiler cast and
things you do what you been playing man
anything other than sea of Thieves been
played yeah although uh I haven't I mean
I have been playing more sea of Thieves
than I had in like the last year but no
this um this week I reviewed uh a raven
lock a little uh Little Indie joint from
cocoa cucumber yes good game
um put a review out on that I thought
you guys had one up too
um and uh yeah I just thought it was I
don't know how in depth you want to go
but I just I thought it was a fun little
romp it's not gonna change your life but
if you're looking for like something fun
for six hours or you got some kids or
nieces or nephews or whatever and
they're over like it's a great game for
an introductory like action RPG for sure
yeah
um yeah so that's uh that was the
majority of the last week for me
um other than like you know
live service games that certain lab
service game that you've been around a
couple other live service games too but
yeah yeah no doubt man salute you first
of all love this setup as we talk to the
pre-show setup it's glorious King I'm
kind of feeling it right like you know
yeah I got that real Xbox
oh you like the color scheme oh that's
what this is we over here respects that
all right well I'll just have to change
you know what it was you started off
with Instinct that that's it I did no
that's what I specifically did I said if
I got blue in here all king's gonna see
is that Playstation sign behind me
because I got green he's gonna see the
Xbox sign right so I gotta I gotta do
the green you know
I'm nosy what's that in the upper what
is that what is it left look like an
accident
up here yeah yeah
but I was like
sure okay now that's the Seinfeld Lego
set I just have to put that up there
no doubt no doubt and you already know
we got the four well we don't have the
four man gets sent some love King yes
yes
sometimes I'm not allowed to say love in
the room ironically sense of Love yeah
says a lot to my brother attic man going
through it obviously you know y'all know
the details if you check his uh Twitter
post you know it's going through a
little relationship situation and um I
want to send a love to him by the way
that's not easy and I spoke to him a
couple times he was gonna try to pull
through we both agree like look take as
much time as you need so he may baby
listen he may be Provident in the chat
but I'm hoping he's taking care of
himself and salute to my bro he will be
back whenever he's ready to be back and
we gotta we'll hold him down and then of
course we have returning lose one Lord
get enough uh most technical gaming Lord
the solo game who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also
that's ostradamus the Lord of clarity
and Lord patreon of the the iron bank my
man PC Master race and returning Lord
sorry how are we doing sir I'm good man
very good happy to be back uh you know I
just want to say yeah man I just want to
say thank you of course to you guys my
brothers for holding me down uh you know
and uh and thank everyone for the well
wishes uh over the course of the week
everybody who jumped into DMS and said
you know wish me and my family well I
appreciate that joystick
[Laughter]
but thank you very much I appreciate it
you know um yeah I was talking to Kyle
and King about the fact that you know
this situation with the passing of my
uncle it made me realize that you know
when it comes to situations dealing with
family in Puerto Rico it's gonna be me
that deals with it right and it's like
which is kind of the first time that
really hit me
um but all in all I have to say it was
it was beautiful kind of the entire
everything that that happened around you
know
uh just putting him to rest
um was was kind of beautiful because
it's a small town over there and he's
you know a very sort of devout Christian
and very dedicated to the community and
the church and you know the day that we
you know went to bury him you know you
have the processional that goes from the
funeral parlor to the cemetery and it's
cool because you see all the cars you
know in the small town going through the
town you have the police escort
um and literally people on the street
especially the older you know older
people stop and to pay their respects in
the street as it's going by you know and
obviously many of those people know who
it is that's being buried so that's even
that makes it even more sort of special
and then um you know my my uncle was
also like a very talented musician so uh
played the guitar and loved to sing so
when we got to the cemetery he was sort
of serenaded on the way to his tomb by
by you know three guys from the church
as well singing some of his favorite
songs again it was a beautiful thing it
was a beautiful thing so I was glad to
you know to be there and represent
education of the family so again thank
you guys I appreciate all the well
wishes there's the head now now you know
that's the heaviest yeah the first born
yep yeah absolutely absolutely I mean
you've had that talk you know I mean
when the responsibilities Falls it falls
on us as that entity to kind of be the
the single point of contact for the
entire family and representative so to
speak exactly exactly so yeah so have
you got a chance to play Eddie I figured
you've been busy bro so uh I I played a
little bit of stuff on Steam deck while
I was there because I was you know the
late nights you know get back from from
family stuff and then you know all of my
fast able to my godparents and then with
my in-laws for a day
um and they you know they're in bed you
know 9 30 10 o'clock their events
yes I'm in the room trying to get a
little bit of game again just to sort of
you know just detach my mind from
everything so I did that and then upon
coming back
um through on redfall for a little bit
through one
through on Jedi uh you know Survivor for
a little bit thank you yeah yeah yeah
man um so yeah we'll talk
dirty all the way around
this is a good thing this is the good
thing about I have to say the 40 90
coupled with like the the the I9 yeah it
Brute Force yeah
you know forced past a lot of that stuff
the Lamborghini with the twin turbo man
he said thank God I spent
so yeah and then funny on on the PC
redfall looked pretty nice ran well oh
it's crazy but what crashed on me
multiple times
word to the wise don't pause the game
for more than a minute because you will
come back to a black screen
you go oh no
no times
so that we'll talk more in depth about
that
um what else what else oh yeah and so in
in other news in other news my TV calmed
out oh no in the year that I absolutely
did not want to purchase a new
television which one
no I see no I never upgraded I still
have my KS 8000 my Samsung
still holding it down and it didn't have
any you know 120 FPS into that but the
ks 8000 when it came out in 2016. it was
that TV it was that TV it was still
holding it down color wise it was a
fantastic TV and I'm like I gotta hold
my head I just spent all this money on
this PC I just made this trip
yeah
the purchase has already been made so I
so I said you know what I'm not I'm not
going no no no I'm not going to buy the
interim TV right because I'm gonna be
mad at myself that I spent oh let me
spend a thousand dollars just for
something
that that I don't really want right
right so I just I bit the bullet what
you doing
it's a 65-inch s95c Samsung oh you did
oh
man man oh man oh man so uh I'm having
it I don't I don't I don't have the time
to sit down with my Spears and muscle
and yeah you're annoying with your
videos
so bad he's he's like you I mean yeah
when you're talking about
I don't know man I don't know you got
that seven thousand dollar rig over
there
got a crazy new TV I'm sitting over here
with my 30 series card wondering why
redfall won't go above I don't know
yeah
I don't know man
there'll be no more purchases for me the
rest of the year that is for sure like I
said I went ahead and just I just got
the 65 inch in addition to that I didn't
want to be bothered with sitting there
trying to calibrate it so I paid for the
professional calibration so it'll be
I'll have it I'll have it in about 10
days
um
and so I was like um are you gonna spend
500 on me
like yo cause the dude come over and
look movie quality he said I can do this
guy you know I never said I gotta say
this like this old school IOP uh you
used to annoy me so I go for because
like yeah what I used to hate her he's
such a video foul and perfectionist with
it Ben that like me and king would be in
awe of the soap opera movie effect but
we used to call it we used to call it
real life in the Box
yo this looks crazy and solver come over
with the disgust it's just not accurate
representation of the thing and he'd be
like you gotta change and take this I
used to be so bad when he come over yeah
it's so funny so we went we go to um
King's house when he just got the uh the
3D TV right he had bought like eight
pairs of 3D glasses for the family and I
go in I'm like I'm excited to see it
writing Coggins as well so we go
upstairs and he puts on Aeon Flux with
Charlene's Charlie staring because the
colors really pop the blacks really pop
so
he has it he has it and soap opera mode
right and I'm looking at it and he's in
awe he's like oh my God
you're right I feel like I'm there like
like Charlize is in my living room and
[__] is the same way so I'm like oh yeah
man yeah this is awesome so we leave
because again I'm not gonna disrespect
I'm going to my man's house he just
spent all this money on this TV I'm not
gonna disrespect
and so I get outside and Cog is like
what you what do you think
it's not supposed to look there
so that that has always been my energy
uh I just ever ever since I paid the
first time it's funny because I was the
one that got shame for having the cheap
TV right shout out to that right so so
once you want the first thing it's like
one time it took one time for me to be
shamed and then after that I was like
I'm getting the best TV out of anybody
absolutely yeah it was relentless on you
no no they killed me they killed me that
day so uh yeah so I went ahead and did
this um I'm excited but pissed at the
same time but I think I would have been
more angry with myself if I got
something just to sort of yeah you know
exactly exactly let's go for Paris
that is it's happy to be back good to
have you back we missed you we miss you
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how
well happy Cinco de Mayo for everybody
you know passing over here
uh Canelo Mighty Man 44 yeah he fought
yesterday you didn't see me do a combat
talking with the Zone crap
we Banning this home we're not we know
we don't come I'm not supporting the
Zone they put on crap shows it's not
working money you're viewing time we
boycott I forgot yeah you know um queno
told me don't even talk about it today
wow yeah
it was just it's disheartening because
uh next week or the week after we have
Devin Haney versus lomachenko just had
um tank versus Garcia you know we're
having great fights going through and
this guy continues to duck and fight
these whack dudes
yeah then I need to be in the ring with
you yesterday and
it's evident that you win 12 rounds with
this dude man like you
you gonna mess around and lose to a NFL
guy you have to go but you did you you
fought bivo
you made every excuse in the world
like a character yeah like he's like
he's like he's the fifth building
that girl is
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
none me
probably had a couple of crashes it
ain't a good game I'm not gonna lie but
at the same time I spent seven thousand
oh we're not doing it
love your consoles we love you 500 it's
a good price tag you see these PC dudes
they be talking about master race new
boy yeah we get we get we getting the
show that in the stick lately yeah
lately the PC ports have been alive
like you should be
don't get don't get mad because your
glasses don't go past 30 FPS that's all
right listen listen we have no problem
with this but seven thousand dollars I
don't need that frame sunglasses capped
at 30.
[Laughter]
I believe it's not PS5 oh you selected
video oh you selected with it that's
right that's right anyway so I was
playing fortnite yesterday you know May
4th came up and they had all the Star
Wars stuff there so right now you got um
a little bit of Titanfall still still
there and then you have uh um Star Wars
yeah Anakin that's uh available Padme
but they have this little uh extra
season pass it's like a season pass plus
you pay a thousand V bucks for it it's
probably like three dollars and um I get
Darth Maul oh you got to do all these
quests so across the world you know um
Darth Maul not not Darth Maul Anakin and
pop-up uh yeah Darth Mauler pop up okay
uh like Holograms Kenobi and you can go
talk to them and they can teach you ways
of the Fall so you go inside this like
this Dimension you are you supposed to
be there when you come out uh it's it's
so much fun that they can just drop in a
little stuff like that and then you can
show your fandom by running around with
the characters on you know May 4th it
was so many people running around with
Star Wars characters that was fun I'm
playing Lou payroll I'm strangely
addicted to this Wild game me too Hero's
amazing man it is
ugliest game in the world most addictive
beautiful game at the same time
absolutely nuts it's it's one of those
you know for me I would have never paid
for it ever I don't care what
recommendation it was but then there's
something in Game Pass that I went in
there and I was like okay people's
talking about it let me see what it's
about it is everything is cracked up to
be so I was playing that I reviewed that
back in the day and I didn't review it I
just captured footage for it and I kept
so I captured some footage and I was
like wow this I mean I don't know he's
gonna review this but why would anybody
ever play this game and then the other
day I just was like vibing at night just
not ready to go to bed but you know
still wanted to do something was
watching the twitch stream or something
I pulled it up and I was like
I am never stopping playing this game
ever did you get caught up with that one
more Loop oh yeah absolutely always just
one more Loop just one more loop it's
it's the most addictive game going right
now but that's about it that's what I'm
playing right now I really didn't have a
chance to play a lot of stuff today oh
so Guardians of the Galaxy that's right
yes
with the Lord's Tuesday at 5 p.m well 4
30 because we have a new Time new time
is at uh 4 30 okay oh
this is the best Marvel movie
in years not just phase four well listen
it's way better than anything the face
will ever thought about um if you were
waiting for Marvel to show up
forget that Ant-Man and all that other
crap that came out before that this is
the movie James Dunn left on a high note
uh he left the series the series
actually is probably the best series
from the first one to the third one that
Marvel has okay it's probably the best
you can look at some of the series and
like like Iron Man or Thor you like you
didn't like Thor dark World or some
dudes didn't like love and thunder or
whatever it is always a point of
contention with one movie out of Trilogy
yeah you could make that argument I mean
cap cap got something to say because
technically is it civil war party that
first movie is right yeah I put you
there I wish you there but Witcher
Soldier was yeah winter associate but
that's what I'm talking about that's
what you say like they got that one wow
it was consistent and the only thing I
can say that is uh truly consistent with
it besides the the um the actors
is the director
and it just gives me hope knowing that
he's going over to the WB and what he
did with a uh franchise that nobody
cared about nobody nobody knew anything
about Guardians of the Galaxy and
everybody that now I love Groot
they brought it the law of frauds
please this movie has so many references
to your childhood and everything and
Beyond it is something that you need to
go see it's very good very good movie I
recommend my own doubt and of course we
have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading that
realness in the running IOP not telling
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear shout out to Mr Maddie play
Shout out to Friday dude had a good one
little little red full therapy session
I'll go check that out and I haven't
listened yet I need to listen shout out
to Ben for editing that one
a lot of thoughts a lot of a lot of
emotion you know what I'm saying we good
we good we got through it and then uh
shout out to my man on Ty guy Travis
shout out to eat bantus the last word we
have my manual Destro up in there talk
about Guardian Games everything that's
going on with Destiny right now seasonal
update the new season that's coming a
lot of exciting changes as far as gaming
for me Jedi Survivor a little bit but I
had to do a lot of travel this week so
shout out to CD project I want to get
them their flowers
because I was as a kid and solved those
um you know for me I had a friend of
mine had to do like a procedure so I was
like all right let me go up Connecticut
so I'm not gonna be able to game on the
console so basically I started cyberpunk
I was playing a little bit on um series
X
played that and then boom Cloud Save
Right which CD project has then from
there I get to my manuscript like he
ain't got no you know what you call
console so I bought the laptop I had the
30 70 joint boom continue
Cloud say right boom then got to go to
the hospital all right we gotta take you
in the morning
appointment they're gonna put you on I'm
gonna be in the waiting room got the
same deck fired up Cloud safe I'm like
this is what I'm talking about like this
I just want everyone to get to this
point and it seems like CD project has
kind of set off the movement with that
and I just love the idea of just
continuing it on these three different
platforms and everything was there my
data was there I'm doing my things I've
been rocking that and then I did a
little bit of Destiny guarding games but
that's pretty much it for me but I saw
if you want to get the super chest now
because we got something yeah we got
some funny things
yeah yeah absolutely oh and also
completely if you forgot shout out to to
everybody over in the shop podcast I was
with them last night I almost forgot
that I was going to be on and I came
back from the movies I was like oh what
am I gonna have for dinner and I'm like
and then I see the and I see the pop-up
and I'm like oh no
shout out to blam shout out to pong
shout out to fuzzy and then Retreat from
Game Pass Daily was there um cool time
yeah to hang out with my Bros that was
that is my first uh podcast appearance
outside of IOP that was the first
podcast that invited me yeah it was how
many years has it been oh no it's it has
been a couple years but that was the
first podcast that invited me on after I
joined IOP so it was it was good to come
back for the 301st episode the fact that
they've been around so long so yeah
shout out to my Bros over there it was a
good time no doubt um yeah let's get
into these super chats
somebody in the chat was like Hey stops
back the super chat's gonna be good yeah
yeah last week so what um
all right we got Robert kellett two
dollars Super Chat gonna melt that Xbox
chain King damn I gotta melt it down you
gotta melt it down oh man what
um
I will melt it down for a snitch whistle
for you wow
oh oh then we have a
yeah
Huckleberry Finn whoa whoa
first time listener my wife's boyfriend
recommended the sooner so I know it's
gonna be good he has excellent taste
shout out to cuckleberry Finn yo what is
going on I actively named sir wow that
was the difference a very good Super
Chat yeah that was creative that was
creative wow all right all right welcome
back Sauce
Robert Kelly once again so I'm
struggling with troubleshoot gaming no
not me like I said the Beast powered
through
the only game is actually struggles with
the Spider-Man for some reason he was
eighty percent of his CPU power
yeah there you go live
um that we have Marvin ginyard two
dollar Super Chat this week's saving the
midwestern Albion humpback
Which rare when we hit the like button
Which rare animal are we saving kids I
guess it's the midwestern Albion I'm
back I
wanna go with the Siberian Bandicoot
I can't
[Music]
and we have Mexican Zoidberg remember
for two years twenty dollar Super Chat
the Xenoblade 3 DLC is the highest rated
game on Metacritic this year that's not
and that that's not a remake Fire Emblem
and Advanced Wars was fire two and Game
of the Year comes out this week Nintendo
mopping all y'all fools with the Tegra
X1 chip I ain't even going live bro it's
crazy ah we'll see we'll see then we got
Mexican Zoidberg once again remember for
27 months so more than two years or
bronze put respect on Lord shiggy
hashtag real market leader hashtag
switch gang outside hashtag switch
coming in okay it's day back I love when
they show up and they show up every
three years when they drop a game when
they drop us out there or Mario
then we have four as a legend member for
40 months Lord bronze solve that s95c is
the truth on God yes I'm know I know
also shoot out shout out to all the real
Xbox dudes staying true and don't buck
up under pressure oh that's Xbox King
salute okay got you my guy don't you
worry
they bucking up oh man I've seen a lot
of dudes acting real strange
if you wonder why I no longer follow you
I'm unfollowing you when you go at the
captain bruh sorry yeah I pick a side in
the war and you understand what side I'm
on
we had War people
and as a five-star general three stripes
ain't no way in hell am I gonna back
down I got you guys later though I can't
wait continue and we have zip Davis five
dollar Super Chat Nick's lost and I
don't feel too good myself but I still
got a big yeah yeah yeah but I still got
a big ooh
in me for the Lord's day
[Music]
let's go Mr meeseeks look at me
then we got Cedric H member for 34
months Lord Silva thank you brother we
have project Aries new member five
dollar Super Chat the officer coming for
Lord king's crown protect your neck I'm
only a messenger games don't matter
hashtag Game Pass hashtag Bill Spencer
hashtag I don't know how to comprehend
hashtag I don't know how to listen
hashtag I have an agenda
damn damn
bro I'm gonna tell you right now it's
like you had that memorized yeah it's
like he was too quick with that
spin the block no Ops get this stop it
continue kill it once again two dollars
to protect King frauden on Jedi in
midfall working well no he didn't fraud
on Jedi gave it to his love he said I'm
fraud and you playing on a PlayStation
5. I heard about you oh man about you be
just because your stuff is acting up
over there don't mean our stuff is
acting up over here
go try the quick resume
messy moving on Nintendo Taco chat 30 60
120 165 none of that matters because we
will all be playing tears of the Kingdom
at 25 FPS
that was good that was good
he ain't wrong he's not wrong switch
coming in huh
then we have zip Davis once again five
dollar Super Chat King should
PlayStation and Xbox fans do a big BBQ
as a peace offering or are we going to
war we'll be the only people bringing in
the food and stuff PlayStation gonna sit
there and mooch you know they broke
that's why they got that console for a
hundred dollars less
on
oh my God be too much today
all right hold on a second because we
got a couple of that's your former masks
okay
if you want
your favorite rapper back
damn
approve the deal
oh it's like that it's like that okay
y'all want to snitch we go up in the
streets
damn got the Hobie hostage all right
csws gaming remember for one month Lord
gold happy Lord's Day y'all stay blessed
Raven lock is dope yeah it looks pretty
mad I'm gonna try that game out
definitely wasn't it from the people
that did the other RPG that was on Xbox
I don't I don't know what they made
before no Generations yeah oh was it
them okay yeah Echo generation
and we have Bounty remember for 21
months Lord Brown enough respect I'll
peacock thanks for inviting me and my
friends to the D Clan hold up let's
elaborate on it don't you do that
don't you do that
we need to elaborate on what that D is
uh don't
[Music]
it's a different Jackson
yo that was wild
give you five dollars looking so good
for following a perfect perfect
follow-up and they looking so good for
Xbox we all know Starfield gonna be a
flop too okay
Nintendo guy now at least they putting
out something
snitching and stuff
if you want to get out early
that that joke last week about Kell's
favorite color being yellow was good
that was fast fire fire that was fire
because then we have Max arthy with the
five pound super chat please install the
latest drivers to see this super chat
about to show me your bill PC Master Ray
slander today I see see what's going on
we are Kelly two dollars with that
non-stop you gotta read my first check
what was the first one I just read one
is there another one before this one all
right hopefully if I missed that he's
super chat
no Carol's time is limited behind her
yes all right tell us if I miss one
please just put it as a regular chat and
I'll read it because I owe somebody back
for song so here we go and we got Tyson
Lewis 20 Super Chat top of the day to
y'all King Haney versus Iron what's this
and Wilder versus Joshua who y'all got
and no worries Phil's still Maximus just
missing the Meridius okay we don't do
that
um but okay so respect on your name um I
I'm gonna do something controversial
here
uh Devin Haney will beat lomachenko but
if it goes to decision they're going to
give Logan Shaker to fight uh and and
y'all can say is that's gonna be a
robbery uh Wilder versus Joshua Wilder's
gonna K on him in one round oh they
fighting actually they're supposed to
fight in December okay whenever Wilder
touches his forehead he's so [__]
yeah that's sad but it's true yeah yeah
we have hargit Chaney five dollar Super
Chat salute Lawrence anyone pre-ordering
The Rock Ally this week probably Cog
yeah
or the Rog Ally Phil dominance called it
the rock he's on the right side he's on
the right side of History oh I noticed
that huh all right
there I was like wait a minute that's
not a switch Yeah he was name dropping a
lot of stuff too yeah yeah oh yeah game
of the year coming out this Friday tears
of the Kingdom break out your switch or
your PC emulator yeah so I saw a lot of
picks out there and Reggie out in the
streets and regulating people finish the
game already yeah it's crazy
I don't support that I support you know
after you purchase the game if you want
to go do whatever you want yeah that's a
backup uh thing
wow no no no no
let's go ah let's play with each other's
joysticks five dollar Super Chat hey
stop boo-boo glad to see you're back I
enjoyed red fall because there was a lot
of [__] and slurping wow
maybe we can couch Co-op song I'm
thinking that but I appreciate it I
appreciate your donations thank you I'm
not gonna bite back you're not gonna
bite back
I deserve that one I deserve that
wow suck it in wow that's different
any day play with your joysticks can I
be in the D Clan please
trying to Super Chat before redfall
topic I agree with the reviews it is
broken but full disclosure I gave it a
chance and it actually grew on me it got
fun my wife was engaged watching me play
she said it looked really fun
like fungus maybe once you get later in
the game like stuff actually happens
[Music]
we have Hector the Macho Man
King give me the word and I'll grab
Sackboy
they put hits out on all the mascots
are getting it you said you seen you you
caught Sackboy on Fifth and Third
I throw them in the trunk man bring them
around
we snatching up all icons Kratos you
next I did continue that's it we're a
quarter all right cool now I know we got
one more bit of business
and you know the patient but uh yeah it
is that time of the month that long neck
that Lords of gaming.net time of the
month we here at log that are very proud
of the tremendous talent that we have
put together the enchant of the entire
team we are out here breaking records
y'all personal records personal
Milestones the opinion pieces the
walkthroughs the guys the reviews have
all been huge congrats to the team you
know what I'm saying and uh just really
quickly just wanted to address something
before I get it to the award is that you
know we at long net do not like
suppressing opinion and as long as the
opinion is backed by claims and and
provided you know the proper sourcing
we're fine you know so I just want to be
clear that again the severe the opinions
of what do not reflect the opinions of
all and let's be respectful you know say
that's the other thing because I know
some things happen this weekend people
might have been upset but we support it
at the end of the day you know we're all
different voices and one thing we're not
going to do is stifle voices so
yo like bro like it's a website where
it's a ton of us all of us all are
opinionated we all have different you
know I'm saying perspectives on things
and that's the beauty of log that to not
solid statement just want to address
that but now it's time for that uh
subscribe of the month man one
particular scribe that went above and
beyond last month and um always takes us
all these unique comic Adventures always
consistent with the uh the wiki
Adventure articles they're absolutely
hilarious shout out to I still like the
Plastic Man and the Iceman one is live
shout out to ice baby but the Plastic
Man what I really like and then also
contributed a fantastic Sherlock Holmes
awakened review so proudly want to
present the Scribe of the month Lord
dizzy scribe of the month to my man Lord
David shallard and of Lord fromage
hopefully hopefully I'm pronouncing it
correctly please correct
give me the correct pronunciation sir
yes
congratulations brother speech man
you're killing it
oh okay uh well so putting the thing
about
um controversial opinions right before
mine I think it's really appropriate I
really really made some enemies out
there with my takes on taser face so wow
but I think really if you think about it
just remember kick punch
it's all in the mind yes yes yes yes all
the devices now you kill him I love what
you love it that's hilarious
cat he got he dropped the subliminal
that was Ill that was Ill salute
PlayStation fans didn't understand it
yeah don't do that
no I salute to you brother we love the
flavor that you bring to the side you're
absolutely hilarious you're human you're
right style keep up the good work make
sure you hit solve affiliate the rewards
on the other day
and I will take care of your brother but
again yeah yeah well we'll see yeah
we'll see he hasn't gotten his last one
yeah wow yo G spring man what's going on
listen man I got we we're gonna have to
send the goons over here I can tell them
what to order and they get there yeah
there's certain things that they have on
Deck already yeah don't buck up on me
all your merch
yo I got Calvin working over there so
we're looking okay
turn that out right now yeah shout out
to Lord for March killing it Lord to
gaming.net scribe of the month salute
sir thank you so much for your time yeah
absolutely killing it thanks so much no
doubt and then also you know we got that
secondary award you know I mean shout
out to my brother Lord dizzy rest in
peace again from the editorial the real
behind the scenes the nurturers of
talent people that put in that work and
this guy you know he continues to amaze
me just that calming hand that that Sage
wisdom you know what I'm saying behind
the scene and and pretty much a father
figure to all of the writers that come
on and onboarding but he's also an
exceptional writer himself man really
kills it you know I love this straight
likes reviews he he uh basically covered
my rug Ally Ai and all its Glory had the
images looking right everything looking
crispy right now for the steam that
killer but um
but I'm not salute to him man he's
really he's breaking news there's really
no style of article he can't do so I
want to proudly present the Lord dizzy
scribe the actually Lord editor of the
month my man Blackboard what's going on
brother appreciate it appreciate
appreciate it yeah it's been uh it's
been it's been a great ride for all
these years but I gotta say the last 24
hours are really special
yeah yeah it was it's pretty spicy but
you know it's a good learning experience
and hopefully it gets a good exposure
for log knit and of course if anyone
wants to join log that hit us up on the
application well it will get you sorted
yeah
yeah go hit my mans up he gonna set you
up right you know what I'm saying live
for the brain in the building but nah
brother appreciate your work as always
the consistency everything's great and
uh you're gonna be coming back right
yeah
absolutely yeah yeah we got some steaks
and so I've got sucking this
but now that we finish with the Lord's
plan in the business we gotta switch our
Focus to Lord Ben Smith his video game
system history his journey into content
creation and podcast production and of
course what led him to joining the
amazing Last Stand media and also being
an associate producer at Lily Mo games a
little bit let's start from the very
beginning what's up in the first video
game system chat and what got you into
gaming
I think the first uh system I ever
played was the the NES uh my dad had it
probably when he was you know he I was
uh my parents were pretty young when I
was born so he had it like in high
school and and it stuck around and I
played it one of my earliest memories
was playing uh Super Mario I can't
remember which one for sure but I was
like I know I was like carrying around a
sippy cup at like
playing with my cousin Brad and uh
that's probably one of my earliest
memories but yeah going up through I um
I had a Super Nintendo eventually uh had
a um uh definitely had had the original
PlayStation okay got that for Christmas
one year had the original Xbox I mean
honestly at some point in the life
cycles I think I've had every system
every like major console except for the
Wii U okay never had a Wii uh but yeah I
pretty much I mean I've I've been
playing games since like literally I can
remember and
have played pretty much every system the
Dreamcast is one I got but not till like
after it was already sunseted gotcha
gotcha yeah yeah I got that like you're
you know a couple years later but before
everybody pretended like they liked it
yeah yeah
it was like a hand-me-down kind of the
heavy danger so yeah so what okay I just
been playing on on every system you know
that that I could get my hands on since
I had hands I guess the question for me
that usually being King ass is like you
know usually most of us are kind of like
introduced to consoles or systems from
someone else but like what was like the
one that you kind of bought with like
Euro money that was like you felt was
like yours yeah I think
so technically I think the Super
Nintendo was the first console I bought
that was mine but I was really young
when the Super Nintendo came out
so I don't know where I got that money
you don't know how you
were
the first one
situation in here
but like purchasing but I think I don't
know I'd probably say the Xbox was the
first one I ever definitely paid for
with like money I earned that I know for
sure
you know I mean listen he does it
innately it's fine
the background okay
okay so you take it around with there
and then any any standout games for you
from that from the Xbox that you you
know really gravitate maybe I'm assuming
Halo but you know or something else yeah
yeah oh I definitely bought it for Halo
I mean that's definitely the original
for me
um but I've always been somebody who
if there was a game out and I could
afford it I bought it I don't do that
anymore because I'm like I have a family
now
but yeah I've always just been somebody
who plays everything that I that looks
somewhat appealing to me that I get my
hands on and I've always been you know
whatever console it's on if I own the
console I'm like I'm gonna play it if I
really want to play it bad enough I'm
gonna buy the console if I don't already
have it so yeah I've just always been
somebody who wants to play games it
doesn't it doesn't matter to me where
they are what they are if it looks cool
I'm gonna give it a shot unless I hear
it's trash and then I might still try it
he's doing it no doubt yeah so I guess
what about I had a question what about
um any of the Obscure what we consider
like the not the Super main streams but
like the turbo Graphics is the 3dos did
any of those kind of sneak in and also
handhelds yeah no the the turbo graphics
and the 3DS I wasn't I wasn't bored when
those came out just sorry yeah
I mean I I have
I have old systems like I have an Atari
uh I have a turbo Graphics but I got
those you know I was like 25. I they
weren't like you know things that I I
had as a kid or grew up with or anything
I've gotten into them but admittedly
like it one struggle for me has always
been like going back and playing
something old when there's something new
to play yeah I've played
games from like all generations since
I've been aware of gaming but to go back
even further I'm like oh I want to pop
this in as a sad to say almost like it's
a novelty for me and then I'm gonna move
on it's not gonna be like my super
Pastime or anything and sometimes I even
find myself like having having an issue
like oh this game came out six months
ago but I have this brand new game yep
uh I'm probably not gonna play that game
that came out six months ago even though
I really want to yeah because there's a
new game not a fan not a feeling that
backlog is crazy and then it's kind of
getting to that squirrel mentality hot
thing you know what I'm saying I gotta
play it I salute to you man kind of
rocking and rolling with with most of
the major consoles and then again you
just stayed consistent from every
generation I'm assuming you know it's an
Xbox 360 PS3 you just continued on and
then as far as the Nintendo I was gonna
ask you about Nintendo as far as the um
I know you said you didn't do it with
you did you do you did the Wii yeah and
um I wanted to ask also about the N64
any standings there okay yeah I've
actually still got my N64 plugged in um
the kids rocket I got a seven and nine
year old boys uh they still rock it
um and my my kids got like his switch
sitting right next to the 64 and about
a third of the time he'll still go to
the N64 over the switch so like I'm
proud of that I'm proud of that
fostering that you know that love there
so yeah but I uh yeah I'd say that
probably the N64 is my favorite console
but when you asked me to quantify why
that is I'm like look at the games and
I'm like well there's some good ones but
I think it's just Nostalgia for like
that's like that for me that was like
that developmental period I played so
many games with my friends which you
know you can get four of you oh yeah
like the built-in tat like I love that
about 64. yeah for sure so I think
that's probably like my favorite console
of all time but
if I had to re like if you're asking me
to return to a console right now I don't
know if it'd be the 64 or not just
depending on the day so yeah
can you get any questions before we move
on from the uh game talk no
um he was very diverse yeah win on
anything and I would have asked him if
he picked up the Xbox
um on launch but I I doubt that so I
think he built a library up and you know
got a library when he picked it up like
you know Halo whatever was playing with
his friends so it's really not too much
to go from there because he's had
everything yeah yeah he didn't lock
himself down to one ecosystem you know
yeah I I did pick up the the Xbox at
launch oh but I didn't pick up the 360
at launch not because I didn't want to
because I was a broke college student
shout out to the broken game out so yeah
so you picked up the
um the Xbox at launched did you try Halo
before you brought it by at one of the
kiosks in the store no oh rip word them
out just all my buddies were getting it
like yeah that's that's why I got it I
mean everybody else was getting it and I
was like well I gotta I gotta try it and
I I had like income at the time and I
was like well I have income but like
I don't have any bills so I'm buying an
Xbox you know obviously I love the
priorities that's right yeah I love that
I love that you got an extra 200 yeah
200 I have ramen in the cupboard yeah
these next couple bucks I need to take
the bus I could jog
hi guys
salute salute that's already uh game
talk before we move on yeah no I just
love the fact that for a lot of us it's
it's not necessarily like the objective
great console although we realize it 360
a PS2 whatever but it is the ones that
we have the best experiences with like
if you look at the N64 for us I mean
that's a huge deal because it was just
wrestling all the time right we had our
experiences with our Marios and and even
like GoldenEye we didn't play that much
golden eye we did we played some but it
was really the wrestling games for us
and that that's just going to be a
special moment so for me personally like
I I love the Sega Saturn which is
objectively a bad console but my
experience with it and how I engage with
it makes it my favorite so yeah it's
it's just it's just the experiences like
objectively there's certain things that
people consider to be great but when it
comes down to it is what I remember
about how I engage with those games with
those consoles because you and I with
the Saturn we make it to the next level
the next level we were always you know
we were always at you know at JNL
Penguin Village
ram car exactly getting all the import
games where Japan the Japan was lit for
that Sega Saturn but here nah nah it
wasn't a joke man I'd love to see it
that first game in history so I want to
switch gears a little bit get into
content Creation with no abandon as far
as like you know what inspires you to
kind of embark on that journey and then
I think some handsome Phantom origin
stories I need that yeah so my original
foray into content creation as usual
eloquently put it
um I think I'm trying to remember the
order of things here but I think in 2009
my buddy and I were like well let's um
we should DJ and then we just started
hanging out all the time wait wait DJ
Ben Smith on the ones
wait wait DJ you can't just gloss over
that break that down when I talk to
people and I'm like oh yeah I did you
know I was doing this they're like wait
hold up
all right so what was your DJ name the
hell with this what was your DJ me our
company name which I didn't come up with
but I liked it was uh valongo live we
weren't like I wasn't like a DJ yeah we
DJ that some clubs but we were like a um
you know we'll do high school dances
right DJ Kate finesse
let's go
[Laughter]
like Ben was it more like okay you said
you weren't actually an actual DJ but
were you like were you in there
scratching and mixing records or was it
just going it's on the song you know
later on I started actually mixing some
beats and stuff and I remember one night
we were at this little hole in the wall
dive bar with like a bunch of redneck
drunk women and I just started mixing
multiple songs into each other like it
was one of the first times after we'd
been because it was mostly like oh we
play a high school dance and they want
to hear you know whatever the top four
top 40 joins me yeah we just hit the
next button on iTunes and we got it but
I thought we finally get started getting
some software and some some actual real
equipment okay and uh I I started mixing
songs you know matched up bpms and ease
my buddy looks my buddy looks over at me
and he goes
what'd you just do everybody started
dancing and I was like I'm just playing
what feels right and he's like do it
again I was like okay so yeah we we
didn't do it for too long because we got
into other stuff and then uh we you know
we so we started doing a gaming podcast
okay which then turned into a Gaming
website which then turned into like it
wasn't that it was huge it was just that
in 2009 2010 there were many less yeah
than there are now so we felt huge in
the space and then that was around the
time Minecraft came out and we were I
don't want to say we were one of the
first but we were early in doing like
the the story progressions like we had
Minecraft Mondays and we had always you
know we were very much like log now
where we had a bunch of different
writers from all over the place and we
just had people contribute yes and it
got to the point where my my buddy uh
that I was running with Brandon he ended
up going and getting a job with a gaming
company and had like a non-compete
Clause so he was like I can't do this
anymore so I kept the podcast up for
like a little while and then no maybe no
I didn't keep the podcast up the podcast
stopped and then I kept the website up
for a little while until I got an offer
to buy it and then for the for the
domain and everything and I was like
well we could split this and I could pay
the rest of my college tuition with this
let's do that because I was getting
married I was doing a master's degree at
the time wow I was just I was I was
ready to be done with it and that kind
of like
that was big we started streaming on
Justin TV all of our podcasts they were
live too like very similar to you guys
um that was early on and then I kind of
like took a little Hiatus just because I
was married Masters starting a business
having kids like still playing games but
I can't do all the other stuff at the
time yeah yeah that's a lot man that's a
lot salute to your earliest Journey so
then again you do that you get you get
all these things kind of on your plate
at one time and then what kind of again
kept it going when did he kind of settle
down life settle down for you to kind of
get back into the mix
I think it was in either 2015 or 2016
um I was so during that time I wasn't
doing all the gaming stuff but I was
doing other podcasting okay
um history type stuff and we were pretty
successful and I ended up writing like a
little ebook it's not published anymore
because it was so out of date at that
point that I deleted it and uh my buddy
Dustin came to me you know
that's the last damn video Dustin came
to me and goes uh my buddy and I Brandon
oh we we had just like barely met like
we barely knew each other but but I knew
his parents and he goes you know we're
trying to podcast and I saw you have a
book out and I was just wondering if we
could like meet with you well you know
we can pay you if you need whatever and
I was like no we're buddies that's fine
and so we just talked about podcasting I
don't know do they actually gave them
any good advice but in the end like
that's how we kind of became friends and
then he invited me on to a few episodes
and then one day I was just like do we
want to go to PAX East
let's go
and I had been the paxis in 2011 as
media which was like I thought that was
the Pinnacle of my life at the time of
course
in the media that media badge hit
different bro it hit different continue
absolutely and uh so we were um we were
we decided to go to PAX East and at the
same time I would for some reason was
running for mayor
randomly I just decided into that one I
just decided
yeah
let me have some Cheerios and today I
think I want to run this town
reality to run this town in the
background said I don't really like how
they're giving out these parking tickets
I can't continue this is ill continue so
we're we're at PAX East and we had been
you know goofing around talking to
people and
Dustin and I start looking around and we
see all these other people that we like
we're kind of acquainted with and
everything and we're like
why don't why don't we do this let's go
and Dustin goes yeah just um forget
about being mayor and just come run a
game
and I was like I was like but why not
both
um and then like I hopped over he
already established like the domain the
handsome Phantom domain okay as a domain
for the podcast okay and so I jumped on
board and and we just like started
picking up people and kind of ran with
it for a little while until everybody
you know life kind of goes on and people
start going their different ways but it
still exists we still have the podcast
with a different iteration of people
um and actually it's a different podcast
than it was when I started with them too
but uh like we rebranded and restarted
but we're in n200s now somewhere in the
200s
what was the I gotta ask what is the
significance of the day like you have to
break this down for me I don't know
shout out to the origin story of
handsome fan of y'all shout out I wasn't
there I wasn't there when the handsome
Phantom name was made I just came in and
worked on it
it wasn't a written like we didn't have
anything written before that uh they
just did the podcast and wanted like a
website for it but you never asked you'd
never be like yo what is
I probably did yeah
continue babe I did that at some point
and I probably knew but I don't remember
it's not I honestly think it was like
well what sounds cool like I think
that's what the idea was but I could be
totally wrong
I'm gonna tell you right now being that
you never asked and found out it's
probably way more nefarious than what
yeah
this is probably you know something they
thought was cool
it was it was Ted Bundy's nickname
it's weird because the full domain is
actually handsome Phantom Megan
it does the door for clarity
he said I think Dustin said it has
something to do with Persona 5 and
Phantom thieves okay yeah yeah that
makes sense okay Persona 5 wasn't out
for like oh yeah
well there goes
and why is Megan Laurie
we need to address that part
let's talk kind of a magic but where a
lot of people know you from you know
saying as far as that Last Stand media
so how did that come about Lincoln would
call it the legend and the LSM fam how
did that come to Caleb so when I was um
when I was in office when I was a mayor
uh Colin invited me to be on one of his
podcasts
um uh Fireside Chats all the time yeah
yes yeah so Dustin and I went out for
Fireside Chats and I kind of like I
would email Colin here and there and
we'd talk back and forth not a lot or
anything yeah and then but I was like
keeping up with the podcast and I think
it must have been like I was listening
to a knockback or something that Dustin
didn't listen to because he hadn't seen
it yet or whatever and I told him like
Hey Colin's talking about hiring a
producer or no not a producer an editor
and I thought it was he was talking
about specifically video editing right
and he was talking he was actually
looking for audio editing which funny
enough I was doing for another company
anyway I told Dustin
that story went on Dustin got hired he
worked his butt off he he you know he
rose to where he is and then it got to a
point where he was like well we want to
bring on somebody else to do editing and
stuff or different ways so that's when I
I came on and started working for her
for LSM so it's kind of like a I think
he's the one who told me to talk to
Colin
I'm the one who told him about the job
he helped me out give me a job like you
know it's kind of like we've always
scratched each other's back kind of
thing absolutely love to see it and the
thing that's that's interesting is again
people don't realize like watching you
in person is ill because all the
responsibilities and things that you do
and um definitely want to give you some
respect for that because it is a lot
like this bit let me tell you about put
his business out but this bear is
organizing trips this man is is doing
the production value at the stage it's
been the audio he'll be like God you
know your levels there I heard your fan
your fan your fan you got to get you and
I'm like yeah he writing like it's it's
a certain level of professionalism and
then you do all of this and then as well
as you know contribute to content
creation mayor at yourself so I guess my
question to you is like how do you
manage and compartmentalize all of this
like that is a lot that you are doing
then lastly I mean it does have a lot of
shows
you know say like how do you find the
top to marriage all this stuff bruh uh
I've always been somebody who has like
multiple things going on and you know
from the time I was 16 I had multiple
jobs and hobbies and everything else
part of is that I've always turned like
my hobbies into jobs like I was a you
know interested in in DJ and music so I
turned that into a job I was interested
in gaming so I turned that into a job I
was interested in other things that I
didn't want to do a podcast about so we
like created a podcast Network I was
interested in local politics so we we
turned and I ran for mayor I was
interested in Brewing so I started the
brewery like I've always just been
somebody who like I don't sleep very
much and I don't have any hobbies that I
can't make
it
I will say though that right now like
things are you know I'm getting more and
more with LSM but right now like the
nice part is that I don't have a job I
gotta show up at nine whenever they tell
me I can't so like I'm still working a
lot and with everything else I got going
on with kids family like I feel like I'm
busier than ever but the nice part is
like it's my busy I get to decide when
that busy is absolutely now respect on
that and I got a shout out cord weiner
he said Kyla said we need a producer
call the bear
you know talk to us about that as far as
game development on the chops too what
we doing over there pretty much what I
do as producer this is what most
producers do is um I just handle all of
the interfacing with uh the platform
holders gotcha so you know Xbox Nintendo
PlayStation steam like if we have a game
coming up or need to run a sale or
neither do mate whatever like I
get that already I fill all that out I
get the files uploaded to it whatever
and
um manage that I don't really do
anything on the game production side and
I would like to someday but we're not
really that that kind of a team like
Barry who owns who's the majority owner
of fantastic names fantastic name sorry
yeah glorious I've heard that name I
think it's amazing yeah you gotta watch
those guys those guys yeah I mean he
really does most of the actual
development and then we have some like
freelance people that do you know art or
music or whatever and then Colin does
some of the writing and uh we have
another guy who helps out with writing
sometimes too so uh I really do I mean
uh for I don't know how to say this
without without swearing the B work can
I do the B work like that's kind of my
thing okay um I mean it's it's nice but
it's also like we're not putting out a
game a week or anything but not like a
one or two a year we call it the Box the
Box the Box nobody wants to be the Box
the box is in the corner okay all right
all right got it uh
so really like it's it's crazy because
and some of these things I only do a
couple times a year like there's stuff
leading up to it and stuff after it yeah
but then like they'll change their
policies in the meantime and everything
all the platform holders or wow you know
it's a totally different kind of
situation so it's like a struggle to
constantly have to learn yes just to be
able to do the next thing but that's a
good thing too I think it keeps you on
your toes and yeah keeps you working but
yeah I mean it's nice I get to be
involved in all the development but um
the only thing that producers normally
do I think that I don't really do is
like I don't dictate schedules or
anything like that like it's I tried
they get they asked me to one time and I
was like okay well here's what we need
to have this and they have this and they
were like yeah we're just gonna get it
done we'll get it done I was like okay
you told me to do it I just did it I
just did it I was ready yeah yeah salute
Saloon man I love love to hear that
stuff love to see how like just a
general you know as far as being a
contributor in that space and then
obviously it has been you know a bunch
of games was it perils baking was it
hypoxia uh one and two you know a twin
breaker and stuff like that so to see
you know Colin kind of jump into this
far away as far as making games and then
also you being a part of that is pretty
cool I did want to comment real quickly
um in reference to your content creation
recently you know what I'm saying as far
as you know the Betty's handsome YouTube
and twitch channels out there doing
getting your stream on you see a thief
streams getting your pirate on and and
also on the YouTube channel I just love
to see you know the content creation the
reviews and stuff like that so give me
the inspiration as far as now into
content creation so we can get to low
band a little bit more
so I've always had like you know like
that I've always been doing content
creation of some sort it feels like
other than those couple years I took a
little break there with the kids and
everything so I was just kind of itching
like I got to the point like you know
I'm working with
literally six or seven days a week I'm
working with creative people who have
outlets for their thoughts and ideas and
I'm just sitting there editing them like
oh I want to say this right now and I
know that's how people feel when they're
edit when they're when they're listening
to podcasts but because I have direct
access to you guys at any time and I
know you'll respond because it's our
jobs sometimes I'm like oh I just want
to like tell them this like this is my
thought or this is you know oh they
actually here's a correction or you know
whatever and so I was just kind of
feeling like
I need something else I've got the the
HP podcast but
um it's it's great it's a good outlet
but honestly mostly it's like us hanging
out with with the boys yeah
and so and then I do Twitch streaming
but like my twitch is dedicated
specifically for sea of Thieves because
that's what I want to stream like I
think that's the most fun game to stream
for me and then um so I was just like
well I need some way to just like at
least once a week I want to be able to
get my voice out there in a way that is
not necessarily like on my podcast
because I do that of course too but like
just a little bit of an expounded way
and I don't want to like go for numbers
I'm not trying to rig the algorithm
obviously if I work on the videos I want
to get views you know but my main goal
is just I want a creative Outlet I feel
that so I decided to throw up the
channel and I try to do at least one
video a week and uh it there's no rhyme
it's like here's what I want to do this
week and that's what I do I I don't I'm
not like beholden to anybody else I'm
only beholden to disappointing myself
that's a nice feeling no I salute to you
man I will put the link to the channel
in there because um It's really
informative stuff I love I was talking
to you you know obviously pre-show
I really loved your section on like why
you fell in love with PlayStation early
and your maybe frustrations now where
they are and it really okay you have to
watch it like it takes us back to that
don't let King watch it no kick see kick
people
Kate likes that PlayStation like yeah I
Gotta Give kid like me and him kind of
came from that PlayStation that
aggressive I share your views yes yeah
like My Views and your views are more
aligned than than you would think I know
a lot of dudes probably think like I'm a
PlayStation hater no I've been online
for every place that ever came out um I
was following that machine when they
were going to make it with Nintendo and
they split and they have this Revenge
dudes I like that aggressive
no-nonsense let's get it done type of
Sony thing that invests within theyself
and you know um
to me there was the Brash out there
dudes
um they were edgy they would do
definitely things that Nintendo wouldn't
do and their quality was above what Sega
was putting out
so it was just like they were A step
above and they were the cool kid yeah
like right now it's just certain things
that I don't agree with but I've been a
PlayStation dude like since they dropped
yeah
I mean I was the ones that got me but
Trey singing from yeah
the purest right
[Music]
that is awesome love to see that
creative Outlet you kind of embraced
that so we gotta ask the questions we
have all the guests here in the realm
I need Laura Ben's top five video games
or franchises of all time just what's
important to you
man yeah on the spot I didn't I didn't
remember this was going to be a question
if I'm being honest with you I think it
does vacillate day to day like it
changes
um I always say that like you know
nothing's ever gonna replace my love for
Mario in general it's just my first love
it's always been good it's probably
hopefully always gonna be good and I
don't care if it's a kids game I don't
care if it's an adult's game it's a game
that I like and you know Mario did you
see the movie oh of course I saw the
movie absolutely it was like four times
already I didn't see it four times
because I got I gotta take the kids and
I don't
the wife knows but she doesn't care
about it yeah I'll go see a movie and
then but I know like if I went and saw
the Mario movie again somehow I'd come
home and they'd be like
were you in here
me and Mario friends like that
so we got that Mario yeah I'd say let's
say Duke Nukem I don't know if these are
any particular order by the way yeah
Duke Nukem um uh 64 not it wasn't 64. it
was Duke Nukem 3D uh that that
generation though was the first Duke
Nukem I played and just went back and
then went forward and then got
disappointed and then went back again so
I uh Duke Nukem was probably another one
that's up there
um the original Crash Bandicoot is one
of the first games I ever paid for with
my own money for sure
but I definitely bought I definitely
bought the game
and it was one of the first games I ever
remembered my dad was a gamer like way
back but I remember my dad like I come
home from school and he'd be home from
work and be like playing Crash Bandicoot
and then we'd talk about it and I was
like I was you know I was young but like
that's one of those great memories and
of course I've played all the other
games too but so Crash Bandicoot's got
to be up there remember that old
commercial right all of them you do yeah
oh slow crash Legend okay so we got
crash in there Mario witness Duke Nukem
what else we got I'd say I have to get
give Call of Duty an honorable mention
it's not an honorable mention it's on
the top five
um I can't point to a specific one
there's been high points there's been
low points but I've always played it I
played it as long as it's existed and
I've certainly like hated on it a lot
over the years probably more than I've
Loved on it but it's like it's a go-to I
always go back to it
um and then one more I don't know like
coming up with that last one is always
tough because like there's so many
different games and series that I've
Loved over the years but I think today
I'm gonna have to say because I know you
want to talk about it and I'm going to
have to say sea of Thieves
it's not the game I have the most like
actual love for the actual game but it's
the game that's like the most dynamic of
any game that I've played in the last 10
years so that's true that's got to be
the last one for me so slowly hold on I
can't let you just slide through like no
I know I know like because because you
know what's funny it's so interesting
that you said that because in the
beginning I wish attic was here for this
I would be talking to him right now you
know in the beginning obviously he
didn't launch you know to the fully
featured section I can even have a body
yeah
we're gonna sidestep that we won't talk
about the cracking not having a body
yeah the cracking was lacking and people
were like you know the feature set and
you know what's interesting is one I
remember saw when we used to go to E3
the lines for that game
insane right same number two after the
initial you know content was a little
less in the beginning but once they kept
ramping up ramping up and to see what it
is now and it's arguably one of Xbox's
most successful new IPS like it is still
downtown organic growth
tell the people you know that are
unaware as far as sea of Thieves in the
community and what's going on with the
game yeah so you're talking about the
early like if it did launch without a
lot of features correct and I did not
play at launch like I wasn't somebody
was there at launch I jumped in at one
point with some buddies for like a
couple hours and then didn't play it
again for two years or something like
that uh until another friend got me into
it but it's funny because people are
like now that you know we've had a
couple
lackluster titles from Xbox and people
are like well maybe redfall will be
really good one day like sea of Thieves
when that launch was broken and not very
good now it's you know everybody loves
it and I'm like sea thieves didn't
launch broken correct it was just boring
correct it was a big difference yeah it
was boring yeah you can't you I mean you
can fix
um broken it's hard to fix boring and
they have In fairness but so yeah I mean
I don't play sea of Thieves like the
majority of people play sea of Thieves
break into how you play What's the hook
what's the educate them I am almost
entirely PVP oriented no I know it oh
wow
dude that run up and steal the booty
yeah
I know it is
um
[Laughter]
he did a blend with uh what was that uh
Billie Jean and Pumped Up Kicks I can't
move it
so you you out there them see you out
here going into the Seas but you don't
yeah I mean still in their booty I'm
telling you I I really like I just enjoy
being in the world I think so much of
that is like sea of Thieves has the
option uh for you to have the mic in
game like you don't I don't do that I
talk like I talk to my buddies in
Discord but then like you can either
hear other people talking or you can
talk to them and everything like that
and so like that's the I think that's
one of the big appeals but just like
the nice part about it is literally
every fight you ever have is going to be
different and everything that every
encounter you have is going to be
different and the PVE is great I love
you know like some of the stories and I
like some of the missions and they've
recently rebalanced a lot of that to
make it go a little quicker for people
to depending on their crew size and
everything and like that's made me love
it more that's made the Seas feel more
alive than they ever were before it puts
out a lot more loot for me to come along
with steel and that's awesome but yeah
I'd say just like my my favorite part
about the game is just like the
interactions between players and it's
not like you know you're not just
getting Xbox message later it's like Fu
man I can't I can't believe you did that
I'm gonna report you for hacking you
know whatever like you do get some of
those but it like you know I'm not
you're not playing Halo or Call of Duty
where it's like a toxic Community like
it's very wholesome and it's you know
right next to the campfire doing the
slave dance like oh my god oh Jesus I'm
not gonna lie that was all I loaded the
game in for in the beginning it was me
brap and the rest of us we was dancing
around a fight so you came out with the
e-books
oh
King
hey but um definitely all the extra
stuff we came back when it was Jack
Sparrow and um oh yes right yeah that
they changed the game a lot I do
appreciate the time they put into it
absolutely salute all that bad the PVP
and of course you already I think you
already answered this but I still gotta
ask favorite console of all time and why
the n64s yeah I think it's the N64 and I
think mostly it's the N64 because of
those experiences during that specific
time I mean obviously we had a lot of
great games for the N64 uh and they felt
even better at the time of course you
know everybody remembers golden eye with
a different kind of Rose tinted glasses
than we actually oh yeah you go back to
it now
but uh he's like yo what's up with that
guy yeah
but yeah I think it's probably the N64
but I think probably
the generation that most shaped my
current day
um gaming sensibilities is probably the
360. there were so like that was such a
first of all such a good period for
gaming that looks more like modern day
than anything before it yes and it was
also such a like there were so many good
titles not only just on on the Xbox but
like that I could play on the Xbox and
so that 360 generation was like huge so
like one has that that tie to it that is
more about Nostalgia and memories in the
64 and then the 360 I think is more
about like what actually shaped the way
that I play games now okay not fair
enough I like that assessment the
legendary sometimes you got the red ring
of death
oh wow I did unload my 360.
uh when the elite came out and I got the
elite he was able to trade it in before
the person who got it might have got red
rings
bro hey no better feeling than getting
your hustle with GameStop or some
defective equipment that you know don't
work but you just need it
needed to work in front of the games
associate before you trade it slowly
don't go up
[Laughter]
salute salute I love it love to hear it
man no doubt the legendary Ben Smith who
I believe is hanging out with us right
Still rocking and rolling we gotta show
we got topics we gonna do this thing so
um solve when we get the uh the pole
while you get the super chats up get
both I'm good with both so you can go
dude go ahead and get the get the pole
all right
yo today's today's difference
is different
with the CMA recently blocking
Microsoft's acquisition of ABK in the UK
what do you think Microsoft's Next Step
should be moving forward the weather at
44 of the vote is appeal and focus on
the EU next coming in at second at 22
before subset was a messy Lords I don't
care scorched Earth Microsoft now
they go up for blood coming in a close
third place with them to focus on third
party exclusives and first party quality
and uh last pays at 13 was way smaller
acquisition so shout out to the realm so
of returning they want the the Lords
want the fight man they want they want
an appeal they want to go to the eagle
they want to take it all the way to the
thing they are some you know the king
they not been in the knee yeah I mean
yeah it makes sense I wasn't here to
give my opinion on this last week yeah
um listen yeah appeal as much as you can
and if you know somebody else decides to
go that route and block then you know uh
the way I see it is this
they were there were certain remedies
suggested by these governing bodies
right we can go back to the remedies and
and and break some of this stuff up
and you know in a lot of ways the deal
can be done it just can't look the way
it looks now right that's kind of the
the the the sort of just that I'm
getting so yeah it makes a whole lot of
sense they'll fight until they they
decide not to until maybe the you know
the uh
shareholders saying you know what let's
not keep let's stop pursuing this and
maybe go another route or like I said
some of the remedies that were suggested
you know take out 30 billion or whatever
it is and and just get Call of Duty uh
by itself and then go buy King by itself
and you know and in a roundabout way the
deal kind of still goes through with the
most important aspects of it I think
that that's something that can happen
but I'll be honest though I gotta I
gotta sort of I respect the gangster the
CMA here because this is cloud it you
know what it is it kind of felt like it
kind of felt like Xbox felt fell for the
red herring a little bit like they were
there was so much aggro right with with
the Call of Duty it's like Call of Duty
Call of Duty Call of Duty and Xbox is
like protecting the front right and
thinking around the back with a knife
was the CMA with the class the clown
right
uh Cog and I were speaking this week
yeah and we was like you know it was
unfortunate that you you were gone yeah
but I would have gave you your flowers
yeah
you were the only person saying stop
worrying about Call of Duty the real
thing is cloud yeah you want to attack
this by any means and nobody else was
saying this you know everybody else can
sit there and say well you know I was
talking about clouds that that [__] up
um the only person that was talking
about Cloud was you and how they can act
I effectively block this and
um I remember
a sale nah
but the CMA every time it seems to be
listening to you so what I need you to
do is shut up
[Laughter]
and the funny thing is they still did it
wrong right because they still they
focus on the gaming aspect of the of the
cloud stuff and I mean that stop talking
it's the newest hanging fruit
he just told them no don't don't focus
on that this is the real this is the one
that you can make sure that you never
get this done so I mean I will say this
though it just feels it feels like they
really fell for the red herring because
then once once they they kind of felt
like they they were defending against
Call of Duty and not paying attention to
the cloud stuff they went out and
offered everybody and their mother to
tell you a deal yeah yeah just
exemplifying how powerful they could be
into space
I'm like oh hell no
want to know what guys I did was that
like I want to know if if Mike from
accounting is still available
shout out to Paris to the chat Paris not
feeling that he was omitted from the
field he was talking about the clouds
I'm sorry I just talked about TCL with
you
anyway it's gonna be interesting because
I think one way or another
some aspects of this deal are gonna go
through in some way shape or form it's
just going to be interesting to see how
they machinate that yeah let's see how
it goes no doubt no doubt so excited
with that or the patreon question
um let me yeah we haven't gotten two
more I got okay I got a couple more
Super chats yeah
start the patreon question all right
shout out to sack shop okay so everyone
must have seen I don't know what else to
call it the great white Knights of
Castle redfold this past week out here
straight lying through their teeth about
this game on how awesome it is I
understand people can like objectively
bad games but at the same time I
understand when people just straight
lying you know how I know they don't
like redfall they butts us on Twitter 22
hours a day defending the game they'd
open yo much love bye man I can't handle
this much Barnum and Bailey's Captain
circus for much longer so stop shop says
I guess people are too defensive of
redfall and no what he's trying to say
is that people are capping that is a
arguably bad game and that they're
saying that it's a good game what I
would tell you is if those people don't
share your views your page is your
little sovereign
from this
all right we got Mr Irishman member for
21 months Lord silver why is Phil and
Matt taking bullets when it should be
Pete Hines taking most of the heat yes
I'm not the one in charge of all xenomax
Studio soon got you V I'm glad that you
that's a good Super Chat and stick
around
then we have Astro parrot King remember
for two months five dollars of attack a
new Challenger approaches Ben is here
best way to start the week how about how
does Ben look better than my cowboy hat
than I do type of day
who was the answer parrot yeah so he's
we're down in Houston yeah for the out
for the Last Stand event and he goes I'm
going to get a cowboy hat and I said
well give me one too and he goes all
right and then he shows up without a hat
for me he's like bro I paid 250 for this
it's like custom fit and I said you
didn't give me a hat and he goes no I
said give me yours
actually take it from him but he let me
try it on I got a picture
um
now I wanted to know where my cowboy hat
there yeah splendor
Splendid member for one year two dollars
Super Chat talk that sad and talk Savvy
you gotta be on it hard part sorry sorry
man he just got back
good gosh he's looking at her saw him
like he fresh beat up too excited too
excited I see I was missed man yeah you
were missed clearly
then we have Mr blt's ten dollars
if free R Kelly dressed up in a sob
costume and if let me play with your
joystick dressed up in a PS5 with a
blonde wig costume these would be some
wild conjugal visits
[Laughter]
then we got Robert Kelly Two Dollars
Super Chat you rock Ben for being a jack
of all trades and dare I say master of
all it's crazy man I don't know about
master of all
I know a little bit about a lot of
things and a lot about nothing
absolutely salute what else we got then
we got God's hit man ten dollars laying
them down for the Lord
you're going to sleep with God
exactly let's go scoop of God
what's Phil saying like hey uh say we
don't need to be Hands-On with every
project but in the same breath we're
hands on with Starfield this is from the
same interview he did recently yes we
know we will discuss
everybody read but can't comprehend no
everybody listen but don't understand
we'll get to it we gonna have to hook
them phonics Edition for you let's go
just said that Sony secured a deal with
Konami for Metal Gear Silent Hill and
potentially Castlevania exclusivity King
it ain't looking good
stuff too yeah those deals have been in
place way before the ABK deal with it
why you acting like this is new news
kale oh news travel to you slow cause
you want me off
oh he's behind the wall
just got that from uh by parrot right
don't do that don't do that Flamingo to
you
acting like he send him a raven
he get a toucan oh man also uh remember
that Jess Gordon claims Dead Rising is
returning is returning yeah a lot of
things but we're going to continue
all right let's play with each other's
joysticks two dollar Super Chat oh
brother
I'd rather watch SOB get the pole but I
ain't mad
hey there we go
right there buttons I just want to move
on
misbehaving with with company over
what's going on IOP after dark
three R Kelly five dollars Xbox is that
girl who tell you to wait before you can
get some then we get some in his trash
you know that was crazy you can't get
you back yeah PlayStation is the one
that charge you more
and charge you more for the same thing
guess what you get for Valentine's Day
what you got last Thursday oh man remix
um little Timmy's crying that's his
final hours playing red ball on series
apps and asking Phil why are you holding
a silver medal oh man this is messy
continue
then we have Jonas the dab two dollars
if you chat Microsoft drops 40 billion
ABK second party game pass exclusive
forever could be I said there they were
remedies they were suggested
who knows we'll see we'll see something
happened and then people go right back
to I didn't care about Call of Duty
anyway
I didn't care buddy oh yeah I heard it I
heard a lot of that that's for sure dude
one more THX 1138 two dollar Super Chat
peanut butter and jelly
It's peanut butter jelly
um
these people zesty
are we good
though yeah we're good we're caught up
all right we are caught up welcome back
rule in the building no it's a game back
in the building I might check real quick
sir
yeah yeah can you hear me yes yes all
right golden golden no doubt so we're
here let's get to these Main Event tops
where a lot of people are here for it's
actually uh addicts topic we're gonna
set him up on redfall the the reviews
have hit the streets the the afterbath
we had lots of gaming.net mcmuda also
reviewed the game and uh yeah let's look
currently sitting on Metacritic at
59. currently and um yeah there's a lot
of talk right now there's the the
internet is in a frenzy the Xbox
Community isn't a frenzy about the game
so let's get to it let's get to it I
want to start with um let's start with
band man I mean
you know thoughts on it but like what
was your thought processing did you get
a chance to to try redfall what do you
think of all the backlash or the
aftermath regarding the reviews of
redfall yeah I played for
I don't know four or five hours on
release night uh with some buddies and
it's it's interesting because redfall is
the kind of game I would normally like
set up and play with somebody's for a
little while but it's not the kind I'm
not that's not really my style like I I
liked you know back for blood yeah I'm
just mainly thinking of these like four
player Mission based kind of games like
I liked it because I was playing with
the Buddies like that's a lot of my
gaming experience now it's just playing
with the dudes and
I enjoyed that aspect of it all right
enjoy that aspect of gaming most and so
like for that reason I was interested in
it
but as more and more stuff kept coming
forward as we got closer I was like I
don't know like I don't know you know
here and hearing you guys even saw who
went and saw it and talk about it and
along with Maddie and then like just
seeing some other you know little little
leaks of stuff trickle out I was like I
don't know but I'm still gonna play it
like we set up a time to play we're
gonna get on as soon as it's out
definitely gonna play it and I was just
absolutely floored by how bad of a time
it was I had a great time again hanging
out with the with the guys trashing it
like we were just you know trashing the
whole time we were playing it and
this is like before all the reviews were
even out so it wasn't even like it was
more of a maybe it was a confirmation
bias and I thought it was going to be
bad and then it wasn't very good yeah I
was just amazed at one
I gotta I've never had a problem running
games on my computer at all
and by the way sorry King I'm I'm with
Sav I'm mostly a PC Gamer these days but
oh no but not all the plastic you know
y'all I have horrible uh
it's okay you know we over here look
over here you know you know that dude
that when he's not invited to the party
he hates on it
ain't nobody famous gonna be there
oh kick is that VIP dude anyway
the club is exclusive nobody can get in
there you sound like a PlayStation fan
like anybody can go and purchase to get
in nobody wanted
but you're selling this but you know
what it is you know you know what yeah
it may perform party but the thing is my
game actually looks like what your
Nostalgia is going to tell you in 10
years that your game actually is like
man you know what you did what you did
you paid that price for it I told listen
I told her I told her to come downstairs
and sweatpants and a t-shirt
[Laughter]
thank you
continue
so I was just I was disappointed in
every way about the game I thought it it
didn't look as good as it could it
didn't run as well as I thought it
should it was empty it was a little
confusing honestly like I start and I'm
the kind of guy that if I know I'm gonna
play a game and that's pretty much
anything on Game Pass and like 80 of
other games that aren't on Game Pass if
I know I'm gonna play it I see the first
trailer I'm out if I don't know that I'm
gonna play it I'll watch until I decide
I'm gonna play it yep so I didn't know
really anything about the game so I
didn't know if this was shown but like
basically right after you do like the
first thing in the game you like you
free some prisoners and then you or so
like they were just hiding out and then
you build a base and I was like what's
happening are we like looking at the
past here
these terrible Cuts cuts no Cinema just
PowerPoint slides like they aren't even
they aren't even Google Drive slides
they're in 1997.
office 97.
he hit us with the office 97 said no not
too clippy with that flip oh man
yeah
so no I'm just overall
very disappointed and I wasn't even
excited that's how bad it was to me like
this was a game I was like I'm looking
forward to that but not excited yeah and
then I play it and I'm like well now I'm
mad that I was even looking forward to
it like you know that that kind of thing
and the the worst part about redfall to
me is there's something there yes
there's something there this could be an
awesome game but it doesn't run right
it's boring it's empty and I walk up to
a vampire and he just stares at me and
like I don't I don't know I think the AI
is not good and I think the most
disappointing part overall and I know
this is a tired thing no that's cool but
did a good Studio made it yeah you know
and maybe maybe making a game this bad
means you're not as good of a studio
anymore maybe that's what it means I
don't know but prior to this games I
played and games I didn't play were all
revered highly yeah and whether some of
that's revisionist history with prey
everybody pretending like they liked it
when we know I was there yeah
I remembered not everybody liked that
game like they like it now uh but it
just it's disappointing to see you know
uh a potential in the game and then a
studio that you know has made better
games yeah just just be disappointing
and and boring empty uh buggy and maybe
some of that gets better down the line
but I'm not I played four or five hours
of it and the next day my buddy was like
you think I'm you think you're gonna
play redfall anymore I was like well I
already deleted it so no not now maybe
when they maybe later but not now I
don't say that no that's that's honest I
hear where you at brother let's get
lordsgaming.net's own editor-in-chief in
the building wig look brother you know
you we we got it for the site you know
be it in the 11th hour but uh oh yeah we
were able to you know shout out to you
you have tremendous uh tips and tricks
initially for the you know person who is
new to experience the game for the first
time to survive but you know you've
reviewed the game you know once you give
it and also just your your overall
assessment of this whole situation
because it's really a bloodbath out here
as far as you know people being upset in
reference to the quality of this game so
overall your thoughts are the whole red
four reviews and the aftermath
yeah absolutely thanks for that setup
call gum I think
um when I first saw redfall I thought it
was intrigued because I like some of you
guys who was really enamored by prey I
love prey so much it was such a great
experience that and the way the story
was set up was fantastic so naturally I
was pretty excited about how red phone
was announced and especially I had
vampires and you know vampires and video
games has always been a hit and miss
kind of thing so except for vampire
survivors that's definitely a steer
addicted
you're welcome here anytime
getting back to it so we got the code
really late I think it was like
um for you it was like Saturday for me
it was Sunday like okay and I told like
the wife and the kids like all right
daddy's gonna be away for a bit so I
gotta installed it and I played it and
then I couldn't get it out on time in
embargo because it's just it's it takes
a few hours to be I think it took like
me around over 20 hours so so the like I
played the first area and I noticed
right off the bat okay the setup was
nice okay you get into the fire station
uh you there's something going on but
then the more I played of it then the I
got to the loop you know where you
capture the safe houses you get the
skulls yeah you get the nest you know it
just becomes so repetitive and then um
when I first saw my first AI glitch I
was like huh okay you know yeah it's
just running around
so like then I noticed it's starting
creep Mount more and more and more my
God and but I have to say one thing the
vampire AIS they will wreck you but the
human ARs they're like I don't know
that's what I said yeah yeah it's it's
it's something
um well I gotta interrupt you first yeah
because I I gotta say something
internally that we you talk but I gotta
put it because it's so hilarious so I
remember against the cold y'all so I'm
gonna do your thing you know we know we
up against the eight ball you know
obviously man professional he's like I
got you but I'll do you know probably
Impressions or whatever so at the
beginning right he go kick this man for
he go yo I don't know what do I talk
about
like this is like the first hour right
he's like you know this this is good I
don't know what so I'm like oh
interesting really good it was PC right
there okay yeah so PC so so I because
remember what I get I said look your
world on the street
I'm hearing things I don't want to
influence you the world on the street is
I'm hearing things so I'm dying to know
what you thought so the first hour yo
was late he's like I don't know what
everybody talking about
so then it was like 30 minutes later
he's like oh nah nah
it was just such a funny thing to read
that timeline on our Discord I had to I
had to tell you that but I was beating
to tell you I was like bro that was the
funniest transformation of emotions I
seen in a timeline but continue I'm
sorry for interrupting continue
absolutely
because I was I was enamored at first I
guess
vampires yes and I saw the texture is
not loading and then just the frame
drops and I have to admit the massive
day one patch would had a lot of issues
with or it's pretty much redialing the
entire game I had to do it twice but
then it got a little bit better but it
was still wonky and by the time I was
entering the the second Zone I was just
like you know like I was just like that
rushing just you know I just wanted to
finish it and get it over with and yeah
and the best the worst thing about it is
the size some of the side missions they
had a lot of like personal
personalization of the characters like
some people were like going through
grief and they were like telling you to
it's a fetch Quest but it's like but
like French this heirloom for my my dead
mother yes gravy and there was things
like that there was there was a lot of
potential in there but they just half
asked everything you know it was like
undercooked and the immersive Sim
elements you can see they wanted like
players to like move around the
buildings they had little entrances here
and there and we found them they were
really exciting but the thing about it
is there's no stealth in the game it's
either you kill something or they're
just too dumb to notice you and you kill
them later that's all it is yeah and but
um I don't know if I said but I gave it
a six out of ten and I feel that for me
redfall is a symptom of uh Arcane
Austin's sort of like uh the last days
of of uh Zen and Max when they were
independent like okay we need to get
into the live service game so ever
everyone has to do one here's a card
choose everyone choose one and they got
stuck with redfall and that to me feels
like what happened that's the situation
that they got stuck with this game they
had to make it a service game and this
is what they produce because obviously
as a studio of their caliber should not
be putting out this kind of uh this kind
of game
no well said Brotherhood down there
being solved kind of talked about a
little conversations after Guardians and
stuff we had like a little bit IOP after
talking because I haven't talked to him
in a while but I'm sorry about when
you're saying something on the other
friends
yeah no I'll be well said in reference
to you know that's what it felt like
right as far as the you know the but
there's the xenomax days where they were
trying to figure things out
pre-acquisition now at least that's what
it felt like to me like that Fallout
Maddie was at it perfect like that
Fallout 76 kind of energy just kind of
throw the wall but solve you know let's
talk about it man you know obviously me
and you went to an event and uh
saw this game you know initially and
then obviously we see what's going on
now so what are your thoughts between
now then and the reception
yeah so like I said to you yesterday I
had I haven't listened to the latest
episode of Duke yet right but I had
hoped that you guys would talk about how
you feel about the game through the lens
of what we saw when we went to the
preview event and I'm gonna keep it real
with you man like I feel like we got
bamboos
I really do
um you know we went to that event it was
a month out from launch right so maybe
it's naivete on our part or whatever but
my thinking was I was going to see at
the the closest to finished build of
that game that we were gonna see right
before the launch my thinking is this is
this is essentially what the game is
going to be
um still you know ironing out some bugs
or whatever but this is it right
and what it feels like in hindsight now
after having played the actual game for
a couple of hours not too much time is
that it feels like they took the build
of that game that was running the best
looking the best polish that up as you
would a vertical slice and let us play
that with the anticipation that they
would be able to hit that quality bar in
the final product by the time it
launched and that just did not happen so
essentially what we played was the the
most ideal version of what they wanted
to release
and not indicative of what we were going
to see day one and that to me that was
that's disingenuous because it's not you
know especially that close to launch if
we were six months out from launch and
we got something like that I I would I
would think hey no there's been a lot of
changes to this before we actually you
know it's not going to be the same thing
when when we go in but a month out again
maybe it was naive on my part to think
that I'm thinking this is close to done
yeah
so yeah well we played and what we
talked about and again I think uh you
know our impressions are out there right
that that uh that episode of Duke
ultimate is out there for everybody to
listen to I think you know we we were
cautiously optimistic about the things
that we saw that could be expounded upon
that seemed like they could be exciting
in a four-player multiplayer setting
um and but we were all you know we're
cautious about you know the the
immersive Sim elements and how they
would sort of play out in an open world
where you know same thing about the gun
play how that would would play out and
and sort of the looter shooter aspect of
it you know um the upgrade path what you
know how how significant that would be
to the gameplay all those things I think
we we were sort of pretty measured about
right we didn't go say oh this is the
greatest thing ever
um and unfortunately from the little
that I've played which has only been a
couple of hours and it and that has been
marred by crashes like straight straight
to desktop crashes of the game
um is not indicative of that whatsoever
um I'm gonna reserve my full judgment
until I play it all because I do want to
play it all just to really see what the
the final experiences but what I've
played so far
with the crashes with the you know with
the pop-in which is crazy
you're you're set up you're doing PC 40
40 49 40 90 with an I9 uh the latest I9
whatever what's that bill sir you Flex
that so yeah so it's I mean it should
not be having problems at all with this
and then I look at the ground it's gonna
have problems even with the 490
and and for the you know the the frame
rate generally is fine like the frame
rate flies but I still get to pop in
yeah and I'm looking at the ground and
I'm literally it's not even quick
popping it's the texture sort of
morphing in slowly like I looked at the
floor it's funny because I I shout out
to Maddie and shout out to Carrick I I
kind of looked at both of their reviews
and there was one thing that Carrick was
saying that was perfectly indicative of
what I saw he was looking at a decal on
something on the ground and the decal
the texture wouldn't pop in quickly like
you know it would slow slowly morph into
itself he literally timed it and it was
a minute wow a minute for a full texture
for 4K texture to load in wow and so
even even looking at it
[Laughter]
so I'm Gonna Keep It Real from what I
played so far and my thoughts may change
in the long term
um this game should not have been
released this game should have been
canceled and I say cancel for this watch
so I've gotten a little bit of pushback
about hey I know you love immersive
seven games I know you love the games
that Arcane has made in the past
you have to judge this game on what it
is and not what you want it to be the
problem with and I and I fully agree
with that except for except for the part
where they told us that the immersive
Sim aspects the arcaniness this is a
shot of the of of of what the studio is
known for we're going to be a prominent
part of this game it's it is some
something that's going to be integral to
the gun play as well it's like in how
you tackle these these sort of combat
situations the powers and the gun play
are going to be you know work in Synergy
with one another
and
we kind of saw it when we first saw it
right it was like well the power seemed
limited and I think they made the
mistake of showing us the entire skill
tree and kind of showing us what the
powers were in their their strongest
form and in their strongest form they
just do things like oh the power lasts
longer yeah
double jump it isn't really the the
powers aren't transformative in a way
that gives you the type of Arsenal that
you would normally see and expect from
an Arcane game with the type of you know
power set that you end up with
um
and it's just super disappointing so I
look at it and I'm like well you know
what
I think I just think from a design ethos
sort of
aspect of it it just it is not them it's
not them I I sincerely feel that this
game came out of a moment again this
game got started way before you know the
acquisition it was a moment where
Bethesda and Arcane in particular were
looking at okay the games that we make
are well received they don't sell well
good point we're having we're having
money issues right so let's try to make
a game that is more appealing to a more
uh to a general populace right catch it
a wave exactly I try to catch a wave
after the wave has passed which is never
a good thing
and ultimately try let's see if we can
integrate the things that we're known
for into this type of game that may be
appealing to a broader audience and in
general and this isn't Arcane Austin
this Arcane Leone they were somewhat
successful with death Loop and I think
the success of death Loop is partially
attributed to the fact that death Loop
is still fairly linear like an Arcane
game is
as opposed to trying to you know
transpose that that sort of design sort
of philosophy into an open world I think
it can be done and I think it could be
done super well
um I look at something like breath of
the wild and hopefully tears of the
Kingdom taking sort of immersive
sensibilities and throwing them into an
open world and that's exciting to me so
my thinking is hey Arcane the masters of
this
figuring out a way to to a put that into
an open world and B do it in a co-op
setting where everybody
powers are supposed to work in unison
and this really beautiful way
and they didn't do any of that it's not
arcaney enough the only thing that I I
get that feels like Arcane is sort of
the the the the World building and the
and the design of the world the
characters that feels good right I I
kind of like that the rest of it though
the gameplay execution when it comes to
the immersive stem stuff the stealth is
essentially non-existent
we don't have a real stealth animation
for for for you know for stealth kills
yes um you can really only you can
really only enter uh you know a building
in in two or three different types of
specific ways very specific ways
um you just don't have that flexibility
in gameplay that they're known for and
then the the looter shooter part about
it is is when you look at what it's
emulating right you look at a
Borderlands or maybe like a Destiny or
something things of that nature it
doesn't do it even remotely as well so
it's like what is this game for so that
when I look at what I've played so far
and again my thoughts may change in the
long term
I look at it I'm like someone somewhere
down the line should have said hey we're
under Microsoft now we can afford to
keep taking the risks of the types of
games that we make without worrying so
much about the monetary sort of uh what
we're gonna make back on it and we can
continue to expand upon that formula
that we're the masters of and they
didn't do that
um and we got this so that's why I say
so far by what I've played and what I
initially played and it just feels like
this is a concept that should have died
somewhere along the vine and it didn't
happen and unfortunately the consumer
has to has to deal with this and I feel
for I feel for the team because I just
don't again somebody blame has to be put
somewhere right of course of course at
the end of the day they made this game
um
but I just it just feels like no one's
heart was in it to be perfectly honest
and that's weird to say but it just it
just feels like I I don't know whose
passion project This was
um but again
in theory everything that they have
there should make for a great game you
have vampires right I'm looking at it
I'm like okay if you really really got
down about giving each of these
characters a bunch of different cool
powers that worked in unison with each
other the gun play was super tight and
the the AI was smart and forced you to
think about how because that's that's
the thing about these games the AI is so
intelligent that it forces you to sort
of on the Fly figure things out and post
a native with your powers exactly and
and none of that is the case I I killed
a vampire that was out in broad daylight
it was in broad daylight and it was
floating above me and I just popped it I
I popped it with a with a rifle twice it
dropped down then it did some cool
little dodging movements or whatever but
then I just spun around and pulled out
the shotgun and killed him two shots and
that was that and and that was the most
resistance I got from any sort of any
sort of NPC so it
around very very disappointed
um and again I don't mean to to drag
Arcane to the mud on this one I love
that studio I love what they put out so
far but this ain't it y'all
if I wanted to comment real quick yeah
you're talking about your your frames
and maybe that's maybe the difference
between my my 30 series card and your
seven thousand dollars
I was getting decent frames like usually
above 60 between 60 and 120 but it was
inconsistent for me yeah I was getting
like you know one minute I'd be getting
the straight 60 the next minute I'd be
90 the next one that'd be 70. so like I
would prefer a solid 30 over
inconsistent 80
.
right but this is the thing right and I
haven't played no in-game frame cap not
none whatsoever insane again whatsoever
a modern day game with no option to cap
your frames
absurd yeah just weird sort of quality
of life things like you said that no
option to cap your frames little things
like when I got multiples of certain
weapons right because it's a little
shooter you're going to get like
multiples of every single weapon and I'm
trying to unequip them to put newer
weapons in
it doesn't let me it'll just re-equip to
something else yeah yeah and like and it
won't it there's no option to just
unequip everything and then pick what
you want to do bro same thing with the
just cycling weapons like you gotta go
through the whole cycle the UI with the
overlay hey we want to tell you this tip
and the whole takes up one quarter of
the screen like like almost like Xbox
snaps yeah whatever and I'm like bro
could you get off the screen like okay I
got it we got the tip like it's certain
things fundamentally I just want to give
slow motion balls or something you said
he said one third of the skill trees are
dedicated to multiplayer but what if you
don't want or have anyone else to play
with it's like finishing solo plays I
did what again because I felt that way
too okay so I'm absolutely solo too yeah
that's right well they did when we when
we saw it you don't need a friend yeah
when they saw it they were like okay we
know a lot of the pushback is hey this
is an Arcane game you're focusing on
it's multiplayer stuff we're gonna show
you this game is just as capable as a
single player game as an arcane
experienced and so when I get the
pushback about hey love it you know
criticize it for what it is and not what
you want it to be they told me it was
going to be something else yeah you
gotta keep setting shots at me bro yeah
yeah no no no no but not even it it
wasn't you it wasn't you it was no
problem all jokes that you were right
you were right when we had a discussion
you and Maddie were harder on it and I
was more hopeful you know on it but look
it's not about me King has been patient
um I'm gonna make sure you got your bars
outside that we can get because King has
been very patient yes sir all done yeah
man look red fall you know the the
aftermath reviews you know Community is
very upset King you know what I'm saying
they they didn't hear from the King you
know what I'm saying they need to know
what's going on how's he feeling about
this well I heard Ben say you know I'd
rather play it at a cap 30.
got that
we got you covered bro the cap 30 isn't
even really Captain it's it's Captain
sure but it doesn't hit 30. Mr
expectations everywhere they said they
capped over there you you uncapped
you crazy with it
be wild with it he said whatever your
piece you can do is it's my fault it's
my fault it's your fault you wanted 60.
BC go above and beyond
he said I was running around there 190
one time anyway
okay I I can't sit here and cap for this
game
no no no not at all um when I turned the
game on because I was going on Xbox uh
Xbox two plus one yes oh salute ready to
Jazz yeah it was a great show
um
and I turned this game on I said there's
absolutely no way it's what they said
I went on Colt last Monday
Xbox two plus one the next day and um
same thing I gotta hear everybody that's
playing these these NDA dudes that was
playing well I got a chance to touch so
and and yes we have some NDA dudes on
our team one is right here
one is right there two are here
um
he got that code I saw it yeah yeah no
actually the code it was weird the code
came to me and I'm like why the code
coming to me yeah
it's like it's up to you
divvy it out as you choose
yo
I turned it on and I ain't even gonna
lie man
okay so I
play a little dude yeah and um I said
let me get him he wake up in the boat
now I could not believe this was water
oh bro I went to a door and it had like
a broken hose at the top and what they
thought was water coming down
was like a hard if it felt like a
Playstation One the N64 that hard I'm
gonna get to that 64 part okay so we go
on PlayStation one yeah so I heard dudes
talk about that the graphics is 360-ish
that's no cap
[Laughter]
that is okay
that is no cap at all I mean you can
take the best I guess Call of Duty 360
one remember that take those those best
games and some of them out perform this
dude
yo I was walking around
the sparse environment of a shipwreck
right and it's people littered here and
there it's like okay it's like on this
boat there was only five people
and all five of them died they had 10
cars
10 cars five people I don't know the
vampires must have took everybody up all
right
so it's in when I get downstairs
is water again we back to this war yes
yes because we I thought we conquered
water in the 3D space
though he was we was there with it with
the development okay
obviously they didn't get the memo
oh y'all in trouble
I looked at the water so there was some
fake little narrative to tell you why it
looked so horrible
because the solar eclipses happening the
world has stopped
I was like all right it's stupid so I'm
going I'm going in this 360 world but so
it's a 360 World with more polygons
right higher resolution let's get that
out the way yeah not saying better
polygons I just said more okay
so I hear people talking
I have Dolby Atmos bro you can hit him
so normally
on the right they're there yeah they're
above me they're there they belong me I
hit them down there yeah update to the
left I hit them over there these dudes
are talking all around me
I said where are they at preaching I
can't sneak up on anybody to kill
anybody because I don't know where they
at but they talking though and they
sound like they're close to me and I
keep looking around like I had the same
problem
and I don't know until they shoot me yes
yes and then you don't even got the Ping
to be like where Direction
I'm looking for Action you gotta shoot
me for me to get action and I see you
haha then I shoot you
yeah all right so again walking and the
texture popping is crazy yeah yeah
thanks for popping his face why is the
texture popping I got an SSD
what happened to the velocity texture
the velocity texturing what happened to
the mess shaders
that was it was a lot of cap it was a
lot oh I got a molasses
we go we're gonna get to the real issue
the root of the problem we're gonna get
to the water problems all right so
what I think
xenomax is
is a dude that run his company
but he a messy woman all there like you
you feel just trying to get his room in
order
we doing that bad College movie oh man
Phil got his half of the room he just
got it he was like yeah okay so this is
looking good we have to push the little
things back you know but we have Forza
coming and you know he's dropping Hi-Fi
Rush that's a good thing we're doing a
lot of things everything's in order and
they like yo yo yo Todd what you doing
over there
by itself
and Phil is like
um isn't Pete helping you with those
dance moves
you think you can get those dance moves
up to 60.
yo Sam told you and I hate this guy for
being right so always no matter when
these games ship they broken
Bethesda has uh uh a stigma they have a
stink about him
you ever had a roommate that stink that
he don't want to use deodorant oh come
on he got us think about him
Nicola Bethesda isms right y'all be like
y'all be like yeah you know little
quirks and quickies well the quarks in
the quickies will caught up to you
this is this is what happens when
there's no true oversight Microsoft has
been on their side of the room
and they've been yelling over there to
the other side yo Pete y'all good yeah
man
we good
time how does it look it's Todd ready
all right and I know Phil was like
let me go over there and see what's
going on
so redfold there's no way in hell nobody
saw a red phone was like oh no this is
good to go
yo this is it right here we got one what
we're gonna do is what we can control we
put out uh controllers
all right controllers everybody love
controllers we're gonna put out
controllers we're gonna have crazy merch
I've never seen so much merge for a game
that is a first party IP first time out
the door I've never seen so many hoodies
jackets shirts fight back
did you show it off
let's not let's not discuss okay okay I
don't know if they wanted us
when you uh
when you go look at the uh
the designer lab yeah because
um my controller was messing up so Saul
was like we'll go get you one of those
designer ones because I don't need
nothing like that but I was like let me
go over there and look and I go look and
the first thing they offer to you is
redfall designs
and I was like yeah I'm gonna go to
Walmart and just pick up like a regular
green one but you see they they worked
on bamboozling now they pulled your
dudes out
let's get the dudes that rock with us
and we're gonna put them all in a room
and we'll give them the highest end but
y'all didn't know that I was playing 40
90.
nothing else on the operating system but
red four and they gave it to y'all and
they they hit it they gave you a
controller and it was like yeah go ahead
and play and have a good time and yeah
we're not gonna do what we said the game
is about with the full player you know
interaction just gonna let you just go
out that's why they got their effects
when they telling us and then you know
how they do when somebody give you
something they don't really want you to
drive it like you know hey here you go
and then they take it right back
just go down this street and turn
the best part about this this is all
right and it's a limit
the best part about this is we have
buyer protection it's called Game Pass
uh we doing it come on kid we doing that
I don't care the game sucks
yo Ben deleted it and I'm on my way
all right so I listen
seventy dollars
sucks to be you boo boo you could have
did a better deal you could have took
your fifteen dollars see this is how
pimp moves happen so we Justified the
product
okay that's what we're doing we're gonna
justify you getting Hoodwinked because
you could have said all right this don't
make no sense you have seventy dollars
here you have fifteen dollars here I'm
iffy about this game because I know
nothing about it this is not Castlevania
this is not Metal Gear this is not uh
Resident Evil this is not something that
has a pedigree this is a if okay right
and you didn't know what it was anyway
until they told you you needed to have
it you did not know what it was I
thought it was left for dead type of
thing because I love Left 4 Dead yeah
and then I thought okay well maybe
hopefully is better than back for blood
because I didn't like back for blood and
hopefully it's better than it evolves
this thing is worse than all of them
all of them all of them combined but you
have seventy dollars
take 15
or nine dollars go buy a game pass for
tomorrow so it's a little Tippy four
that he bought place you you jumped out
there and you was red flagging too hard
oh okay so how dare he have confidence
and excitement for the product to give
it the money that they they did they
charge fifteen dollars it deserved right
give it to Fifteen dollars you would not
be like this right now well the best
part about paying 15 to play redfall is
that as soon as you delete it you can
play whatever else you want on gameplay
you can play Luke Harold that look worse
than that but better get some Goat
Simulator or something you know
I totally I'm a total Mark for Game Pass
and I rep it all the time but I can't I
can't sit here and say that okay well
it's okay that it was trash thank you
Ben because you should have just got it
on Game Pass like they presented it as a
premium product yes AAA this thing ended
the show this was the just one more
thing guys to end the show I'm not
saying that it's okay that is trash
don't you right never don't ever get
that part confusing thank you my my
message to everyone is Be Frugal with
your dollar the only way this company
will learn if they can't put trash out
is if you don't buy right you know and
then this is going to apply later okay
you don't buy
they see the number engaged in Game Pass
you came in the door for Game Pass see
the best part about Game Pass you came
in the door to see that one chick she
was whacked oh what else you got in here
and I'm over here with this
so at no point in time do you feel
slighted because for your 15 you got
like what three four hundred game so
stop
the problem is is xenomax man I mean uh
um uh Bethesda
they are dancing to the rhythm of their
own music
and Phil just cleaning up his side
we are finding out how dysfunctional
they are
it's every game like Fallout 76 Fallout
um New Vegas these games always had bugs
and problems and y'all overlooked them
y'all thought it was cute
this is what happens when you don't
reprimand somebody hmm
and this IP comes out on Microsoft now I
gotta say Microsoft was like we need a
return on investment more than likely
and this thing was so long in the tooth
that if we cancel this game all the devs
that worked on this project don't get
their bonuses don't get paid don't I
don't know how that goes yeah right but
I know some of their bonuses is tied to
the performance of said game now it
doesn't help if the game comes out and
the performance is trash right
and the game isn't good because I saw a
developer
went on Twitter it's you know she was
basically showing her heart like she
sees peers of her Champion that this
game is bad yeah
that's that's what world are we living
in nobody wants a bad game so yeah the
game should have been canceled the game
should have been deleted because it's
fundamentally a bad game right from the
core it's a bad game aesthetically it's
a bad game
performance Wise It's a bad game it's a
bad game that can't be fixed I don't
believe at any point in time it can be
fixed inside Game Pass I don't care what
patches you do what quests you do at
some point in time that game is gonna
just like Fade to Black I don't think a
sequel comes out for that game this is
one of those I just want to get it out
forget it move on okay all right okay
all right Lord attic man good to see you
brother I don't know if he's still here
man good just good to hear from you
brother we talk about you so yeah I know
this is topic that is passionate to you
so it's cool to see you jump in uh you
know what's your your thoughts on on the
whole red foil and the aftermath and the
reviews and everything
I think my biggest problem with redfall
is how the coverage was covered
um I got no issue with anyone that does
it I understand it's PR's job that's
their whole thing but I feel like the
whole industry and not just particularly
this this game
could really start to redefine how PR is
done yeah and and it's not anyone's
fault because I feel like
what happened with redfall where you
know where you guys were talking earlier
about you know saw felt Bamboozled over
the the way that the pr was handled it's
not a Bethesda thing it's not an Xbox
thing it's an industry thing and I've
spoke about it multiple times that you
know the industry needs to do a better
job at being more transparent with
products uh you know you know what's you
know what's going to sell better than a
game that you kind of false advertise to
a degree a game that you actually put
time into and you have no problem
showing that time that confidence yeah
and to me that's just the biggest thing
I didn't like it's like you know
I'm not saying that
the game that we played before was night
and day difference but I am saying it's
it was dramatically different and to me
I can handle a game that's underwhelming
all day long I can't handle a game that
I felt like people were trying to sell
me something else
and I think that's the biggest issue is
you know and and plus what does that do
too you know I I'm sure it's like I said
these PR people they're just trying to
they're doing their job but at the same
time
you making you're making influences look
mad suspect when they go through these
kind of things
and it's just like it's not cool it's
not you know and I feel like
hiding the fact that the game was 30
frames for so long definitely doesn't
make you look good and that's why like
it's very important that us that people
understand this is not a particular
Studio this seems like an industry-wide
thing because uh you know shout out to
the people I was reviewing uh Jedi and I
just been I almost have the review done
but there's just no way I was getting to
it uh this weekend but you know they
low-key sent me the review code like mad
late and then if when I was reading the
Embargo it was just pretty much like oh
you don't have to worry about the day
one patches they're already in
and I'm like oh so you sent me these
after the day one patches and to me that
is
that's that's an issue there too it's
like you shouldn't be expecting these
reviewers to review something and not ex
and not be honest about the game and the
condition it was when they reviewed it
like what's the point in having a day
one patch that fixes the majority of the
issues when you could have theoretically
just pushed the game like two or three
weeks and let them play it the game
that's supposed to be released and not
oh we're gonna play the game for for a
week
with without the day one patch and then
it's like they kind of expect you to go
back and replay it yeah oh but this this
is this is the way the game's going to
be launched but that's not the way I
played it yeah that's the reviewer
played it in the pre-patch state so he's
given one opinion then sometimes you'll
see the community attack the reviewer
because then they'll have the patch
version and they'll be like it's like
I'll give you a good example uh me and
smooth play Gears five
work just fine no issues but what ended
up happening
is they did the online
they did the online connected to like a
Lobby like a connection based right so
we're on here saying yo the game worked
good we had no issues it looks from our
review perspective oh the game has no
issues but then when when when the
servers kicked on and it was
overwhelming it me and smooth got
I would say to the last act before the
game and uh went live when that game
went live we couldn't connect to each
other anymore we couldn't play the game
individually uh I mean together anymore
like I if I remember correctly we had to
beat that game individually to review it
wow so it was only the last act but it's
just like you know this kind of scenario
it's like now what's going to end up
happening is
you're gonna have some people looking
mad sucks oh why ain't you talking about
these issues because this wasn't part of
the game when we were playing I know the
feeling and that's why I just I
personally feel like you know once again
the entire industry needs to be more
transparent they need to stop giving
reviewers games that they know for a
fact need a day one patch to to to to uh
to run properly and I feel like
that is the that's the that's the lowest
bar that's there like to be transparent
with your consumers feels like the bare
minimum 60 frames on the back on the box
or remember that and it's just you know
even obviously you look at you look at
Red Ball I do feel like the game was
underwhelming uh to a vast
majority I feel like I was nauseous I
had to uninstall it like you guys called
I was literally nauseous I had to beg
him to do like three more levels with me
I need to experience to co-op please it
was just like this isn't it man and the
sad part about it is I do
Xbox for the most part I will say
they've been having better reviewed
games and I feel like even though that
they've had better review games a lot of
them have been like you know the uh you
know a form like double A stuff and you
know some indie level stuff and the the
sad part about it is all that all that
good will that they've been building up
I feel like a point releasing your first
big AAA title in this condition because
this is to me to my personal opinion I
enjoyed Crackdown more than redfall
because at least when I played the
single player I really enjoyed the
single player of Crackdown I didn't
enjoy much redfall at all and it sucks
because
Arcane is one of my OG Studios that I
love and to me you can ask hog I was
like look I don't I want this game to
succeed just because I don't want Arcane
being turned into a support Studio
because they're still going to lose
faith in the studio or or dissolved yeah
gentlemen I don't think they would
dissolve them yet I I you know who knows
it's just one of those things it's like
at the end of the day my biggest thing I
could take from redfall is the industry
needs to be drastically more transparent
with us you uh and and you know again
reviewers I get it
when you review something you need those
clicks especially people that do it full
time but if the industry won't
self-correct itself and the reviewers
continuously review under these
circumstances then at that point the
reviewers are just as fault as the
actual people doing it because they can
stand up for it too sure I get it you
might have a couple games that you know
you don't get day uh you don't get out
day one but guess what when the industry
starts having these games these massive
games not having 50 60 reviews and it's
got two or three they're gonna start
saying yo what can we do to get these
these reviewers happy I don't think the
reviewers realize how much actual power
they have but it takes money out there
it takes more than a couple yeah like
the whole industry got to come together
people are tired of working under weird
embargo lifts and section A has it first
and section b gets it second then
everyone's got to come together and say
until you fix these crazy rules that
shouldn't have been applied I ain't
reviewing nothing from your studio the
only reason why I have to give you a
little bit of pushback on that is
because everybody in this space is me me
yeah but that's not going to change
because me walks into the store to pay
my bills me make sure that my channel is
up and running me so I'm not gonna lean
over and say hey man are you going to
take a stand with me
because he got to get his views up too
I'm not necessarily saying that like we
see this in the uh like not this
industry all the time I mean there's
people in France right now having giant
strikes for retirement age
unions there's no and I feel but people
go on strike all the time that's not
part of you do you have you see you see
massive amounts of Staff just leaving
leaving the thing and going in a picket
line like to me I get it and it's not an
easy conversation to to not necessarily
because they were a lot of these
reviewers especially the bigger ones
they'll be able to get that money
regardless maybe the views won't be
exactly where it was and it's a hard
thing to ask people to to kiss away a
perfect chat yeah but at the same time
when who who's gonna make a step first
the industry that has set the boundaries
or the people that keep going against
about the with the boundaries and to me
I I don't see the industry pushing back
that much I don't and maybe it's going
to come on us the uh the influence the
podcasters the streamers is going to
come on us to do something because the
industry why would the industry change
something that's working so well for
them
and that's that's my biggest thing it's
like I've always said on this podcast
multiple times over and over again I'm
for transparency and actually being
honest and I'm for anything else that at
the same time I can understand why they
do it I do because you know uh when you
set a system up like that's been set up
it's hard to say yo let's try something
else but at the same time if they ain't
gonna do anything about it and start to
put more policies in place in the end
and the reviewers won't take a stand
either then where are we ever gonna fix
it
yeah I hear where you're coming from
it's a very very controversial subject
because of the fact of access and you
know it's one of those things because
like King said there's always going to
be someone where if they're not big
enough if you're big enough to say hey
and I'm good you know I'm saying oh I'm
gonna pay for my own game and I'm not
going to let's be honest this whole
thing is about access let's just do it
this is my sad part is in order to grow
in this industry to a certain degree you
do need some form of Industry access
unless you have like a huge amount of
money pulling it somewhere else and the
pot to your point the powers that be
will say hey okay you decline you feel
away there's always going to be care to
create a b and c who they're just trying
to get their Channel off they're trying
to get make a move and you know I don't
know the answer to it I don't know it's
a tough conversation and I don't know if
there's an answer to it but I do know
one thing the way things are going now
something got to change industry for
sure or a couple really really big uh
reviewers coming together and saying
they're not messing with that game yeah
with this embargo something's got to
change because we're having more and
more of these incidences all the time
like games are being broken almost right
for sure for sure and sometimes
sometimes reviewers say sometimes they
don't and it's it's just it's the
transparency on everything it's like I
said don't the people in the chat this
isn't just a one developer one publisher
thing the entire industry does this to a
point yeah look I get my balls up Quicks
everybody got this off um look
this game man I got so much thoughts it
first of all is just a major
disappointment it just it is I'm beyond
this is an embarrassment to me you know
I'm saying because at the end of the day
this game was delayed a Year y'all
we we we keep in mind called This is
their first 70 game makes it worse and
it's requiring 70 and here's the thing
y'all know me like the thing that really
bought I said this on Duke that really
bothered me about this situation is yo
my word means everything to me people
come to me and say yo [__] what do we
think what are you where you at yo if
you're with it you know we'll trust it
and look I'm not gonna sit there and say
that I I did feel slightly deceived by
this situation because look
went to this thing like King said it had
to be 1490s it had to be on the best
Hall clearly it was not you know series
X but it's just like what I played was a
smooth experience right when I played it
had density right I'm not going to say
it was frame perfect but it was
definitely 60. you know what I'm saying
it was definitely smooth and I walked
away from it like solve said like okay
I'll be consistent they got to fix this
AI because I was like some of these
cultists I'm like bro I'm writing your
corner Vision how you don't see me you
know what I'm saying some of that I did
like how that the vampires was moving
you know what I'm saying kind of thing
but what I played at that time I said
okay we just got to see how this story
is going to land how this co-op's gonna
land and maybe in retrospect looking
back out of it looking back out of it
like this is your Co-op debut but you're
only letting us play the single player
you know what I said looking back at it
now right and L on me the only thing I
will hold is that I should have asked is
the console version going to be
representative of this or at least 60
frames right I should have asked that
but again for all intensive purposes I
thought this is what we're going to be
playing so it didn't even cross my mind
at that time all I was thinking about
okay all the stuff that Harvey was
talking about as far as Studio
development and as far as the the
adversity they went through as far as
getting the game out and then as far as
my main concern was you know the four
player untethered experience from a
cpu's perspective I didn't tell them I
did understand that what bothered me is
now fast forward
you know we know how this go man you
know generally companies that feel
confident
you get that too weak ahead of time cold
so now we're getting down to the why and
I'm just
going on the week and then you know
attic is firing up on me like the attic
is like yo bro way to join that yo and
I'm like yo chill chill
and I'm like I'm checking it it ain't
there right then I'm starting it some
people don't need to do with the 49ers
there's some people are starting some
people are starting to get it
and you know viewers talk about
themselves like
results ain't really sounding promises
all right somebody who hit me like bro
he getting like day or two before
release manage I had to literally
finally get it then you know and I'm
like all right knock it up not gonna
complain I'm not gonna sound privileged
you know I'm not gonna sound entitled we
did get it okay fine but I'm like look
at the time like we said the time we got
it we like we ain't gonna make this
embargo so all was what's the long net
rule either making Impressions or you do
uh tips and tricks and then we just
we're gonna miss we don't go extra hard
and slay people just to make the Embargo
we want the proper experience my mood
did his thing slow to you brother you
killed that with the tips and trains
that did impression and then after
embargo you made the review in a normal
time but we didn't have much time to
operate what now bothers me is the word
starts to get out
and I'm like it's soft it's one thing to
be like yo the game is packed there's
another thing to be like yo this is the
worst game I have ever played like this
is functionally broken I'm like and my
mind I'm like yo how how is that like
that's not so now I'm like nah this is
bothering me because now remember Cog is
taking yo it's a solid experience we
just got that was my initial impressions
call up addict shout out to DJ I'm like
yo get this series X let's let's get
this I need to see what people are
talking about yo I swear to God this was
not the game
bro we fired it up I'm like yo
what is this like King is like this
feels like 360 like I'm in Bend energy
it's so bad like I am laughing like to
the point where I remember that game the
darkness yes yeah bro it's so bad that
I'm looking me and Adam are looking at
each other's characters and their feet
are not matching the terrain yes and
they're like I'm like yo this is some
360 N64 energy like what is going on
this is not I said attic I swear to God
the gay version that we played was way
better than this like what is going on
for the console and it's just it's just
it's just a terrible look it is it's a
terrible look you know did you have
access to the whole game or was it just
a slice it was literally a slice of Us
coming out of the firehouse from the
beginning right it was the slice before
the boat I mean after excuse me after
that after the boat I don't know how
some of those problems were fixed but
that I mean that gives you some excuse
that they didn't you weren't playing the
whole game right they had perfected a
portion of it but here's the part that
was scary for the console me and addict
and DJ we're we're running mad blocks
I'm not I'm hearing voices and not
seeing no enemies
I'm going mad but I see one person so
I'm like the game that I played was dead
star who remember they as soon as you
come out the firehouse you you go down
those that little ramp steps into the
park there was like the blue area the
gate that's vampires there was cultists
moving back and forth there was enemy
density like I'm just like yo what is
this I felt so bad at the castle
experience I'm like yo this is not it
this is the fat fish yeah like bro like
it was different so that's the part you
know what I'm saying I will stand on my
squid at least I did call you look like
her IG picture yeah she did not look
like her IG picture oh so that's my
thing and it's just like you know the AI
ends up being worse and look I'm not
gonna run too deep with it but it's just
like to me it's kind of what y'all said
earlier like this felt like
pre-acquisition Bethesda you know what
I'm saying this felt like yo we're gonna
try to catch a wave we need to do
something and at some point who stamped
finish
finished and said this is a goal this is
unacceptable and that to me is an
indicative of the pipeline at some point
I understand and we're going to get into
you know obviously it's going to
transition into the field thing and
we'll get into it but it's like at some
point there has to be the quality
control pipeline they need a whole
police right so so what happened to Each
one teach one though what happened to
the to the week once once every three
months we have group meetings and we
exchange technology this way who was it
and we're gonna get to that we're gonna
get to that but this is clearly a
problem with
pre-acquisition projects of a company
that now has been acquired this pipeline
has to be because this is unacceptable
and the Xbox fan base you're charging
seven dollars for this game I don't want
to hear about oh it's gonna go on
Gamepad and then we gonna fix it later
that sets a dangerous precedent and a
dangerous perception shooting on Optics
that you could just throw something in
and okay we'll deal with it later and
let's get back to the store yeah Xbox
deserves better Xbox is Right better so
that's it you know I deserve it yeah
absolutely so that's all I want to say
we're going to get into the meat of this
how does it feel being catfished
not fun bro it hurts because yeah you
know what they sound like Ben remember
that guy it was in the papers that he
sued his wife uh he got married to her
and then he woke up the next morning she
didn't have the makeup and all that
stuff
we call the police oh
but if you enjoy your merch and your
special edition so I gotta know how much
you buy for redfall before the game
actually I'm I'm good I'm good the I
didn't go in with anything I I do have a
shirt so even you had doubts is what
you're saying no I did I did this all
yeah you had doubts you went by the
merch yeah you know because you know I'm
a couple of defy the Duke with the shirt
if I feel it if I'm all the way in you
know you're gonna see that shirt that
week about listen my Starfield jacket
just can't I'm going in I'm hoping you
know I got the boys bro I got this I got
the Starfield bubble Goose I'm ready in
the summertime but look now you're okay
you're in your defense yes I was I was a
little gun shy let me see but I did but
it was like you've been it was one of
them choices I thought I was gonna like
this is me in the homies four players
and there's some aspects of it you can
see that they it's a part of a game
there when you're going through the door
through the vampire nest and but it's
just so simple game design everything is
oh you don't know how to get through
this get a key find the key get to the
next level yeah
we got to get to the main event of this
let us um get these super checks and
then yeah I guess these super chats and
then I gotta handle some business yeah
like follow And subscribe and this is if
this is your first time checking out
iron Lords podcast uh subscribe
you know Ben is having a great time it
felt you haven't even felt the four
hours yet have you been like four hours
yeah and I told Ben it's gonna be a
later show we pushing it right now um
let's get to see what channel we gotta
pay something Max arthony with the two
pound Super Chat can confirm the red the
red full credits run at 60fps
thank you for your your digital Foundry
technical analysis my menu is a steady
120.
those credits for lit thank you then we
have project Aries new member five
dollar Super Chat all of Microsoft's
Acquisitions no one considered the
amount of employees not happy but
willing to finesse the bag job security
is greater than bare minimum work I'll
never say they put bare minimum Works
they worked hard on this obviously it
just feels like a lot of times when when
the heart of it isn't there the the
final product just isn't going to work
and that's what I feel like this is you
know yeah I know this I know they worked
hard yeah yeah
and we have Matt without fear remember
for one year five pounds Super Chat
clippy was like it looks like you're
trying to make a triple A game would you
like some help with that
yo because I could visualize that I'm
going to the bathroom I'll be back
we have Malcolm X LAX lax3 relax three
five dollar Super Chat in the current
state redfall is in the current in its
current state redfall is that
Blockbuster Game Pass weekend game buggy
unfinished but you see the potential
um yeah like I said maybe I'll change my
mind too we'll see I don't know it's
gonna take something dramatic yeah then
we have Spartan go 17 two pound Super
Chat my man's Phil catch it more L's
than Dylan Brooks chill I wouldn't put
that on Phil but you know heavy is the
head that holds the crown so stick
around buckle
then we have Robert kellett two dollar
Super Chat Cog Maddie and Saab got the
special build yeah we certainly did
so did Colt and everybody everybody else
got a chance to be wined and done it was
IG modeling look the same on the outside
of those lights right yeah that was one
of those things I you know as soon as we
finished our playthrough I talked to
Maddie I talked to college like there's
an a console to be found here it's all
workstations uh you learning experience
yeah definitely to keep your eyes open
and ears open chat I see you clippy just
showing all of our age yes sir yes he is
then we have Max arthny again five pound
Super Chat Wolfenstein young blood and
red four are so similar on paper just
one just ran a lot better than the other
incredibly disappointing yes very
disappointing not true not true
not true
I just wolf inside is a better game yeah
you just fundamentally it's up at a game
this is an unknown IP that made you care
about and strung you along yeah and you
should have saw the sign we should have
saw this we should have been flags all
over the place yeah now looking back at
retrospect but yeah I can see what
you're going yeah
so we have darn thread with the 100 SEC
uh super chat if PC is Master race then
how come you need dlss for fake brings
to get good performance oh shots I
didn't say I turned on DLS
he can Brute Force anything yeah exactly
so you heard that I don't need that bro
yeah
what's this deal
is that the best SSD kid
I think that we have an issue that I
personally saw with red Falls I feel
like they tried to take red Falls uh
like arcane's signature gameplay and
divide it with four characters so I've
said it yeah and I I feel like the
biggest issue there is you know
they could have did more with the map
where it felt like the people like the
bad guys actually had relevancy in the
map yeah there's little things they
could have done and early in the
development that I felt like would have
would have went a long way yeah like use
technology
like use Dolby Atmos like use LOD like
used mesh shaders like use the velocity
architecture like use something that the
Xbox say they could do you already made
too because that wasn't rdna at all
Raphael call Antonio left Arcane maybe
it is why
um he will be associated
with the future of them
and yeah we got to see him exactly so
we'll see what happens
um bone slaves after bone slaves Cali in
the building Cali IOP in the building
five dollar Super Chat redfall should
have been uh marketed as a smaller title
or free to play game the backlash
wouldn't have been so bad I do think
that if I do think if this game would
come out like 30 40 dollars
it would have been a little bit better
on them it still would have gotten like
uh crucified during the the reviewing
process but I do think people will be
like look because the moment you start
rating stuff especially your first 70
product you you're you're putting
expectations on that can't be
realistically met and I think like once
again that's not an issue with this in
particular that's the industry issue too
there's so many games that come out that
I'm like look at this game would have
been half the price or 20 less this game
would have got received way better and
it probably would have sold more
yeah and we've got to push for quality
then we have Robert kellett uh two
dollar Super Chat it has slow down on
series X stop defending the King was
playfully defending them then he got to
the rear continue and we have Max you
can come for me all in like okay you
know you you can't have an opinion King
you gotta agree with me King because my
opinion is right and yeah cheater of
your little sovereign
[Laughter]
[Music]
Super Chat I love it but Game Pass is
about to become an interactive Museum of
failed first party games from XBox jeez
jeez it's a bit harsh but yeah it's
probably coming from an individual that
hasn't been able to keep up with the
payments of Game Pass
don't do that to his wallet don't do
that they had to come and repossess your
game I know you you went in and you saw
a big
I'm gonna try this red phone
you make a seventy dollars
oh man don't do that to that man
finances like that the way your
checkings and savings is made
some of the the Savages I see in this
chat I wouldn't be surprised if he
literally re uh re-super chats fifteen
dollars and say take that punk
he can do that but I would tell him take
that 15 to go get game back
all right people's wallet we gotta get a
person that is not in the ecosystem but
I will say this yes they they have to
change the narrative and the perception
by hitting with their AAA first party
Quality quality I have to do that all
right then we have Robert Kelly uh two
dollar Super Chat good job giving them
the smoke it deserves Kings okay
y'all know what I do I tell it like it
is I don't care what nobody's saying but
I'm an Xbox homer so don't ever think
that oh at the end they messed up so bad
I'm going to PlayStation at the end of
the day we might put a little spice on
our stuff for you know Community relief
but we actually do care about all these
Brands succeed and we're going to give
them the smoke that they deserve I want
PlayStation to become an app six
people don't understand the
website and then one panel member of One
writer
writers not reflect
Reflections
website and said podcast please and best
believe it
then we have Nick's five dollars if you
had shout out to Phil's Ghostwriter they
once again have King watching the
interview with a box of tissue while
holding his chain for dear life oh Jesus
Jesus yes this is true and shout out to
you for listening with your ears closed
all right so we'll backslap remember for
two years ten dollar Super Chat lessons
redfall goes as low as 21 FPS on Xbox
almost as low an FPS as the flip book
cut scenes whoa wow how how do you do a
reveal trailer with high quality
animation and don't have anything close
in the actual game bait and switch yeah
I felt when I saw those cut scenes I was
like man that felt like a budget thing
like that was really yeah yeah remember
when I saw it and I came back and I was
like it looked like 60 I was talking
crazy out my neck I look like 60. I
thought I was playing as dusk Falls
yo but that wasn't happening as much fun
speaking of windshield how did it feel
to be the main character
that is the main character okay you look
like you better I'm going there I'm
going there
Ben's like where's the check though I'll
get the check he said I got a better bid
then we got pixel bit G remember for 40
months Lord bronze
redfall got everything from controllers
to t-shirts why they don't have what
they don't have is a game
pass don't get me back my my bite back
DLC cost yes there is DLC coming for
this game you paid for that I guess it's
yes separate it's not going into game
pass that I know of maybe that's DLC
coming they said they come they bring in
more characters more characters
what it said it won't get you back your
DLC cause so you planning on investing
into a bad game well there are plans for
DLC yeah so yeah but he's planning he
just told you it ain't gonna get me back
my money that I'm planning to give to
this broken girl they gave already gave
already oh when they buy the game
outside yeah they bought it no uh if
even if you play it in Game Pass you can
go and buy the the DLC uh a la carte if
you want oh [__] I don't think you for
being Forward Thinking shout out to
maybe you could go to Microsoft and said
I hit that button by mistake I thought
that was today baby
anyway time that we have later
tagging nut sacks oh he's back oh he's
back he's back that's all he wanted to
say you want to make sure we read his
name yeah
and he came back again sagging nut sack
once again with the two pound super
attack red fall wallpapers fire though
man we talk about the wallpaper then we
got Gerald back remember for two years
five dollar Super Chat all hail the ILP
let's hope redfall is a valuable lesson
about being so hands off with these
Studios yes pipeline mommy cannot go to
the store without without leaving
somebody watching the kids
then we got sagging nut sack once again
10 pound Super Chat
honest we're eating good backlog is
crazy I just finished Raven lock
Benedict Fox's next yeah I will wait
till I will wait till 60 FPS drop to
redfall Game Pass is keeping me engaged
till the Heavy Hitters drop right keep
sagging bro keep saying
nuts
[Laughter]
then we got Iron Mike ten dollars Tyson
still not understanding what did you
guys play when you got when you got
flown out we weren't flown out
yo they're trying to do us 30 seconds
I do think I do think we need to like
clear up the confusion on that what it's
not like they gave us a different game
what they pretty much did is they gave
the best perspectives
yeah it's what I think the expectation
was but again no console version there
right he's no version no Co-op and and
and it was it was dense and populated in
a way that the final game just today
until now I haven't seen it it's not
representative
I didn't make it because
I would be so heated I told you about
the time I got catfish I would be so
heated boy I would because I'm still got
scars from the catfishing the catfish
man they got my man
oh like how you say that
so either questions when we got flown
out yes we got flown out AI on point
with the performance on point was the
gameplay look more engaging yes
everything he said it was running at 60.
go check out the free episode of
defining Duke ultimate with the preview
with Maddie Cog and myself all of that
is in there absolutely yeah trust me
absolutely I also gotta say like the I
think you guys sat in a really small
couch as well
it was killing me they were Cog has too
much muscle to be sitting on that side
ultimate conversation yeah
[Laughter]
don't be doing me like that bro
so we're gonna give you free control
again
that's wow y'all
about brothers
[Laughter]
man
that's all you need
to be about Brooke last word is canceled
next week
preview on on ddu it's all there it's
all there man challenge
they're like yo there's no space for you
to do the interview as well so I was
like No Doubt
okay bro what are the funniest comments
on the video was no two girl [__] if
you want to couch
it got the most cops I think it was
wrong but you had the funniest comments
salute to y'all for cloud I mean that
was hilarious hilarious then we have Max
arthay once again two pound Super Chat
red flop powered by the all 12 teraflops
oh my God
yeah sagging nut sack once again five
pound Super Chat and King it goes both
ways it's lights out for both whoever
lands the first Punch Remember Joshua
can box but Wilder cannot
see this is the difference
wilda has a chin yeah he survived by
having a chin what he also has is the
hand of God when he touches him and he
short circuits his body I just want you
to be there on live with me just just
come hang out and I'm going to show you
first round me and you're gonna have
drinks later
then we got Rumble Grumble chat so cool
to see working class Consciousness hit
Lord addicts Bob spontaneously no way to
push back as individuals needs
Collective action yeah yeah it's true
then we have Max arthay again two dollar
Super Chat red four Feels Like An Early
Access title from 10 years ago yep yeah
that's fair that is absolutely Fair
okay and we got ebontists five dollar
Super Chat games can come and go but the
iron Lords are forever all right you
back you back
he said that already
yeah
common is what I'm acknowledging
continue that's my bro we have Spartan
go 17 two pound super chat this joint
felt like Eminem Revival album Trash
damn oh my goodness yes at least he has
some good tracks
all right let me roll back a little bit
I think we're mostly good we got it no
no no no no no no hold on a second yeah
I got jumped a little bit okay we have
Lord Metroid member for 19 months Lord
silver good Sav is here now the Super
Test won't be in the track oh don't be
killing me an attic like that we tried
our best is it the best come on the best
we could I was trash I appreciate that
yeah everybody owns it that's what makes
it funny he's like look y'all go get
this work I don't care your name is this
today
call me the courthouse yeah yeah I'll
change your name yeah yeah he's
hilarious with me eating rice and beans
and
ILP perfect Sunday thank you
oh man this is crazy then we got
lockmart with the two Euros
God bless this league of bald men yeah
yes
when the red fall TV show when is the
red fall TV show coming out that'd be
funny right okay he might be better as a
TV show everything but the game
can't be worse then we got hard to find
two dollars to be chat Casting Couch
[__] is what they call him
Triple C
who said that that was hard to find
block him
I was too good to see Savage
a second
there we go
sagging that sack once again two pounds
Super Chat Joshua has a chin too I don't
know everybody have a chin technically
on their body his made out of glass
there we have Max arthay again two
pounds Super Chat I'm stuck at 10 FPS
step hey is Steph is Steph Steph Cog
Steph Cog I'm stuck at The NPS
then we have Cog no Nito
God no need to shout out to my bro bro
for doing his thing it's a shame he's
hidden from the world for playing
Nintendo but
Luke that we have gaming for today
the unfortunate result from all of this
is that people will stop trusting what
content creators and influencers have to
say about a game especially when they're
floating up
also hey King boo-boo
let's say You're supposed to be holding
us down man
gotta pay the bill so gentlemen remember
don't no speaking no no speaking while I
pay the bills your silence on the set
even if it seems like I'm talking to you
no doubt so
give me one moment
yeah so this show is sponsored by better
help
so let me ask you guys a question
how much time do you really spend on
yourself in any given week and how much
time do you spend on other people
how do you balance the two things do how
are you even able to balance the two
things it's really easy to get caught up
in what everyone else needs from you and
never take a moment to think about what
you need from yourself
for me personally as all of you guys
well know I work anywhere from 15 to 17
hours a day Monday through Friday and
then on the weekends they're dedicated
to my wife to my parents to my niece and
my nephews and of course to IOP
so when you spend so much time taking
care of other things and other people it
could kind of leave you feeling a little
bit stretched then and quite frankly
burned out right and honestly therapy
can give you the tools that you need to
find more balance in your life so that
you can keep supporting and taking care
of the people that you love without
leaving yourself behind now for me
while I haven't gone to therapy for
these things that I just talked about
many years ago I went through a very
difficult divorce and although I felt
that a great weight had been lifted from
me upon my divorce I still found it
really difficult to navigate my feelings
while trying to get my life in order
I took the advice of friends and family
after you know talking to them and what
I realized is that advice from people
that are close to you that love you is
great but sometimes you need that
objective point of view from someone
that doesn't know you so I went ahead
and went to therapy and I have to say
that it helped me immensely to focus on
the positive aspects of like removing
myself from a toxic situation
while not getting sort of drowned by the
emotional the physical and the financial
realities quite frankly of ending a
10-year relationship with someone that I
had planned to spend the rest of my life
with
it helped me to learn
how to take positive organizational and
sort of coping skills and how to set
boundaries for myself when dealing with
other people and when other people sort
of try to cross lines with me
and ultimately it really empowered me to
try to strive to be the very best
version of myself
and the great thing that I realized
about therapy more more than anything
else is the fact that it's not
necessarily just for those big traumatic
moments that we experience in life but
it's also very helpful just for dealing
with the day-to-day stresses and
anxieties that we go through in our in
our daily lives
so
with all of that said
if you're going through something in
your life that's difficult that you feel
like you know your family can't help you
with or anyone else can't help you with
and you're thinking about going to
therapy give better help a try
betterhelp is entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule all you got to
do is just go to the website fill out a
brief questionnaire and you'll get
matched with a licensed therapist now if
you find that this therapist isn't a
match for you don't get frustrated just
you can go right back to the site you
can switch therapists the times that you
want for no additional cost until you
feel comfortable with the therapist that
you're working with and another thing
about Better Health that's great it's
just the fact that you don't have to
deal with the awkwardness of having to
go into an office and deal with the
Dynamics of of getting to know someone
personally and laying on a couch and and
things like that if you don't feel
comfortable with that you can do it over
the Internet a zoom call you don't even
have to show your face if you want to so
honestly it is it is so simple to get
the help that we need to get our lives
in order so
if you need to find more balance in your
life
go to betterhelp so for us if you visit
betterhelp.com iron Lords today you'll
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
h-e-l-p.com slash Iron Lords no doubt no
doubt chat link is in the description
y'all you know what I mean so thank you
guys appreciate y'all appreciate y'all
for listening solve his honest thing
they're calling you
know the chat as well every day yeah we
needed this right after refwork yo yeah
out of pocket I know what y'all doing
but health is wealth is mental health
agreed so look man let's get into it man
I appreciate that song Let's get into
the main event here um yeah man uh Phil
Davis Spencer man Thomas Maximus it was
outside or shot the kind of funny man it
was a very very big interview
shout out to Paris throwback bank and uh
Gary winner and um yeah there was some
some key quotes you know so I'm trying
to pull those up from from the article
in reference to you know the whole deal
of um you know
redfall obviously the disappointment
from the community you know as far as
the comments about you know not trying
to be in the business of out consoing
Sony or out console in Nintendo so yeah
you know I'm just gonna read a couple of
excerpts you know so from it you know I
said I know this will he said we're not
in the business of you know console link
he said is it really a great solution or
win for us all I know is that that will
upset a ton of people but the truth of
the matter is when you're third place in
the console Marketplace and the top two
players are strong as they are and have
in certain cases a very discreet focus
on doing deals and other things that
kind of make being Xbox hard for us as a
team that's on us not on anybody else
now this is probably the one that
probably got the most response where uh
Phil said I see it out there I see
commentary commentary that if you just
build great games everything would turn
around it's not just true that if we go
off and build great games all of a
sudden you're going to see console share
shift in some dramatic way we lost worst
generation to lose in the Xbox one
generation where everyone built their
Digital Library of games this idea that
if we just focus more on great games and
on our console that somehow we're going
to win the console race I think does it
relate to the reality of most people he
said around 90 of people who buy
consoles each year are already in one of
the three major console ecosystems and
that switching costs are higher now that
people have established the digital
libraries offset of that Xbox one
generation he talked about
um obviously the the fortnites the
Roblox and the Minecraft as far as all
games that were available last year and
that people that continually still
playing and then he went on to say I
know some people want us to hold us to
hold us up as being a better Green
version of what the blue guys do and I'm
just going to say that's not a win for
Xbox and staying in the wake of somebody
else we have to go off and do our own
thing with game pass with the stuff we
do with xcloud and the way we build our
get our games so yeah I mean is just so
much exercise here there's um you know
he took accountability for the whole
redfall situation you know he's not
pointing the finger at anyone he said
he's going to he said at some point I
have enough knocks against me that it's
going to be someone else here but I
think it's transparency and what we're
building what our aspiration is for the
game what it's going to look like what
the features are and it drives me crazy
that when we have self-inflicted wounds
of putting things out there and
communication that's confusing or
misleading about what the actual brand
product is going to be there's tons more
quotes I know you guys know most of them
but the gist of it is most people feel
it seems to be a split there's some
people who feel look this is the
probably the most transparent a leader
of a corporation a Gaming Corporation is
ever going to be that should be saluted
and then there's other talk that is like
look this is a defeatist attitude we
shouldn't be talking about third place
and and things of that nature and then
the great games comments so look I want
to actually yeah let's start with let's
start with let's start with at it
because I don't know how much time he
has
um you know when you hear all these
comments and I know you made a video you
know what's your thought process on Phil
on the on the kind of funny interview
just some of the things he said
I feel like
to some degree I agree I agree with Phil
uh but I do feel like he doesn't put the
value on good games that should be put
the value on you know owning a platform
there's more to it than just good games
there's messaging there's relationships
but
the good games I would say is like
70 to 80 percent of the problem you
consistently give out good games you're
going to change the perception around
yourself you'll start to get more and
more people to gravitate towards your
actual platform regardless if it's their
PC or or if it's the Xbox and slowly
you'll gain that that momentum a little
bit of it back and then you can use that
to leverage other things in the industry
but to me
it feels like
he values and he puts a lot of value in
the good games but I don't think he
really it's something he don't realize
first of all I don't know exactly what
he meant by that and I wish he could
have elaborated a hundred percent what
you meant by that I feel like he left a
two Bland where it could be decrypted
multiple ways but to me it's like look
we got to understand that
after last generation and you know a
good year year and a half of this
generation people aren't going to look
at your your your platform is like the
place to go play games but if you start
to slowly fix that narrative you're
going to see more and more people
gravitate towards it because they're not
picking up a game because they feel like
okay you know I could play this but I
don't know what's going to happen in the
future like when people pick up a
PlayStation 5 that know the brand they
know they're gonna have stuff in the
future
right now it's up in the air with Xbox
because they're so inconsistent with
what they do and until you fix that
consistency and that perception people
are going to look at your brand that way
and that's pretty much all I got to say
but I'm going to take off you guys good
to hear thank you thank you for showing
up it's good to hear for you brother
we're going to talk get through it and
like I said man feel better feel better
brother I'd love to see love to hear
from you today I see so uh let's get up
skills I guess man our steamed guests or
the Ben Smith comment sir these are
making the rounds man you know Phil is
trending there are thoughts even though
it's gaming hats this week that we're
trending well shout out to the Rose
experience you know what I'm saying he
had his thoughts too you know it's a
contentious time like what's your
thought process on any of the comments
that Phil made does anything resonate
with you where yet with this Phil
Spencer interview well first I wanna I
wanna shout out the actual interview
itself
um I thought it was well done and I know
from personal experience and and from
hearing others that when you're talking
to these you know Big Time execs that
got tons of PR and managers and
everything else like you got to run
questions yes and sometimes maybe you
can get a slip away with a question that
wasn't approved or something like that
good point but whether they did the
slip-ins or whether they got good
questions approved like these were real
questions these were softballs yes so
you know
um a big props on that so either Xbox or
kind of funny or both yes but I'm sorry
as far as his comments like I think
whether Phil is just a good spokesperson
or whether he's a totally genuine dude
like he seemed relatable and open and
honest and we don't get that from
everybody we haven't even gotten that
from Phil sometimes in the past there's
been times and right now he's seen you
know it seemed very real and transparent
and there was part of me that was like
okay part of this is for you know the
placate the fan base and part of it's to
interrupt you one quick second Paris was
in the chat who conducted the interview
he said we were not censored to any
questions we could ask whatever we
wanted that's great that's awesome yeah
perfect
um that's that's good on I mean that's
great on Xbox that's that's awesome
um but I I thought I thought they asked
the good questions then how's that yeah
no no they had if they had the option to
ask whatever they wanted and didn't shy
away from the good questions that's
that's great that's good journalism
that's good work uh anyway I think that
that Phil just
I agree with what a lot is what he's
saying about you know we're not going to
become the market leader overnight we're
not going to do this through that but I
agree with what addict was saying is
that I don't really understand the
mindsets of good games won't get get
more people to buy our console yeah
maybe it doesn't rocket you in the first
place in 18 months or something but for
me like right now I mean I play most of
my games on PC I play exclusives on PS5
and I have my Xbox for basically for
game pass because I want to play in my
recliner instead of sitting at my desk
you know and
I just
part of me that's like well next
Generation if this keeps up am I buying
an Xbox like if I can play all my games
on PC and the big ones are gonna you
know I'm gonna prefer that on PC anyway
most likely especially stuff that with
mouse and keyboard I just
why do I buy an Xbox if they start
putting out hits
I'm gonna buy an Xbox now In fairness
I'm probably in a bit of an anomaly
right I'm I'm somebody who
I've already decided unless it goes to
complete garbage I'm gonna probably be a
Game Pass subscriber until they
discontinue there I die like but the
average consumer is not that way the
average consumer jumps in and out the
average consumer uh you know pays more
attention to to their subscriptions
probably than I I do and I don't I just
don't understand the concept that well
if we put out good games nobody's gonna
care I don't need insane I don't
there okay he didn't say nobody's gonna
care he said we're not going to jump
into the jump uh or it's not going to
make a difference it was your
interpretation of what the word was said
so like addict said the ability to leave
it open-ended actually gave people the
power to have opinion on something that
I'll get to it but yeah he didn't say
that okay continue continue I mean but
the words he said were
it's not gonna change things we're not
going to jump ahead right and it's not
going to gain us more customers
essentially I'm not I'm not those aren't
verbatim but yeah yeah that's what he
said and for me that's that is true if
like
if you put out consistently good games
I'm going to become more loyal to you
and the thing that's sometimes you know
how it's it's not what you say it's how
you say it right well it's kind of that
same thing and where when you don't have
one thing you have another every time
Xbox puts out a bad game which is In
fairness rare or if they just don't put
out games at all which is a little more
common
that just engenders me more towards
PlayStation and as someone who is as we
talked about earlier lifelong been
console agnostic been platform agnostic
I'm like
well PlayStation's looking pretty good
to me right Nintendo even looks pretty
good to me on the on the 17 FPS we're
getting for for uh the kingdom you know
so like I just I guess I understand
where he was coming from and what he was
saying and and I appreciated that he
said even though we didn't have Hands-On
that's still my responsibility like that
kind of stuff I really appreciate that
stuff and I think that's genuine but I
don't understand the mindset of
well games aren't going to save us
you're a game company bro like I know
you're also doing services and that and
the game passes doing a bang-up job and
I know that Hardware Sales aren't
necessarily gonna that's not everything
but like if you're not getting the the
consoles out there for the attach of
Game Pass and for the attach of of your
actual purchases
what's the what's the point like I just
I don't understand the philosophy right
and just for Claire let me re-read
because I did miss the statement and I
probably wouldn't reread it the exact
statement so I think this is the one
that everyone's fired up right as far as
the interpretation again the call he
says first this is the first generation
with big games they're playing that
where the big games they're playing were
games that were available last gen when
you think about fortnite Roblox and
Minecraft the continuity from generation
to generation is so strong I see a lot
of pundits out there that kind of want
to go back to the time when we all had
cartridges and discs and every new
generation was a clean slate and you
could switch the whole console share
that's just not the world we are in
today there is no world where star field
is an 11 out of 10 and people are
selling their ps5s that's not going to
happen that that's probably one of the
the main quotes as opposed to the
secondary other quote which is the idea
if we just focus more on great games on
our console some how we're going to win
the console ways race I don't think I
don't relate I think that I think does
it relate to the reality of most people
so these are the I think these are the
core ones that's getting everybody and I
agree with that statement that if
starfield's 11 out of 10 people aren't
going to sell their ps5s but if I've got
a PS5 and Starfield comes out and it's
only on Xbox and it's good then I am
going to buy an Xbox I will keep my PS5
as well television like you can do right
now right you ain't passed on your phone
or you can get Game Pass I ain't playing
game pass on my phone
I'm not poverty or are you gonna get
game passes
I mean I I understand I understand that
but and that's where it comes in whereas
they're looking at it more as a service
but even if you're some there are a lot
of people who only care about AAA games
and that's the only reason they want
game passes to play them day one I'm not
that person I don't think any of you or
those people right but there are a lot
that's a large base of their if they're
not putting out games that meet the
quality eventually people are just going
to stop signing up for a month here and
there and eventually stop becoming
longtime customers so I agree with
pretty much you know I agree with the
underlying philosophy there and I like
their I do like their service based
aspect even though you know it goes
against what we historically know as
gaming
um I I'm just a little
in the context he was talking about it I
get what he's saying but that mindset
bleeds through of well good games aren't
going to save us and I think that's the
only thing that saves you but it has to
be it's an addition to everything else
you have right okay not fair enough fair
enough Lord about mood loads of
gaming.net's own where are we at man you
know where you're at with Phil's
comments you know what what did you
interpret out of them
first I just want to say I I kind of
like this cranky fail you know it's more
of a craigie Phil was outside yeah yeah
well I appreciate his honesty in there
and I think uh when you reach uh that
sort of position where Phil is at they
are looking at everything at a very
strategic like five to ten years uh
window and and uh because of that I
think he has his eyes set on um like
where the trajectory of gaming is going
because
um he said like third in the console
space but let's be real the console
space hasn't realized a lot of growth
for the past 20 years okay maybe it's
like in single digits increases but it's
gaming is a lot more it's a lot bigger
than that and if you look at total
revenues uh from video game companies
tencent is number one right and I have
the the numbers up here it's number one
they they record 8.3 billion dollars
annually last year Sony's in second with
4.24 billion so there's a huge gap and
10 cents barely in the console yeah no
one talks about 10 cents that is
interesting yeah yeah absolutely and uh
and um and I think that's that's what
they're setting their sights on it's
like they're seeing where gaming is
going okay so there's a lot there's a
lot of live service element to it
and that they want Microsoft and Xbox to
ride that wave as well so uh so they're
casting wider Nets they're they're going
for the consoles they're going for the
PC the mobile the cloud they're trying
to cast that wide net just to make sure
to get a piece of every single pie in
their hands and that's and that's that
forward thinking that maybe a lot of
people don't like because they think
that you know they may uh push back on
consoles a bit or just kind of treat
their customers there as second class
citizens as some people have said in
some of the rhetoric but I think it's
it's important to see that uh you can
still have the console experience but
like other people can grow at the same
time and uh there might be some
synergies with that in the future
now whether if I think if it's like a
defeatist
um
yeah I mean it's it it shocked a lot of
people and I think it might come off as
that but I think uh he's looking at
like sort of the future trends of gaming
so I don't I don't think it's that Comet
reflects on the current status of gaming
but but more like what's gonna happen
like five years down the line and uh
they just have to
um
keep with the trend and and and more
importantly than that they have to
implement the the new trends at the
right time because we saw on connect
they were well ahead of their time when
that released I mean a lot of people
yeah I mean look now the everyone
that's fine on me the camera is flying
on you and they're Alexa do this yeah
so timing is everything in the tech
industry and I think that's that's what
they're trying to nail now and that's
why the APK is pretty important because
they want to have that uh relevancy in
terms of the content yeah in terms of
like the Call of Duty and the blizzard
content that a lot of people love and
cherish and they want to make sure that
those games be part of their portfolio
going forward or going forward and I
just I think uh I think it's hard to the
right place I think people are just
making uh I mean redfall is is not a
it's not it's not a good look but that's
just like one speed bump for the road
um I don't think uh Satya Nadella is
going to be like oh redfall got a bad
review you got 60 America
so you don't think it's a different
correlation yeah yeah that's it's yeah
these people are they're looking way
into the future and I think uh even if
he's not here in a couple years time you
set up something special and I think he
can really uh pass the torch even though
personally I would like to see him
continue leading Xbox because uh he's
been phenomenal yeah use a use
successfully aligning Xbox with the
cloud infrastructure Microsoft and now
they're a key player of the of the
company itself you know and I I don't
like to like shell on a trillion dollar
coke companies or anything like that but
you know it is what it is this is the
sort of the developments that we've seen
in the past few years and we're just
kind of reporting on it and giving our
thoughts about it they can leave after
he killed PlayStation oh my God we will
get to you sir uh some of you had a very
uh interesting smile who am I was
talking seems like you are the other
side of this so I want to get your
thoughts on this man a lot to process
from Phil's comments man where are you
with all this
um
again I I like the fact that this is
Phil I think this is Phil as honest and
sort of open as he's ever been
um the fact that power says that they
they were sort of no sort of oversight
by PR and you know and I and I'm sure
that was partly on Phil too he said hey
we're going to do this we're going to do
it and you know I'm gonna be a little
bit unhinged and
I think that goes a long way towards
showing like hey even though again
during directly
I don't know how much he had to do it
with what's been happening lately it all
falls on his head and as it should as it
should and he did what a good boss is
supposed to do would come out there and
and take that L and take the you know
and take all the Flack for it um so that
I appreciate that I appreciate the
Candor of the questions that were that
were made I I definitely yeah yeah for
sure you know sometimes you know I just
you know he's on kind of funny sometimes
the plan right because I think the
initial plan was to come on and
hopefully talk about you know the
success of red Forest yes yes yeah and
then you have to go pivot and and talk
about this stuff so he could have you
know PR could have easily been like no
we're not doing this and that's it and
and no it went on so uh kudos to them
for all that
I think for me what was the most
striking and I and I like the fact that
he said it is and and King's gonna hate
me for this no um
I'm I love Xbox I love Xbox I think I
don't love Xbox I love Xbox I love
PlayStation I love Nintendo as well I
love them they think I don't like Xboxes
I I cannot look at the State of Affairs
in gaming since they've come into the
space
and think that they're ever on paper
going to quote unquote beat PlayStation
or beat Nintendo it's just not going to
happen right and
as somebody who cares a lot about that
brand and that product
I don't care I don't care now caveat I
don't care as long as you don't start
acting like you're in third place
if you give me if you give me first
place
if you I because to me
you could try your hardest every single
time every single outing everything you
put your best into it and if you still
come up short in in those metrics that
matter whatever the case may be
I guarantee you
the fan base will still be there
all of these conversations around
numbers understand that only matters for
conversations like this at the end of
the day if the people that have invested
in your ecosystem and your product are
happy they will continue to be there and
slowly but surely you will continue to
grow That Base do not ever act like
you're in third place and my problem is
releasing redfall in the state that it
came out in is acting like you're in
third place
and that's why when I see people's
arguments about well you know it's not
fair redfall shouldn't have all of this
sort of uh put on its head look at
pentimen look at all these other great
releases they've had fantastic that is a
hundred percent true as an old school
gamer I wish we lived in a world where
you could put pentiment and grounded in
Minecraft on the box of an Xbox and used
and that's and that's the generation
that is oh my God we can sell millions
upon millions of of consoles with these
games that is not the reality of where
we live right now
these consoles and these spaces are
defined by the AAA games that are made
by the console manufacturers period
period whether that's fair or not that
is what it is
so when you're not delivering on those
games right when we go back when we go
and again we go back Halo was great at
the onset ultimately didn't have the
legs right Crackdown is well documented
Crackdown I enjoyed Crackdown single
player but all the talk around what the
multiplayer was supposed to be and all
the the fake Secret Sauce stuff and all
the craziness and the cloud stuff marred
that message it's just the big thing is
about them being able to hit the quality
bar
that we expect from a PlayStation and
Nintendo with those games and I'm not
saying match those games in terms of
type although I would love to see a
hashtag just one I would love to see
them make that game preach fight the
good fight Brother people exactly but
but it's just having people look at
those games and say hey Starfield is of
the caliber of a Last of Us they're
different games but it's of the caliber
of The Last of Us it's of the caliber of
the tears of the Kingdom that's what I
want to see I don't care if the numbers
say something else keep fighting like
you're like you want first place every
single time you come out with every
single thing your small games your big
games I don't want I'm tired of hearing
about all this other stuff that feels
like it's put there to keep our eyes off
the prize and care about other things I
don't care about all the controllers and
this idea that is great as a secondary
and tertiary thing the games are a 100
what matter right and this is and this
is another thing that he talked about
that I think he was being candid and
it's the truth I don't know that the
Xbox faithful want to hear that but
again in my mind it was something that
what spoke truly and it's the fact that
because they have changed their model to
Game Pass and subscriptions right that
is a that is a brand new business that
he has to care about and maintain
that in some ways takes their eye off
the ball a little bit when it comes to
hey our focus is delivering you great
AAA 70 games because I have to worry
about all these other aspects of the
business the metrics the engagement and
all that stuff as opposed to how many
amazing AAA 70 games have I sold you
right the the metrics for them are not
as simple right and then that I mean
that's a that's a problem of their own
doing right this is Game Pass the I Love
Game Pass as a consumer but on their end
of it their business considerations now
that I feel after after his statements
it's just he's telling me hey the
business is a lot broader than what you
think and there are a lot more things to
take into consideration than just hey
every single game has to be a banger
every single game has to be that now for
me as somebody who sits here and talks
about the industry and tries to
understand it on a deeper level I get
that I understand and I appreciate that
he told me that as a fan that ain't
flying me as a fan I want you to fight
for first place with every single thing
that you drop all I care about bangers I
care about small bangers
you're good you're good you're good
small the big bags
and that is it to me so I wish I
understand you know some people some
people disingenuously take the
statements and run with them in
different ways right and then some
people and then some people generally
just did not understand and he
absolutely could have elaborated that
more I didn't call anybody dumb but
that's what I'm saying I am
the level of comprehend is low see all
I'm saying is this
um he could have elaborated more on that
definitely but again he was intelligent
people got it he was more off cuffs he
was more off cuff than I've ever seen
him yeah and I this bothers him and know
their change is going to be made do I
think those changes are obvious changes
that should have been made a long time
ago yes but whatever I you know I
hindsight is 2020 I don't know what's
been going on that did you know that
nobody oversaw redfall and nobody I
don't know all I know is that the
problem is in front of them they see
what they need to do and the hope is
that they address it as they need to
address it and this type of stuff does
not happen again but absolutely 100
percent as a consumer the idea that
striving for an 11 out of 10 every
single time is not going to get you to
the promised land
it's it clashes with what I care about
as a gamer we can have all these talks
about consoles and the power and all
this stuff at the end of the day the
games are what matter yeah
I gotta break it let me play with your
joysticks to our Super Chat solve I will
accept your beggar no matter what the
size
I'm not saying that they need to sell
more Xboxes than PlayStation needs to
sell PlayStations I'm saying in order
for me to care about their brand and get
and buy into any other services at all
they need to release good games because
if I just have a pretty controller and
access to a bunch of third-party indie
games
why do I care about Xbox the service
ring still be valuable to me it may not
it may not yeah but I think the
underlying thing is I will only care
about Xbox because they are known for
their games yeah and it's weird they're
dongles they want to put on the TV
someday I I don't care ever right I
don't care and then and that's the thing
I think and I I mentioned this to Cog
last night I was like you know in a
weird way right it kind of feels like
the eye off the ball a little bit in the
same way that not not as severe right
but as TV TV TV where it's like where
are the games it's great this console
could do all this stuff where the games
and it just feels again this is
different because what we're talking
about that sort of changed and evolved
right the way they sell games is a
gaming service right it is completely
gaming focused and as the consumer I
love that but at the same time
selfishly or not I want every single
game yeah absolutely exactly I want
everything in there right sir that's
right I do have that is 100 I do have
one question we saw before you give the
king my question to you is from the
hardcore gaming perspective from the fan
perspective which you eloquently you're
spending
my question is they're gonna pull a
corporate cargo on you for a second is
what if
again we're not privy to all the
information but what if the Age of
Empires the Minecraft the games that the
hardcore do not consider the beggar
right and the ground is just I mean no
disrespect but the Sea of these a lot of
Hardcore really put their nose up they
they don't acknowledge so what if
because the strategy is this diverse
lineup into this service which I think
we all agree for the most part is a
sound strategy they have a diverse array
of titles in a service that you want to
promote if that's your shift so my
question to you is what if the brass is
looking at Phil as king eloquently calls
him young Odin Sacha the Della right is
looking at Phil and says yo you killed
us kill it with the because Services was
up I know consoles was there but for
what he's there and what we understand
is his mission is Game Pass we heard
like this is him and his team's Vision
to get brass to believe into it so what
if those things despite the red false
nephew which we all hate and they're
looking back like yeah all right despite
2020 you know two we have bigger
projections but overall Phil let's take
it out for us like what do you say that
that with your hardcore gamer
sensibilities versus the the corporate
you know boardroom sensibilities well
that's the part where again the the
engagement numbers and all that stuff in
within Game Pass matter right at the end
of the day but ultimately see it's funny
because we that conversation is the
conversation they have with us the
consumer they talk about the engagement
numbers and as many people played or
whatever internally they don't have
conversations about engagement
internally that engagement conversations
turns into the very real brass tax
conversation about how much money did we
make what did we earn and so that may
translate to Dollars in a way that they
say hey keep doing what you're doing all
I'm saying is
whether you care about it or not your
competition is doing something else and
their standard of Excellence is measured
in a different way and they're winning
so as much as much as you've done to
change the conversation and we've talked
about this multiple times about how hey
you keep losing it by adhering to the
status quo you change the status quo and
now there's another Lane that can that
they use to sort of measure Excellence
right
to the point and it's been successful
enough to the point where the other two
have had to sort of dip their toe in
that lane as well yeah probably
reluctantly Services you see the others
trying to exactly mimicking the third
place console exactly so so
but at the end of the day because you
are third place you still have to adhere
to that method of Engagement you have to
you have to sort of try to meet them
meet the Champions where they are you
got to beat them in the own game if you
change the game
because you're in third still you
understand you're still in third okay so
you still have to show that you're
capable of doing that even if you're not
beating them consistently okay I feel
what you're saying even if you're not
put the effort right you have to put the
effort because your body punches if you
put the effort in right if you put the
effort in right yeah if you do that and
you continue to release great games
The Game Pass stuff doesn't matter right
it doesn't really matter because and I
talked about how the narratives are
created by the big AAA games I love
those small games but we don't live in a
world where those games matter truly to
creating the identity of that console
and it's going to matter to the hard
court so if we're the ones right if at
the end of the day we're the ones that
craft the identity as the hardcore but
then the the more casual players are the
ones that actually give the numbers
right the numbers with the fortnites
right we still dictate The Narrative of
what the thought process is around that
ecosystem so when you walk into a
GameStop or you walk into a Best Buy
whatever you want the person selling the
console whatever to have something
positive the same but I now go with the
PlayStation because this is that yeah
which is why the PlayStation brand is so
strong globally yeah yeah it's a good
point so so at the end of the day I I
completely love the fact that they are
willing to sort to grow the entire
ecosystem with a plethora of different
types of games I love that because again
I'm mad at PlayStation for code shutting
that down and we'll talk about you know
shutting down pixel Lopez and things of
that nature right but the fact of the
matter is that until they dominate the
conversation which in my mind I don't
know that that will ever be the case
right you still have to engage the enemy
on their terms to a certain extent and
that's just it I know King disagrees
you hear me I'm sorry I'm sorry so
that's it that's it I don't really care
I don't care what place you're in just
act like you're in first all the time
Ben real quick and then no I just I just
want to butt in real quick and say the
conversation about the hardcore always
seems to revolve to me
around oh the people who play you know
your Halos and your colors
those aren't the hardcore players in my
opinion the hardcore players are the
ones out there grinding games that
nobody thinks about right but they're
actually more popular with higher player
counts than anything else do you think
Minecraft doesn't have more players than
any other other AAA games
isn't beating Halo fortnight
right so
you're right 100
right so you're 100 right so then what
does that say about how the narrative
has changed where the the mark of
Excellence is your god of war is your
your whatever your last of us your Zelda
and everything below it doesn't sort of
fit the bill right and I'm sorry a
little money like fortnite
in defense
it's only themselves let's look at the
APK enough said that the the bangers
that the hardcore value the God of Wars
the last of us all these games so Rising
until dawn does that matter they said
they cannot exist without the court that
the hardcore let's be honest don't
really gratitude or necessarily care for
so it is interesting how this works
right where the hardcore says these
games Define the platform but the actual
businessman and the people running the
platforms are saying the opposite got
the opposite right and this the funny
thing is right if we look at what the
future of Sony looks like and I I'm I
imagine we're going to get a clearer
picture of that this year we're gonna
get a whole lot of service based games
exactly we're going to get it so there's
gonna be a shift right and again the
conversation will change again now what
I will say is this though right whether
it's fair or not let's say Sony's
jumping into the space after not having
really been into it for a long time the
fact that they are the the number one
console seller the number one you know
first place whatever winner means that
even them jumping into the space
probably puts them in freshly right now
right brand new jumping into the space
after not really touching it for many
years it puts them in the best position
to be dominant in that space right right
it just does right so again the idea of
being in first and what that means
still
it's just success right it's just
success the metrics are measured in
different ways but to me I think at the
end of the day when you dilute all of
that and get rid of it it's just the
games and it's get keep giving me great
games don't step on unnecessary rakes
preach
and and you'll be fine and you will grow
the ecosystem you will take the course
all right look look I'm sorry yeah
there's a quick I'm just gonna say
there's just one thing that kind of
really stood out to me in the interview
uh I think when they're talking about
like he the games coming in on a
quarterly basis and he's like if Phil
was just like it's right there you know
like it's it's like the momentary it's
it's coming and I know that's a lot of
that's a big meme oh my God right yeah
no no like like almost like he shouldn't
have said that but the fact that he
mentioned it it really does feel like
he's so he's seen things that it's like
it's here it's there right there I'm
gonna finally make good on this I get it
let's get the king man he's impatient
talk is going on you know King says a
lot of soft talk in these streets I'm
saying where you at Phil Dominus Maximus
are really expensive you're mad outside
taking the heavier questions first I
want to say thank you to kind of funny
yes absolutely for doing what did and
thank you Paris for giving those
questions
because I mean not saying that the whole
team didn't do a collaborative effort to
give us a great interview to go off of
um
it was a great interview and the
questions was perfect
um
this is for
all you spineless jellyfish
[Music]
called the arms what's going on
what's happening
camera's off I'm nervous nervous what's
happening
better get on
get a low injured
you got shot are you hurt or are you
injured
there's a difference
get up dust yourself off and get right
back outside and fight
five star general whoa I see you
This Is War
now we know the opposition has a better
Navy than us who the hell's gonna fight
them in the water
you'll be a fool
on the other side has a better air
superiority Ted hunt fight them in the
air
you'll be a fool
we have a better infantry we gonna take
them to the ground and drown them in the
water we're gonna beat them to death on
the ground our way
um you don't go inside a fight trying to
fight Muhammad Ali by out boxing them
pause
you coming for Saul get up
two point in time am I gonna
Miss every time something goes wrong you
call for Phil Dominus Maximus Aurelius
jump he is the only one taking these
hard hidden questions be outside
you just saw Anakin turn into Darth
Vader they make it a good boy go evil
he said how am I he I'm grumpy
I'm I do apologize for being Snappy with
you
Ain't No More Mr Niceville oh that's it
that's it we do it y'all keep acting
like this ain't the dude that brought us
back from the brink factual people do
forget you dudes was not worried about
being an Xbox Channel until I stood up I
gave you something in the stands
let them know you guys are in my DM King
what will we do we will hold the line
let's go
let's go weak dudes make me sick
can't do a push-up
can't do it [__]
I seen you frauds making channels Phil
should go
for what
cause a red four behind should go
[Laughter]
biggest games going
they ain't trying to be number one
they ain't acting like they belong
when you got number one acting like
number three oh snitching and rats
ditching and tell it that's what they
was doing you can't handle the work
you were getting worked in the field so
you had to go snitch they worried about
number three
they're doing tactics on you Phil did
allude to tactics though I will give you
that let me tell you something a lot of
you ignorant guys out there
yo watched it you heard it you came
across with your own narrative
Phil told you in so many ways with what
these dudes are doing in the background
my hands are tied so I must learn how to
fight this way bars he did allude to
that I gotta give you that he did for
the first time elude that the others are
doing things from their position that to
not help them get to that I will give
you that continue them silent little
contracts don't put it on Game Pass
don't talk to Xbox
stay away from them kick seated
here's some extra dough
but I thought all you gotta do is go out
and buy a whole dag on building
but then you go out and you snitch oh
man you ain't the Sony that I know
so we can't beat you regular up
squabbling We Gotta Throw Dirt in your
eyes
don't squawful you guys make me sick to
my stomach we're asking for Phil job
don't come back I don't want to see you
over here when starfell drops and they
give that 9 out of ten and your face is
back in the building talk about I always
knew yeah there's a lot of fraudulent
Xbox dudes that's what you're doing we
hold it a lot okay okay pause the drop
oh you're the racing King
Gran Turismo what happened when Gran
Turismo launched holiday drawings I
ain't see y'all out there talking about
wish Jim's job
you actively rip a rap
you wouldn't know a stand-up dude if he
smacked you in the mouth and he did on
that interview we're kind of funny oh
that's a real man standing up there
taking his medicine and he told you I'm
grumpy I'm upset but I'm sitting right
here I ain't ducking no Fades he ain't
Dr Faye I give you that you don't see
Jim anywhere
whatever you say yo if you succeeded Jim
don't need to be outside because he's
giving them great games let me tell you
something
you are not gonna make a game tomorrow
that's going to win the war
you can set building blocks and building
traps
you go out there you make the best game
that you can you don't stifle creativity
inside your building Phil did say that
you make those people put out the best
product I can tell you this then never
make another redfall again
we learned now we good now hopefully
well what's up with you guys
making games that run good that didn't
succeed and you're folding stuff we'll
get to that later oh we're talking about
but I want you to have the same many
pixel office okay call for Jim
don't you call for Phil okay all right
if I done told you I'm the first and
last line of defense you've been holding
me you've been holding it bro I go for
it you've been holding it ain't nobody
but rapper Phil and nobody remember Xbox
harder than you you always stand on your
Square you ten toes down and then we
have to give you a lot of dudes I see it
was folded I've seen them dudes just
weeks off I saw a heart pumping Kool-Aid
okay score it okay I saw it on my
timeline what does he mean by this King
you yourself said you don't like soft
talk
you ain't feel it was no soft talk his
hands was tied behind his back with
certain things that he's actively
fighting the CMA
um
so you want him to go out there he don't
self-incriminate
um he telling you yeah those dudes doing
things but he ain't snitching not as not
not a snitch not a boss
listen man we working how we working we
doing what we doing we work us over here
we we even switch the metrics we know we
ain't gonna I'll sell these dudes the
same we ain't getting the business to
our console Sony okay he did say that we
got in the business to make them a nap
he said I'm giving you what he said
that's the kick translator boss
we're gonna need that quote yeah
please tell the realm the room's on
vacation
nor had they been researched thoroughly
Order 66 has been initiated and you guys
are the Jedi standing there and all the
clone troopers y'all didn't see the
clone troopers because you didn't see
him as a threat
that's why they was able to get up close
to you to put that pistol to your side
all you Jedis out there faulting acting
like you you don't stink your noses up
in the air that's Sony okay the Sith
move and Shadow
any diabolical with it okay so he got a
little clone on me I'm giving you some
facts and some advice okay this is
what's gonna happen to you when you turn
into an app let me tell you something
Jim is living off the hype of Sean
Layton
Sean Laden gave all that stuff ahead of
time then he got unservously booted out
the door
and Jim started implementing his stuff
Jim is games of service
so when Jim drops his first game of a
service then let's revisit the
conversation about how good your general
is when he does something outside of the
norm Phil's been fixing people mess up
all over
redfall ain't fails
red fallers Pete Hines in them you feel
good can we be easier
my man say the team say he's at the back
to the team
it's not personalizing okay listen all
right so it's not I like them okay it's
not listen I think it's like Aaron
Greenberg for them listen I like Pete
too I like Pete or why my man gotta take
the weight of something that was in
development before he got them but in
your phone all right so question so all
right in fantasy right what about the
idea where where'd the idea come from
not to check up on oh no I can't I can't
um I don't I don't know what internally
went down I know when it showed up
turn on investment right
or what I do not excuse that game okay
thank you that's all we say offset
because we just like look we get where
you at with Phil and in the regime and
shout out to Jess he's put out an
article that said they are still
operating independently from what we
hear that that zetamax is still even
though the acquisition they are still
moving at their own but to Saul's point
you know and if y'all mind if I get my
balls unless you finish unless you
finish okay okay to SOB's point the
issue is this can't happen
this can't happen because at the end of
the day even if it that is the case no
one cares me
like like at the end of the day they
report to you so the pipeline got to be
fixed whatever whatever it is right and
and maybe that's a transition and
hopefully this is a learning instead of
this game a triple A game they was
pumping it like a triple a game like
that they did that yeah it was popping
at that like yeah so look I would get
into it though first again if Paris in
the cruising and shout out to y'all
absolutely phenomenal interview tough
questions always talk about people that
they didn't solve for now that was a
great interview and you can tell there
was tension in that room yeah Phil was
uncomfortable Phil was stress he has he
was he was he was cranky it was a little
awkward Energy Shot I love that love
that though you had everybody going I
was lit that was I didn't know what she
was about to do
um look
this is the gift in the cursed
of ultimate transparency
because on one hand like like benefit
you don't really see this level of
transparency on the executive level
just give you the brass tags giving you
the real on what's going on and I have
to commend him on that right that is not
easy from what Gary within them said you
know he was scheduled there kind of to
be for something else ahead of time
he could have easily after the week of
the CMA big block blocking the deal
red fog going out did terrible reviews
easy like you know what um Sandy PR we
gonna cancel that right there and we'll
see y'all when we see y'all and no one
would have known any better except kind
of funny and we wouldn't know right and
that would have been that so I want to
salute as far as or some leadership
taking the energy the problem is
this Xbox fan base is so loyal and they
have been waiting they have been waiting
to celebrate the fruits of the
Acquisitions and and all the moves so
red fool does get a lot of smoke because
there was no way anyone saw the
conditions to be launched like that that
was unacceptable and on any level he
knows that you know so again
the Optics of it right you know what I'm
saying the communication and this is
where I talk about the second class
citizen field you don't hear about this
with the other platforms on their major
releases and we this is not precedent we
do have Halo infinite to look back at
right we do have yo this was your
Flagship why is it launching why are we
getting Craig face what is going on with
your team how is it you're just finding
out so to speak it or you're just now
going to put 60 frames per second again
the disconnects somehow which Phil
address hey we should have come in there
earlier hey they didn't have maybe time
with unreal whatever but the end of the
day the the notification and the
pipeline it's too late in the game that
has to be corrected and just frankly
Xbox fans are tired of it they are tired
of it's again solved we gonna go
baseball but it's like you're a Yankee
fan I'm a Memphis this is Mets energy
it's like you find a way to do the most
embarrassing thing in losing the most
you know it crushing pain spectacular
way and people this was a breaking point
for a lot of people it just was now look
I get it people get acquired you have to
fix the pipeline between when someone
was acquired at any projects that they
had going prior you've got to get in
there this hopefully is alerting lesson
for stuff you like I would hope so look
at the end of the day here's my issue
I do have an issue with the great games
comment
I know Phil cares about AAA quality
Gamers I know he does
whether we want to say or characterize
it that he misspoke
whether it is that he is attacking
a certain subset of people who think all
that's going to turn this thing around
is Starfield Starfield 11 out of Texas I
do see that talk like Starfield 11 out
of ten bro that's it all the pressure he
is right to the letter of the law that
no single game is going to transform and
make everyone sell their PlayStations
and it's on but to soft's point
quality games does make your service
which you're trying to promote and
you're trying to shift to more
attractive to get people in that that's
the thing so again I'm not saying he
doesn't care about that all I'm saying
is the way it was worded it could be
misconstrued that if you're an Xbox fan
oh quality game you know that's not the
focus and that may not be what he meant
but it just sometimes how it could have
been perceived right for the record
I didn't feel the comment for the record
I spoke to the dominance told him I
don't and I don't use that power a lot I
have access sometimes but I didn't feel
it I was just like bro I just got to be
honest that part right there I didn't
like because what happens is it it feeds
into the narrative Narrative of
second-class Citizen it feeds into The
Narrative of wait put it in Game Pass
and fix it later you know what I'm
saying it feeds into this narrative that
I don't want to see for this platform I
like right
In fairness man took the criticism said
100 I respect and Phil we talked about
it and photography man if I talked about
this right now but that's how I felt I
it just bothered me I I can't I don't
care what access I have whatever if I'm
not feeling something I'm gonna say it
period and the man took it like a man
and was like yo I respect where you at I
see when you and I respect the feedback
100 that's all we're saying you know
what I mean at the end of the day
stop fumbling the football
that's just what is a stop that
self-inflicted mistakes that's all we
just want that cleaned up
and for me we got to get to King's Point
Bethesda I am a little concerned
because in my opinion
Phil is dying on his sword for you guys
in my opinion whether or not you want to
say that was the pipeline in place or
not 2022 Microsoft expected Bethesda to
have Starfield and referral ready for
their lineup that didn't happen
then this game gets delayed we see what
happens with refer this happens now
right at the end of the day no one's
really looking at but that's like that
they go on the Xbox it's Xbox One is an
Xbox problem right when the reality it
these whatever the culture was
pre-acquisition has to be changed the
pipeline has to be fixed and you guys
have to work this out hopefully this is
a learning experience for Starfield I
don't please don't do my star feel like
this please bro don't you come for my
God Howard AAA this is my like please
so that's what I'm trying to say from
this like the hope of this is that and
see this is why I can't get mad at
anyone that says mismanagement I can't
push back anymore I can't say because
this doesn't have an interview so you
got to clean this up my other issue
Bethesda I gotta come for y'all is
I'm looking at a situation like
ghostwire Tokyo how is this game
that was exclusive to PlayStation we get
it there was a deal before you have a
year now to come to Expo how is this not
optimize for Xbox
this is a terrible look so again to me
like Maddie has always said this kind of
feels Fallout 76 energy old practices
catching a wave going multiplayer
Wolfenstein Young Blood Fallout 76 all
these different experimental things
because you knew you guys are going out
and maybe red four was that but either a
cancel it or B no one should look at Red
4 and release the same finished
yeah fire right yeah they gonna love
this no one should like who's in the
building who's in the building saying
finished someone should have come in at
some point and said look our name is on
this
at Xbox
so we gonna politely ask you to take
this food back and cook this a little
bit and more respectful respectfully or
or throw it in the dumpster respectfully
like it is it's just that's just what it
is you know what I'm saying so look I
ain't gonna go too much with it you know
at the end of the day
Xbox fans deserve better
at the end of the day despite all this I
still feel they're gonna have a great
year it's set up for them to as long as
they execute you down unfortunately put
more pressure on this showcase because
of the situation you are you now put
more pressure on Starfield because of
this situation
all I'm saying is
communicate be transparent
really get invested with your Studios
upon release
and hopefully it should clear up because
the things are the things are in place
for you we should see games that we have
not seen that we're excited to hear
about we should get a stall feel we
should get a Forza we should hopefully
get a hellblade who knows what happens
with the ABK deal I get that's a setup
you know a setback excuse me but it's
set up for them
you know it's set up for them to do this
you know I'm saying this is just to me a
quality control issue that must be
addressed and never in my opinion you
know I know that's not what was meant
but great games are always important to
the platform Phil knows it I don't even
have to repeat that he knows I know it
and I know what he meant and again kudos
to him for the transparency for coming
because I know a lot of people would not
have been in that fire but that's all I
got so yeah super transfer ready to go
yeah it's funny I you know I've never
I'm never full-blown like Xbox fan on
here whatever but this is something that
like it just like redfall comes out it's
their first one that they go it goes
directly to Xbox and I'm like damn man
like you know death book comes out and
they get to 10. like and it's like it's
like it's mental energy it's supposed to
be a slam what the hell man it's Dick's
energy Patrick Ewing Figaro to miss it's
like it's like wow with this when it's
done right wisdom is always a character
but like I really understand ghost water
Tokyo wasn't like a 10 but it was you
know it was a referral not even close so
it's like it was great it's a great game
I love that game yeah I love that game
no that's it it's like it's just that
energy of like come on man yeah man
absolutely and I think they listen they
know it they know it it's just the
argument that I will always defend the
PlayStation fan that pushes back and say
you see this man is this because I can't
fight that until they clean up and this
makes that argument like yo how are you
going to acquire anybody else if you
can't fix your own you see what I'm
saying that's they gotta stop that
conversation they gotta put this
narrative and nip it in the butt and if
they do Xbox fans will ride or die they
just they just been waiting man it's
been a long time serve this space right
they've been holding it down and I know
he knows that that's pretty much I got
so we're gonna get the super chances
yeah shut up shout out to BG but BJ's
been putting out some great videos on
the stuff that's coming up and you would
think like you know BJ's very
PlayStation Century PC Centric but the
the the videos have been great because
it's very it's just objectively looking
at the situation like this is not a good
look I don't see what's going on great
stuff yeah and last Point In fairness I
do want to say this ain't gonna be a
couple other people in fairness if you
look at the whole this Phil Spencer
common for job talk right if you look at
it as a whole like X like a king set
this man single-handedly saved this
brand when Microsoft wasn't caring for
that right so now that you want to see
the table I got it but it is a what have
you done for me lately league and the
thing is you had the bad 2022 but I do
want to pray give praise to the 2021
when things the pipeline we saw what the
pipeline could be with the Psychonauts
in the in the forza and the Halo and you
know what I'm saying the age like when
you saw what it could be when it's right
so it's just like it was like well again
oh man here we go again just what we
thought you know even though Hi-Fi Rush
was at the top of the year that's why
the red fall situation shook the bass to
its core because it's a it's an
indicator of everything everybody has an
issue with Xbox was reflected in that
title that's why people it really bother
people and I hope they understand that
yeah for sure
all right super chats
remember for 26 months Lord bronze when
my friend asked me about ready for I say
Nuevo English
[Laughter]
then we have B Lou remember for 20
months Lord bronze his point was they're
putting out good games to grow in other
areas not the console race partly
because last gen this is why they're not
participating in it yeah and it's
another thing like he what he said about
the digital age too is very true as well
like a people kind of plant their flag
in one place or another a lot of people
and you know they can't sell their
entire Library like they used to and
switch off to the other concerts not the
reality anymore yeah and we have project
Aries member for new member member for
five at five dollar Super Chat Sony got
punched in the face stood up and went to
the gym Xbox got punched in the face to
stare off to stare off a bridge wow they
need that fire SOB is Right Jesus oh
yeah always maintain the fire man get
out of here
listen General right back you the same
dude your high five Rush dropped they
ain't even say nothing it's a triple
Banger yo I'ma tell you I've been
playing high five
man shut up
it's but if I have game plan so I played
it for free oh but right now they got
punched in the mouth
100 right keep that Underdog Spirit
Alive just keep fighting don't care how
many times you get punched to the page
that's all I care about ain't nobody
give up but y'all
that was good that was actually good
nothing so that talk ain't directed
towards me
then we got sagging nut sack oh yeah
honestly I watch Phil's uh interview and
nothing he said makes no darn sense King
I know he's your guy but he talks that
he talks too darn much damn hey okay
pick up your nut sack maybe you can hear
him oh
yo
obviously it is
[Laughter]
nor am I a huge fan of Jimbo but he
doesn't talk too much he just lets the
games do the talking tell your guy to
stay off the internet because he's
starting to make no sense all right so
you like the girl that cheats keeps her
mouth shut
and ain't sorry about it I don't wanna
know the other one that made a mistake
I messed up but I really want to be in
this you're gonna still be chasing after
that dot over there that don't like oh
man
I see you man I see you if it helps any
the PlayStation fans don't like Jim
either so yeah yeah they're a fool
because Jim is the best thing that
happened to him I don't disagree he's
got business sense but that wasn't sure
Lewis just Augustus
I disagree in quotes an army May March
great distances without distress if it
marches through a country where the
enemy is not Sun Tzu The Art of War yes
but guaranteed if you're if you're going
towards the beef you're gonna reach the
beef
and if you brought that book up too
you brought that book up too so
obviously I can bring up a book up too
right let's go 50 loads of power yes sir
that we have split oh okay I'm sorry
towards your strengths
and you cover your weaknesses oh
my man
if they have a better superiority over
here you make sure that you fight them
on this front but you do something to
come behind how do you think those
Spartans was able to Outlast the Persian
army they all died but how many people
they took with them before they left
yeah they finally funneled a bunches
don't understand that stop bringing me
books that I know about
damn damn we gotta burn the books too
all right damn
Fahrenheit 451 here we go let me see
splendiferous I remember for one year
five dollar suit the stupid chat soggy
nut sack and when are you when you got
Phil money I can't really call them
soggy nuts wow you got Phil money you
can tell them where to go and where to
and when to be there your little 10
super don't mean nothing to me get back
in line player you good yo
he was like
then we got pixel bit G remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat Hold the
Line big up to IOP yeah salute salute
now we have a hard geek to knee remember
for one year two dollars to pretend King
tell him let's go IOP Dominus let's go
yo we see 900 uh views in here man
that's four only 400 likes um what we
gotta save the animal every like y'all
do we save a red date I'll be on
humpback today
we're giving y'all bars an entertainment
today come on then we have Tai casares
with the three dollar Super Chat King
sounds like Sergeant Johnson yes yes
call me Captain King
then we have hargeist and he once again
always coming through for the uh for the
community with the five dollar super
chats congrats to whoever got this code
here's one of the few AAA games that
didn't launch all broken Dead Island 2
with the Xbox global cold shout out to
whoever got that girl thank you brother
identify yourself in the chat appreciate
that yeah always giving back to
community always
we have Robert Kelly five dollar Super
Chat King preaching to people like me
who can't do push-ups and fall in line
I didn't know what was happening I was
like would that camera come off I don't
know what's happening today yeah you
guys gotta be careful
yeah I thought he's gonna have like a
toga or something with the season the
next one when the battle is over oh but
it's over okay okay that's what I
thought
then we have Nintendo on the otaku five
dollar super chat if this was
civilization Nintendo going for the
religious Victory here PlayStation is
going for the domination Victory and
Xbox going for the Science Victory
yeah I love it nerd logic gotta love it
you gotta love it then we got Max are
they again five pound super chat you
just know Phil is fighting off Microsoft
Jim rotten Microsoft Jim Ryan's trying
to take his job also throughout all of
this he's the man for the job I love you
bro punctuation
don't kill my man with the Gravely but I
appreciate you
the
most objective views on the India
two years and ten dollars Sony out there
snitching and why imagine a world where
the Activision Blizzard King deal closes
in June and then the next round of
Acquisitions begins terrified that is
why Sony is of of a world uh is of a
world where this happens
snitches to this day that deal somehow
go through yeah
I might I might edit that segment he did
and post it on some real profit to go
let them with that dude that would be
crazy yeah that we have jovar Ingy ten
dollars Super Chat just sending love to
IOP thank you brother appreciate that
thank you so much we got Gerald Mack
once again remember for 30 months Lord
silver this red fall Fiasco definitely
taught Microsoft who and how much to
trust the people that they work with
redfall blessing and a curse yeah
hopefully lesson learned don't want to
see this again
and we got JD gamer once again the ten
dollar Super Chat that next round of
Acquisitions probably includes Miss
Walker Sega pubg Studios level five and
for an Eastern block tape we're level
five for an Eastern block takeover then
Avalanche certain affinity ioi and cry
Tech and God helps somebody if Microsoft
does more
come out of God is but what happened
when Darth Vader became Darth Vader and
everybody had to catch them hands yeah
we got this particle 17 two pound Super
Chat Phil needs to crack the whip forget
the Kumbaya all right so we got kill
creativity
make the game I want you to make damn it
sweatshirt I understand what he's
talking about
just making sure everything is pipeline
pipeline man get the pipeline man and we
got to go hold on gotta roll back what's
your last one yeah it is the one so the
last one I read was
uh Spartan go 17. okay spawn go 17.
there's okay Phil yeah okay I got you I
got it okay JD yeah yeah JD JD gamer ten
dollar Super Chat
extension a Sony couldn't fight with
Microsoft they had to go get some help
they out here lying snitching and
begging Regulators to stop Microsoft
before they take a weapon that they that
they see coming terrified God I love
y'all punctuations
oh my goodness I gotta run into you guys
first yes then we got Nintendo Taco five
dollars if you chat they need to bring
whoever's in charge of obsidian to help
Matt booty watch over Xbox game studios
like Herman Holst for PlayStation
hopefully without copy and pasting games
no but in Booty's defense if you look at
the Xbox games outside of Halo Infinity
right everything is you know for the
most part the rest have done what
they're supposed to do and Metacritic so
we know what it is yeah
then we have Alex escorza member for 20
months Lord bronze Xbox sort of let
redfall be a PlayStation exclusive yeah
they should let that deal go oh man let
that one rock
you get outside and said red Falls the
best thing since sliced bread
there we have JD gamer once again five
dollar Super Chat the fight ain't over
Sony ain't about to do no Victory laps
the ground troops are coming for y'all
we're gonna have to take you in the
water okay
subscribe
to the king ethos that man is a full
subscriber take them to deep Waters and
drown them yesterday yes I got JD gave
it once again five dollars
in the end this is a simple matter of
big Bank take little Bank every time
Sony about to get that work the same way
they served it to Sega years ago this is
this is old Sega angst yeah this one
angry Sega fans yeah this is what we do
we won't Rise Up from the Shadows like
the Phoenix's we are
then we have Mr two opinionated five
dollars Super Chat I'm ready for hashtag
heelfil hashtag Hollywood Bill wake up
you're gonna turn him y'all see then we
got sagging nut sack once again two
pounds Super Chat King don't you talk
about my knots
leave his knots alone
[Music]
we got it then we have splendiferous two
dollars we pretend I talked about him
too the Soggy Cheetos back in the Lions
Wow Come on
messy too man too much visuals too much
visuals yeah
good good better health please
and we have JD gamer five dollar Super
Chat PS2 down here with their chest all
puffed out I can't wait for that to end
I can't wait for them to spit out all
they air they suck oh wow yo yo I
endorsed that
then we have uh Tom 909 with the 2K
Super Chat I pay for the king toga
tonight that must be Ben bus Ben must be
the same though oh he won Ben and King
in the tokens
do we get separate ones
you know the Super Chat wanted us to be
conjoined
moving on
Family Show
[Laughter]
spoken broken The Last of Us won PC
broken so were you where were you all
the truth Shane the devil they've been
dropping garbage for me oh my God and
you dude they gave you that DLC from a
game that they cooked for five years
that was already done they just give him
this
air peasants shout out to kids
PlayStation Insight analysis
there we have gamer by choice two
dollars this is so funny but true
punctuation takes character soft great
show stop watching
their Super Chat bro that's it how you
gonna get it all right are we good yes
sir we're caught up all right King the
final topic we're going to combine this
if you do not mind problems um look
we're going to start with the first part
um which is the 70 dollar game situation
so shout out to I believe it was tweak
town and uh Derek Strickland who is the
pr game gaming editor he does a lot of
news analysis games
look you know he talked about you know
the 78 dollar games and how um you know
people Sony is looking at it as far as
um
you know let me get the actual exact
quote hold on one second he's basically
saying that how like the data suggests
that 70 game seven dollar games are
resulting in fewer sales so you have
some interesting numbers that he pulled
up he said um in fiscal year 22 Sony
said 19 million PS5 consoles generated a
massive on 8 billion from hallway sales
note that this includes both PS4 and PS5
sales but the primary driver would be
PS5 console sales that revenues are up
and up we said in terms of volume game
unit sales are definitely lower than
last year and then he mentioned that uh
game game unit sales have been on a
downward Trend since the fiscal year of
20 and a period which includes the PS5
launch since that fiscal year 2022
software revenues are high and game
volume is low it's likely that gamers
are buying less copies of more expensive
games the dip and subscriber numbers
aligned with a drop in Network Services
Revenue so long story short Gamers
appear to be buying less games but are
spent spending more on the games that
they do buy the software graphic talks
about the micro transaction and the
revenue recognized from game sales so
this is the first part of what king
wants to talk about you know in
reference to that Trend and then
obviously the other major one was that
uh yeah Sony Studios uh pixel Opus best
known for concrete Genie is shutting
down PlayStation studio will close its
doors on June 2nd so King you can go at
it whatever you want this is your topic
the 70 games Sony set down Studio where
you want to go well I'm going to start
off with
um if the PlayStations uh now Service uh
was put in first party games there day
and day and actually leaving them in the
service concrete Genie would have
probably been seen by everybody and the
studio probably wouldn't be close so
this is a philosophy when you deal in a
certain metrics and your metrics is
units sold
and you don't reach your internal mark
you are fair for your job
if your metrics is unit sold
um that sucks because uh from what I
heard concrete Genie was a decent game
and uh it didn't ship in in the state of
red wall
it shipped in a decent State
um people actually that played the game
said it was a a decent game
so
in this world where we pretty much can
say uh that Arcane is
you're safe you're gonna get a chance to
do something else
why because redfall might have had
four million downloads
and might have had x amount of
Engagement
you had one guy Super Chat and said that
he was it was DLC I was looking forward
to
he was gonna pay for
so at some point in time that game might
reach that that that the internal
numbers right but they go by different
metrics now
talking about the 70 games
you don't know your consumer base
your consumer base is cheap
your consumer-based buys TCL television
oh my Lord they buy consoles when
they're a hundred dollars cheaper to buy
games when they on sale that's why they
told you that oh
they're buying cheaper games
that's in the surface your 70 dollar
bangers that ain't gonna happen they
ain't gonna come up off those bucks
right
and that's why you're not going to see
those sales you don't know your consumer
you're out of touch with your consumer
how long is it going to take for you to
realize
that put in your games day in day in
your service grows your service and your
games can actually have some life later
and make that Revenue that you're
missing out on see I don't like the
close mentality that they're showing
they'd rather take a loss than make a
sale
hmm if you come to my store
and my shirt is fifty dollars
and you say yo I only got 45 I was short
on my hey man take that I'm gonna make
this sale
what Sony is saying is not that's that's
50b
I'd rather eat this
I'd rather not make this sale
I don't think that's smart business
so that's why the timeline on games day
and date is going to change this metrics
right here shows that that seventy
dollar thing is having an impact on an
issue sales and then y'all might say oh
King that didn't happen with God of War
sold like 20 million in two days
that's the outlier
that's the one AAA Banger game and what
happens to all the other games that's
art that has to come out at seventy
dollars and if they don't reach those
sales on those internal projections what
happens to that studio because we're
already seeing
them closed down
this studio and make them a support team
their studio and make them a support
team when they don't reach those
internal sales figures
seventy dollars is a detriment to their
business model
okay we're going there but they said
they said that the consumers spending
more money though when they end it yeah
they're spending more money on fortnite
it's spending more money on Minecraft
they're spending more right now I can
reoccur I will keep on spending I have a
subscription service to fortnite and I
actively spend money inside fortnite
right that's the guy they're talking
they're talking about me
I'm not paying seventy dollars for
nothing
but you'll you'll see me spend seventy
dollars worth for cash inside fortnite
easily
so that reoccurring dollars that's
happening year in game sales they're
making money in those microtransactions
and so on but the initial sales of 70
games are at a low
okay fair enough can't get spoken oh
Lord Batman where you at what is as far
as this uh analysis about uh 70 games
and you know PlayStation saying that the
data you know shows that you know that
they're not doing as well as far as
selling at that price point but they get
more Revenue
well I'll start off by let's see let me
okay you see the Playstation sign now
yes yes I can pretend to be a fanboy
the only reason
that uh the Xbox hasn't said this is
because they've only had one seventy
dollar game and it was garbage
but okay no the real answer is of course
70 games are going to result in Less
sales and of course you're gonna make
more money because your games cost more
so let's say you have a six percent
decrease
in
game sold but this but there's a seven
percent increase in in the cost I'm just
making up numbers I don't know anything
the the you know the the numbers are
going to shake out that you're going to
make more money overall but that my
point exactly was what what King's Point
was that people are spending more money
too on live service games and they're
spending more money on services and
stuff like that and I think we've seen
in numbers in the past and I don't have
the specifics pulled up or anything I
think quarter three of last year it was
like it was a down down point for the
for everybody across the industry that
less people were spending money on
everything so I mean a lot of things
factor in you also have you know the in
uh artificially inflated to some extent
I guess you could say artificially from
covid uh in that period of time when
there were there was such a huge surge
in game purchases so now we're starting
to see things level off a little bit I
do agree that they're seeing
Less sales because they're not putting
not because they're not putting games
under in a service I do agree that some
of these like pixel Opus may not have
been shut down if they had a
subscription service and stuff like that
and of course we don't know all the
details from that there's only like
there's not very many people there so
the chances of something the real facts
leaking out at some point or less than
if it were a huge Studio but I think
it's interesting to see that
you know obviously if you raise prices
you're going to sell less because
people's
wallets don't necessarily get bigger
just because you raise the price of your
game or just because things cost more
they usually get thinner actually and
obviously you're going to make more
money but I
I don't know if
I don't know if a subscription service
makes you any more money and I don't
know that that metric
is important to PlayStation I don't I
think it should be I think engagement
should be just as important as sales if
it's resulting in a net revenue but I
don't really know how you measure that
on Playstation when
they don't really I mean their
subscription service
I'm sure it's profitable
but it's not
it's nothing like Game Pass obviously
stuff like game pass but then you have
to look on the flip side
that yes you have a lot of game pass
subscriptions and they're making a ton
of Revenue there
when will we see and I don't I think
we'll see that it's a positive thing
that there's more Game Pass than sales
but when will we see that there are
the actual number of games sold on Xbox
I know we hear the number sometimes
about DLC Game Pass subscribers buy more
things Etc right but how many more would
be buying it if they didn't get it uh in
a subscription service and what would
that actual dollar amount be obviously
there's no way to actually know that
because in order for that to happen we
would have had to have those two
simultaneous scenarios happening right
you know at the same time but so I don't
I don't know that it's a matter of
subscription or not meaning sales or not
I
do think for sure that it makes very
obvious sense to me that if you raise
the price of your games you're going to
sell more and I think we'll see that
with other I think we'll see less
Nintendo games sold too they raise
they're starting to raise prices to 70.
I think we'll see less sold but I think
we'll see them make more money because
you know the amount of sales you lose
because of a 10 increase is probably
less than the amount of money you're
gonna make from a 10 increase over
millions and millions of copies so yeah
it's it seems like basic economics to me
but I think there is a the case that
King's making of
uh of subscription keeping Studios alive
I think that's a I think that's a fair
point
yeah fair enough Lord my mood Still
rocking and rolling what's gaming in the
building what do you feel about this man
you know the data suggesting you know
say seventy dollar games resulting in
fewer sales from PlayStation yeah
absolutely I mean we also have to keep
in mind that this crazy inflation going
on all over the world so people are
telling the belts I know King likes to
bring up the price of eggs all the time
oh yeah yeah so people turn their belts
and uh when it comes to uh
microtransactions I think people are
always going to gravitate to what's
comfortable for them and a lot of those
service games when they produce new
content they're always going to
gravitate back towards those games
and uh in terms of the studio closing
down you know I I'm just gonna Echo what
people have been saying uh a
subscription service probably could have
saved the studio
um to me also kind of represents sort of
like the last few uh companies under
Sony that produce these kind of quirky
little bit artistic games you know you
had like the flower Journey yes
um Gravity Rush they were great titles
and they had a lot of uh personality but
they kind of pivoted towards more of
like the The Cinematic over the uh the
hashtag yeah yeah so I think this is big
title yeah yeah
oh yeah for sure for sure that's what um
Jim wants Sean wanted creativity and Jim
wants production
exactly so I think that's that's gonna
that's sort of like the the price of you
know continuing that strategy and it's a
shame because you know it's uh there's
so many diverse games that Sony put out
over there the few Generations so it's
going down
like uh the The Cinematic approach and
now with the live service games which is
also
you don't know how that's gonna turn out
because we saw what Babylon fall oh that
was it that game was done in years so
yeah so it's it's rough out there but uh
I think it's just a combination of like
the
the market correcting stuff like Ben
Smith Ben said and uh you know the
inflation issue is creating all these
like multiple effects at the same time
no doubt launched I don't know what's
170 games which I was all taking fewer
sales
yeah I think everybody's head out of the
park so far it's just there's a number
of different factors you know when you
when you think about the fact that you
know Sony's expanded what PS plus used
to be
um if you're someone who doesn't get
fomo for day one purchases you're gonna
be like okay I'll just wait till it
comes to PS plus even if it's a year or
two later like it's just a reality for a
lot of people like what my mood was
saying inflation is a big issue and
honestly a lot of people apart from the
hardcore they're not worried about
getting a game day one they don't really
care so you know they're more than happy
to wait whatever the time it is for it
to go into the into the service and and
now since it's been expanded and they're
asking more money of people the truth of
the matter is it's only has to put it
into the service sooner than they would
have liked right you know
um so yeah that's that's one aspect of
it
I think another aspect of it is what you
guys have been saying in terms of the
service based games as well again when
you think about
you know the fortnites of the world and
then the free-to-play games and stuff of
that nature the money's going into those
games and people aren't you know unless
you're you're a hardcore person that
really loves that you know on the
PlayStation side third person action
game you know character action game on
the Xbox side to shoot or whatever the
case may be
um you're not
you're willing to put money into those
games that are that are technically free
right but not necessarily care about
buying that 70 experience that may be a
finite experience right and and once
you're done with it you're done with it
right uh it's a different sort of
perception about what value is now so
yeah I mean that's just the reality of
it I don't really know
I don't really know that that's going to
change it's weird though right because
again us growing up
70 games were something that you just
said at the time
you know what's funny just just the
other day I was looking at somebody uh
on Twitter put out uh just an old lady
like an old player flyer an old like KB
Toy Stores or Toys R Us flyer right it
was 150 which one are you picking and it
was on one page it was the N64 the other
page was the PlayStation right and it is
one of those things whereas I was
looking at the prices especially for the
for the N64 games you didn't see it so
much on the PlayStation side they were
pretty good about keeping the games 50
bucks but on the on the um what you
would call it on the N64 side they were
selling Doom 64. yeah for 74.99 Wow
insane when you think about it right
74.99 so yeah it's just it's just
different man and again 70 bucks
some may see it as a little bit of money
some may see it as a lot of money it's
just gonna be it's one of those things
going to take a while to normalize yeah
but I think with all the other options
in play you're just gonna see Less sales
and that's it you know it's just that's
just going to be the reality of it but
again as prices go up the revenues will
go up even though you're selling less
physical copies right
um and now the pixel open stuff yeah I
just think it's uh it's a sign of the
times and what's you know the shift that
we're seeing at Sony specifically when
it comes to these smaller sort of Indie
like games they're only going to hold on
to so many studios in that regard and
basically pixel Opus hasn't really done
anything since concrete Genie which came
out in like 2019
um and then they were working on
something with Sony Pictures apparently
and I don't know if that's just been
mixed completely or if it's going to be
moved to another team but again they
haven't
for whatever reason whatever was going
on in there wasn't necessarily important
enough that Sony felt they needed to
continue you know supporting the studio
um but it's sad because when you look at
when you look at media molecule they're
still around right and I don't know how
long that'll last but at the very least
they've said they're already working on
the next thing
um obviously 45 yeah exactly probably so
right probably you would hope that
they're working on an actual game right
and I don't I don't want to hear about
tools and any of this
I thought dreams was great but dreams
despite being great
just the entire thinking behind it and
how they were going to utilize that game
was just off completely like you can't
have a game that's a creation tool that
is completely siled off on a console and
just everything from the way you share
you know the content that's being put on
there creators not being able to export
their stuff and what I think the biggest
bonehead move is not putting that game
on PC and letting the PC Community run
with it it was just very weird that that
they were allowed to make that game and
continue to support it and it not being
something that ever really stuck
um so again it's and to me you know when
you think about media molecule at least
to this point and then you think about
like Japan studio and and uh Sobo right
yeah
um
they're still holding on to those
Studios the astrobot studios and things
in 90. so I think that's as small as
they're going to stay I don't think and
and somebody had to go it's sad because
pixel Opus again it's it's a type of
small sort of developer that I think
they should have you know internally but
again you have all these other sort of
games coming out I know they plan to
make more Acquisitions however big or
small they may be and I think it's going
to be telling uh the types of games that
these these Studios that they eventually
acquire are making because I think
they're going to be a deviation from
what we expect I agree I agree yeah so
it's sad to see but I I think the
writing was sort of on the wall at least
for one of these Studios I'm surprised
it wasn't media molecule molecule but
again it is what it is I could very
easily see with pixel Opus being so
small I think the last we knew was like
20 people probably oh okay so like on
one hand it's like well it's 20 people
let them just do their thing yeah on the
other hand it's like well there are 20
people just roll them into another
Studio make sure yeah good point but the
thing I was thinking is they're working
on that you know that Sony Pictures
thing and Sony pictures as we know
they're like ramping up production
they're making stuff left and right
they're really getting involved in a lot
of stuff so it wouldn't surprise me if
they said okay well you were working on
this since you finished concrete Genie
and now that we're really getting into
this space more we want it to be a
bigger project so we're going to move it
to somebody who's bigger who's bigger
and now we don't need you whether they
keep them or not who knows I it wouldn't
surprise me if that's a reason because
since concrete Genie came out it's not
like they've been making them extra
money right so there had to be something
recent semi-recent I think uh or they
just maybe it's the opposite they saw
the game it was it wasn't good and they
just decided to scrap the team out if
this is all speculation but just it it
makes perfect sense to me even though it
sucks that the studio is closing a cute
little Studio too yeah yeah I mean it's
a I'll jump in it was interesting to see
to hear about that I will say that to do
what about Islam could you imagine if
XBox hit that a studio right oh man oh
boy the headlines have been crazy hello
rake yeah yeah they shut down the studio
the same week that they purchased a
studio
there would be interest I had I had to
do it just for the the hilarity of the
headlines would be interesting but the
champ gets away with it because he's the
champion yeah and that's how it goes you
know what I'm saying you know that's the
reality of the business and the fact
that you know I do agree with King that
there is a shift you know um internally
as far as Jim Ryan's Vision I feel you
know I've seen we've seen some instances
of it I get I don't know all the details
of what happened with pixel Opus you
know I could only go by looking at Sean
Laden's comments I don't know if you
guys saw that Sean Lane actually
responded and he was like yeah he said
I'm not gonna lie this is a deep cut he
said I so love working with this team
and watching them level up to deliver
the genre busting concrete Genie all
while maintaining a culture of support
inclusion and challenge now a new
adventure awaits I win the very best to
every team member so you could tell this
really hit Sean but again Sean is the
old regime it is I think that was like
one of his picks yeah I think he said
that he cultivated a lot of people get
stuff uh
mm-hmm
it's like with any type of leadership or
you know like uh
traversal of power like Pastor baton
that person for the first couple of
years
all the stuff that was done is
benefiting from the past yeah like a
coach from the old President right you
know the old coach or whatever you know
um be it good or be it bad right right
correct and Sean did a lot of good I
don't know where he earned his spot at
PlayStation and you know things happen
but you can tell that he was always for
the theatrics he was always for oh check
this game out he said Gravity Rush these
games
and
I don't think those games happen on the
gym it's not at all it's it's a valid
point it's a valid point and again this
is where not to again make everything
about Xbox but this is why I do think
Xbox overall strategy
is correct I do think because you have
those weird titles those Indie titles or
stuff it's just that we get a lot of
them and then we went to AAA right and
then with sodi it's like you're getting
the AAA but you're not getting the
multiplayer just yet I know they're
shifting and then we see them shifting
away from kind of like these quirky
these Indie these creative titles that
kind of gave the PlayStation that flavor
right they gave it that that thing that
a lot of people like and it is
interesting I will agree with King in
the sense that I don't think this is
part of the ship Ryan you know
philosophy and and it goes to show
because one thing I will criticize
PlayStation on consistently is that you
know I've had this conversation with
Colin man which is like
it's only so many times now you're gonna
keep going to the well all right Last of
Us Last of Us rematch and Last of Us
rematch the rematch The Last of Us
faction like we get it
Blockbuster we get it the movie we get
it but it's like I understand you're
going for the money but at some point
there can be fatigue in hashtag just one
there can be fatigue with that stuff and
I want to see a little bit of the old
Sony which is yo we had it so calm we
had a Killzone we had these little Indie
you know kind of quirky games even you
pulled out Parappa to rap like sticks
things like that that existed at one
point I remember jumping Flash and
remember all that stuff you don't say
like yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying like I
remember that stuff you know the
wipeouts I used to love that with
psychnosis
that's that creative Sony again I don't
want them where it's just all only
this type of game we're focused on and
that's it so I can give criticism there
you know we'll see as far as the um 70
game metric I will push back on Kick a
little bit only in the sense that I just
feels this is working for them yeah like
it's their model I just think it's like
yo we're gonna take a very measured
approach we're gonna raise this price
but we're going to take a very measured
approach on how we adopt into any games
as a service kind of a thing and as far
as a subscription service and to them
it's like even the way they handle the
PC things it's like no we're going to
get this console money we're going to
saturate we're going to suck this dry
pause and then from there we're going to
then say okay now that we've maximized
all weekend out of console Revenue right
now when it's out of the cycle you guys
get Horizon the first one now you get
God of War the first one you know what
I'm saying and then we double back on
the back end and you know to their
credit it's working but I do think long
term yes Xbox is correct but sometimes
like does jump out a little too early
sometimes too so we got to see how this
plays out but yeah interesting news you
know on Sony and see how this thing
works out but also my man Philip
Carlisle in the building I see you
brother Saloon good to see you but
that's all I got anybody got anything
else on these two topics as far as the
studio and all this other stuff because
we have been here long let us get you
want to switch out when we get the polls
and we get the super chats real quick
very cool
um hold on a second then actually don't
get that yeah go ahead all right go
ahead
you must be the mayor if he wasn't you
know holding it down
five hours he said this is light work
yeah this is a look we gotta get to the
pole with Phil Spencer's latest comments
regarding not attempting to out console
PlayStation Nintendo which strategy do
you think Xbox needs to adopt moving
forward the choices are a stick to the
long-term plan of play Anywhere
Acquisitions and The Game Pass model B
remain committed to Quality AAA games to
make your services more attractive or
see I don't care that showcases
Starfield better be 11 out of 10.
Ben Smith Last Stand media marathon in
the building family is in the building
it's great to see you I'd love to see
you get your Sean yeah man it's great
great to see you great to see you get
your shot because you like to quiet in
the cut that makes this the magic sauce
happen nobody don't really know about
you so let the people know where they
can find you what you got going on sir
uh you can find me on Twitter uh Ben
Smith 2588 my name is too generic to
just have my name so I have some numbers
after it gotta spice it up a little bit
and spice that up it looks like a bot
account but yeah
probably the most um probably the other
place uh Ben is handsome on YouTube
let me go get that bed we can put that
link in there that bed is handsome in
there go subscribe to the channel man my
man out here moving and grooving a lot
of good content go check him out we're
gonna get that in there so if you're
gonna get the super chat so I'll do that
yes you okay we got Lord Metroid member
for one year two dollars of the chat at
Nintendo's headquarters the game of the
year is here Execute Order 60. you ready
you ready you ready you ready I love it
a couple of days away it's over after
those two weeks go back to nothing
wrong
then we got Boyd lock member for one
year five dollars to be chat we wait on
sales for PlayStation game pass on Xbox
Nintendo by day one but no bugs but bad
Graphics though damn how is that not a
bug oh my bad like how is the whole
system itself just not one big giant
book oh come on don't do that don't do
that to him like that there's still one
day one three years later as well
true let's see and we got hargit Cindy
remember for one year two dollar Super
Chat what's everyone's meta prediction
for Zelda mm-hmm
my bull protection 93 93. it'd be crazy
that joint coming at a 60 seconds
stop it wow we got JD game remember for
two years five dollars Super Chat so
when he's running towards a
service-based feature as fast as they
can snitching to delay Microsoft but
that won't work even with the 10 to 12
games in the service in development oh
it looks like they hit Microsoft car
keys while they was running out
there we got JD game for again five
dollars Super Chat let's make this
simple for every PlayStation fan Game
Pass works and it's the profitable more
profitable than single unit sales if it
wasn't PlayStation would not be
snitching oh my God they knew Call of
Duty they know what Call of Duty
yo y'all don't really know what y'all
are worth
Sony told PlayStation fans you all
aren't enough we want more there's a
reason their largest purchase was bungee
in the end Services pay more than 70
games
I'll figure it out at the end of the day
Y'all Gonna realize exactly where you
truly stand
in quicksand oh okay
Robert Kelly Two Dollars in the chat
it's only always cuts off the weak links
sadly
sometimes you cut off your nose despite
your face and you lose your identity and
you don't no longer look the same and
I'm gonna tell you right now real
recognize real and you looking mighty
unfamiliar to me oh man
that we have JD gave up again dating
going in today 37. hello in France
PlayStation in two years is not gonna be
the PlayStation we all grew up with so
forget about that PS fans you'll get
those same four bangers over and over
until they're tired of the 44 games
they turn into the Halo gears and forces
the big back launch rise of the shake
that's what we're doing I cannot wait
for you dudes to be over there like come
on man I want something different new
you guys do some work on your
interpretational skills man
thank you sir good Lord
don't you put that evil on me Ricky
Bobby
I'll give you the stink eye you hurt I
see you we are caught up no doubt again
thanks everyone in the room pulling up
legendary Ben Smith Mark moon in the
building salute oh man where can I find
people find you what you got going on
there yeah you can find me at Lords of
game and of course editing and doing all
the writing I'm working on a new
jousting article to respond to
yesterday's uh spicy taste nice nice
yeah so it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
fun and you can find me you can find me
on Twitter at uh wayhick w-a-y-h-i-k
yeah my man salute the EIC lawyer
gaming.net in the building you already
know that blue check though
I heard you do verified in these streets
Elon yeah
just try open return a lot of preaching
the realm was it was they was right it
was solve all body today I had to beat
back that song hard stuff man
you know just
moving on myself making it up
we got Stitch Zelda meta should be
around a ten seventy dollars for 480p
the audacity of these dudes [__] do not
like the switch at all
yeah you can find me in going to work as
I always do you know right after this
but um yeah big shout out to my boot for
coming through yes uh still hasn't I'm
sure he still hasn't received the last
thing that he was supposed to receive
from his uh yeah
exactly
it'll arrived then and shout out to bed
man I got the pleasure of meeting Ben at
the first Last Stand of event over in
Butler
um grace is enough to have me there and
it was it was a good time man it was a
good time Ben is is that dude behind the
scenes that you know he's the MC he's
making sure everything is taken care of
and it's funny because no he was he was
the mayor at that time and he was giving
out the keys of the city
but I always laugh because I you know I
I talked to him briefly because he was
busy right and what the things that he
mentioned today that I gleaned from my
conversation I was like Ben has you know
he's a businessman he owns a lot of
these so so when we after the show we
went down to the Speakeasy that was like
underneath the theater and it was fine
far and everything so I was like oh man
this place is awesome and Ben's like
thank you
thank you for my establishment for my
establishment and then I forgot how the
conversation got there but then he told
me about the brewery that was his too
I was like oh yeah I was like okay mayor
Nucky Thompson
I was like I'm sure that voting was on
the opening up you know don't do that
don't you do that
I'll be your chalky white
it was funny in that moment I thought of
like you remember Roadhouse Brad Wesley
from Roadhouse
JC Penney's coming here because of me
listen man I know what I came through I
was good at the town baby
[Music]
you're so gracious uh and absolutely The
Rock The Rock of Last Air so thank you
so much brother I appreciate it for
coming through man thanks for having me
the legendary and of course the king
rattle enough to troops getting us ready
we was ready for war we didn't know
where he was going with this but it was
ready I mean he got everybody round up
okay we could find people find you what
you got going on first and foremost
I would like to uh thank our esteem
right of the month yes in our 16th
so much
I saw somebody uh get a little bit upset
with a um article that was up because it
didn't show not like this
dude have an opinion silence in America
God forbid he can't have freedom no
they're pulled the season on us he was
like
you know King what do you think of it
you must you must silence him
yo
I just say that uh at loads of
gaming.net
we Champion diversity yes
and for you to have your opinions
without being pointed towards somebody
like I said something today and I was
going in on Pete Hines and who
not knowing that as Pete Hines it was
part of satire right and somebody's
going to take it out of context
sometimes I don't bite and put it up and
be like he's calling for Pete Heinz job
no I'm not I don't call for anybody's
job actually I want everybody to have a
job I want the concrete Genie team to
hopefully move on to another team and
that stuff doesn't get closed out oh
with that said
Ben I've heard so much about you
and didn't get a chance to meet the man
I've heard like they they was amazed
with you like it was some trinket like
some something down like like like you
like you was a McGuffin yeah right he
was like he's the mayor he's handing out
keys he does this he does that and guess
what we went down to a speakeasy and it
was his and then you know we had the he
has a bureau
I'm like this guy sounds amazing
and then you met me and you were
disappointed no no I wasn't okay okay
now I wasn't disappointed at all because
it was something that you said
game and be the mayor
if somebody tried to make it along the
lines of you had to choose one of the
two and you said why not do both
you know great people do both
you know you have Bo Jackson playing
football and baseball great at both
Manny Pacquiao Senator and boxer both
you didn't limit yourself
your brain operates on both sides of the
hemisphere both you have the PlayStation
right then you have the Xbox right there
and that is that encompasses you
so you know I hope you didn't take
offense to anything on my PlayStation
and I know you didn't because you know
it's sat Tire yeah I know you guys are
Last Stand media you guys are crazy over
there so
you hated jokes and stuff like that and
I just want to say it was a great
experience meaning the man that you know
and you lived up to the legend of the
guy well I appreciate it thanks thank
you there's no doubt so look another
winner give you Final Super Chat so let
me roll because they're gonna try okay
brother even pull it out man it was yeah
you know I mean everybody said they love
to him legit that was awesome for real
legitly yes yes so I'll put a couple
more food yeah we got a couple more we
got a sagging nut sack two pounds Super
Chat night fellas King tell your guy to
shut up
we talk about
don't tell the truth
there we go JD gamer ten dollar Super
Chat somebody out here doing exactly
what Microsoft is doing how many times
you're gonna let the LIE they let them
lie to you only to turn around and do
what they said they wouldn't do hashtag
I believe in Generations oh man we go
there look we're good appreciate y'all
this was a long show but a lot of fun
appreciate everybody being receptive
again the mayor Ben Smith mock move
fromage addict the whole crew Everybody
enjoy your Sunday we got more fun stuff
planned this month fun show [__]
[Music]
foreign